hey guys welcome back to another video
by simply learn in today's video we're
going to be learning all about the two
most commonly used databases that is
mongodb and sql but before we begin
let's look at a quick introduction to
database now a database is information
that is set up for easy access
management and updation computer
databases typically store aggregations
of data records or files that contain
information such as sales transactions
customer data finances and product
information databases are used for
storing maintaining and accessing any
sort of data they collect information on
people places or things that information
is gathered in one place so that it can
be observed and analyzed now in short
databases can be thought of as an
organized collection of information some
of the main features of using database
includes improving business processes
keeping track of customers secure
personal health information and storage
of personal data now there are several
different types of databases available
there's relational databases nosql
databases object-oriented databases
distributed databases and so on in this
video we will learn about two commonly
used databases that is sql which is a
relational database and mongodb which is
a nosql database but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button and the bell icon to never miss
an update now without further ado let's
begin
first let's look at what's in store for
you with respect to sql
this session will help you write sql
commands using mysql postgresql as well
as sql server
our highly experienced trainers will
take you through this course so here's
what's in store for you
first we'll start by learning the basics
of sql along with understanding entity
relationship diagrams
then you will learn how to install mysql
workbench on windows
we'll then look at the popular sql
commands to select insert update delete
records and perform other operations on
database tables
you will also see how to use the top
numerical and text functions in sql
next we will cover how to use group by
and having clauses in sql followed by
joins
you'll learn the different types of join
statements as well as sub queries in sql
and moving further we'll understand
triggers stored procedures and window
functions in mysql
you will get an idea about another
important topic that is to write sql
queries with python on the jupiter
notebook
then we look at another free and open
source relational database management
system
that is points on demonstration
finally you learn how to become an sql
developer and see the top sql interview
questions that are frequently asked in
the interviews
so these are the topics covered in a
going ahead with respect to mongodb
first you learn what exactly mongodb is
then you look at a simple demonstration
to install mongodb on your windows
system then we'll look at a detailed
mongodb tutorial that explains how to
insert create update and delete data we
look at how to connect mongodb with
different applications and in this case
we'll be connecting mongodb to python
and lastly we'll draw a comparison
between mongodb systems but before we
begin if you haven't subscribed to our
channel already make sure to hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update
so now let's dive right in in this
session we are going to learn about
databases
how data is stored in relational
databases and we'll also look at some of
the popular databases
finally we'll under so according to
oracle a database is an organized
typically stored electronically in a
computer system
a database is usually controlled by a
database management system or dbms
so it is a storage system that has a
collection of data
relational databases store data in the
form of tables that can be easily
retrieved managed and updated
you can organize data into tables rows
columns and index it to make it easier
to find relevant information now talking
about some of the popular databases
we have mysql database we also have
oracle database then we have mongodb
which is a nosql database
next we have microsoft sql server next
we have apache cassendra which is a free
and open source nosql database and
finally we have postgresql
now
let's learn
what is sql so sql is a domain specific
language to communicate with databases
sql was initially developed by ibm
most databases use structured query
language or sql for writing and querying
data sql commands help you to store
process analyze and manipulate databases
with this
let's look at what a table is
table in a database looks like
so here you can see
the name of the table is players
on the top you can see the column names
so we have the player id the pro and we
also have the goals scored by each of
the players so these are also known as
fields in a database
here
each row represents a record or a tuple
so if you have the player id which is
103 here the name of the player is it
doesn't require much coding to manage
databases
now we will see applications of sql
sql is used to create a database define
its structure implement it and lets you
perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data and extracting data
in a database
sql is extensively used as a client
server language to connect the front-end
with the back-end thus supporting the
client-server architecture sql when
deployed as data control language dcl
helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
in this session we will learn who is a
sql developer and what are the
responsibilities in a company
first we will understand who is a sql
developer
sql developer is a person who is
accountable in creating and managing
huge data assets of a company
in other terms sql developer is a person
who can develop sql databases as well as
write and test code
let's understand this with the help of
an example
let's say we want to search a particular
product on amazon website and amazon has
stored all its data about products in a
database now we will write the product
name in the search bar and when we click
on the search button it will run a sql
query that fetches all the information
about the product and displays us on the
website so this is the basic task done
by a sql developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of a sql developer
all databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a sql developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses that is
called database modeling
after the database is created and
deployed it's the sequel developer who
is responsible for fixing the general
issues of the database
sql developer should be well-versed with
structured query language to create
optimized sql queries and refines the
existing ones to extract information
from the database
sql developers run several diagnostic
tests to keep a check on the server and
the database in order to understand how
to organize companies data sql
developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business and sql developer also
gathers client requirements and
identifies the features that the
database owners want
as data is an asset to a company sql
developers backup and restore data for
the clients
they also perform tasks like data
management and data migration that is if
a company has stored all its data on a
local storage and now it wants its data
to be stored in a cloud storage so the
safe transmission of the data from local
storage to cloud storage is known as
data migration and that is done by the
sql developers
after knowing the responsibilities now
should look for skill set required to be
a good sql developer
one should have a good knowledge of sql
commands functions joins and procedures
let's have a look at few commands such
as create drop alter and truncate these
commands come under data definition
language we also have insert update and
delete commands these commands come
under data manipulation language we have
grant and debug commands these commands
come under data control language we also
have commit rollback and save point
commands these come under transaction
control language these are the basic
commands a sql developer should be
familiar with
and a sql developer may have a little
command on any one programming language
you don't have to be expert in
programming all you need is how to
interface between application and your
database for example you are using mysql
and your web application is based on php
then you should know how to connect your
application to the database and how to
issue queries
how to fetch results and then how to
display it to the users
one should have a good understanding of
various database management systems such
as mysql microsoft access oracle postgre
sql dbase foxpro sqlite
ibm db2 libreoffice base mariadb and
microsoft sql server
one should know integration of databases
with data visualization software such as
power bi and tableau which helps
businesses to make better decisions and
give you an add-on as a sql developer
once you develop critical thinking and
problem solving skills to create
optimized queries
now we'll see how a sql developer is
compensated in both united states and
india
in the united states sql developers draw
an average salary of dollar seventy two
thousand two hundred eighty two per
annum in india the average salary of a
sql developer is rupees four lakh forty
nine thousand five hundred thirty two
now we'll see how person can become a
good sql developer for that
one should have a good command on
structured query language and know how
to interact with database management
system and can issue queries to get the
desired result
earning industry recognized sql
developer certifications such as
microsoft certified professional
developer mcpd or oracle pl sql
developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam
and it's important to accumulate as much
practical experience as possible start
by designing creating and querying small
databases connected with your hobbies
and interests for example your favorite
music videos or your personal finances
this will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio which will be highly
beneficial when you start applying for
your first full-time position
now we will see some major companies
recruiting sql developers first we have
the multinational financial services
corporation american express followed by
the multinational professional services
network ernst and young we also have the
messaging company whatsapp then we have
the e-commerce giant amazon as well as
the technology and computer solutions
company dell finally in a list of
companies we have the multinational
technology company google in this
session we will learn about ear diagram
have you ever wondered how these big
ecommerce companies manage their tons of
data that keeps updating every second
and these data sets keep on updating in
their databases to perform operations on
this data they should have a conceptual
understanding of these databases and
this is done by understanding er
diagrams of the databases
so let's understand what an er diagram
is
an entity relationship diagram
describes the relationship of entities
that needs to be stored in a database
er diagram is mainly a structural design
for the database it is a framework made
using specialized symbols to define the
relationship between entities er
diagrams are created based on the three
main components entities attributes and
relationships
let's understand the use of er diagram
with the help of a real-world example
here a school needs all its student
records to be stored digitally so they
approach an id company to do so
a person from the company will meet the
school authorities not all their
requirements describe them in the form
of ear diagram and get it closed checked
by the school authorities as the school
authorities approved the ear diagram the
database engineers would carry further
implementation
let's have a view of an ear diagram
the following diagram showcases two
entities student and course and the
relationship
the relationship described between
student and course is many to many as a
course can be opted by several students
and a student can opt for more than one
course here student is the entity and it
possesses the attributes that is student
id student name and student age
and the course entity has attributes
such as course id and course name
now we have an understanding of er
diagram let us see why it has been so
popular
the logical structure of the database
provided by er diagram communicates the
landscape of business to different teams
in the company which is eventually
needed to support the business
year diagram is a gui representation of
the logical structure of a database
which gives a better understanding of
the information to be stored in a
database database designers can use er
diagrams as a blueprint which reduces
complexity and helps them save time to
build databases quickly
ear diagrams helps you identify the
entities that exist in a system and the
relationships between those entities
after knowing its uses now we should get
familiar with the symbols used in ear
diagram
the rectangle symbol represents the
entities overall symbol represents
attributes a rectangle embedded in a
rectangle represents a weak entity a
dashed oval represents a derived
attribute a diamond symbol represents a
relationship among entities double oval
symbol represents multivalued attributes
now we should dive in and learn about
the components of er diagram
there are three main components of fear
diagram entity attribute
and relationship
entities have weak entity attributes are
further classified into key attribute
composite attribute multi-valued
attribute and derived attribute
relationships are also classified into
one-to-one relationships one-to-many
relationships many-to-one relationships
and to many relationships
let's understand these components of
rear diagram
starting with entities
an entity can be either a living or a
non-living component an entity is
showcased as a rectangle in an er
diagram
let's understand this with the help of
an ear diagram here both student and
course are in rectangular shape and are
called entities
and they represent the relationship
study in a diamond shape
let's transition to weak entity
an entity that makes airlines over
another entity is called a weak entity
the weak entity is showcased as a double
rectangle in er diagram
in the example below
the school is a strong entity because it
has a primary key attribute school
number
unlike the school the classroom is a
weak entity because it does not have any
primary key and the room number
attribute here acts only as a
discriminator and note of primary key
now let us know about attributes
attribute
an attribute exhibits the properties of
an entity an attribute is illustrated
with an oval shape in an er diagram in
the example below
student is an entity and the properties
of student such as address age name and
role number are called its attributes
let's see our first classification under
attribute
that is key attribute
the key attribute uniquely identifies an
entity from an entity set
the text of a key attribute is
underlined in the example below
we have a student entity and it has
attributes name address row number and
age but here roll number can uniquely
identify a student from a set of
students
that's why it is termed as a key
attribute
now we will see composite attribute
an attribute that is composed of several
other attributes is known as a composite
attribute and oval showcases the
composite attribute and the composite
attribute oval is further connected with
other roles
in the example below we can see an
attribute name
which can have further subpart such as
first name middle name and last name
these attributes with further
classification is known as composite
attribute
now let's have a look at multivalued
attribute an attribute that can possess
more than one value are called
multivalued attributes these are
represented as double oval shape
in the example below the student entity
has attributes phone number roll number
name and age out of these attributes
phone number can have more than one
entry and the attribute with more than
one value is called multivalued
attribute
let's see derived attribute
an attribute that can be derived from
other attributes of the entity is known
as a derived attribute in the er diagram
the derived attribute is represented by
dashed over and in the example below
student entity has both date of birth
and age as attributes here age is a
derived attribute as it can be derived
by subtracting current date from the
student date of birth
now after knowing attributes let's
understand relationship in er diagram
a relationship is showcased by the
diamond shape in the ear diagram it
depicts the relationship between two
entities in the below example student
study course here both student and
course are entities and studies the
relationship between them
now let's go through the type of
relationship
first is one-to-one relationship when a
single element of an entity is
associated with a single element of
another entity this is called one-to-one
relationship
in the example below we have student and
identification card as entities we can
see a student has only one
identification card and an
identification card is given to one
student it represents a one-to-one
relationship
let's see the second one one-to-many
relationship when a single element of an
entity is associated with more than one
element of another entity is called
one-to-many relationship
in the below example a customer can
place many orders but a particular order
cannot be placed by many customers
now we will have a look at many to one
relationship
when more than one element of an entity
is related to a single element of
another entity it is called many-to-one
relationship for example students have
to opt for a single course but a course
can be obtained by a number of students
let's see many-to-many relationship
when more than one element of an entity
is associated with more than one element
of another entity is called many-to-many
relationship
for example an employee can be assigned
to many projects and many employees can
be assigned to a particular project
now after having an understanding of pr
diagram let us know the points to keep
in mind while creating the er diagram
first identify all the entities in the
system embed all the entities in a
rectangular shape and label them
appropriately this could be a customer a
manager an order an invoice a schedule
etc
identify relationships between entities
and connect them using a diamond in the
middle illustrating the relationship do
not connect relationships
connect attributes with entities and
label them appropriately and the
attributes should be in our chip
assure that each entity only appears a
single time and eradicate any redundant
entities or relationships in the ear
diagram
make sure your er diagram supports all
the data provided to design the database
make effective use of colors to
highlight key areas in your diagrams
there are mainly four types of sql
commands
so first we have data definition
language or ddl
so ddl commands change the structure of
the table like creating a table deleting
a table or altering a table all the
commands of ddl are auto committed which
means it permanently save all the
changes in the database
we have create alter drop and truncate
as ddl commands
next
we have data manipulation language or
dml
so dml commands are used to modify a
database it is responsible for all forms
of changes in the database dml commands
are not auto committed which means it
can't permanently save all the changes
in the database
we have select
update
delete and insert as dml commands
now select command is also referred to
as dql or data query language third we
have data control language or dcl
so dcl commands allow you to control
access to data within the database
these dcl commands are normally used to
create objects related to user access
and also control the distribution of
privileges among users
so we have grant and revoke which are
the examples of data control language
finally we have something called as
transaction control language or tcl
so tcl commands allow the user to manage
database transactions commit and roll
back our example of tcl
now let's see the basic sql command
structure so first
we have the select statement
so here you specify the various column
names that you want to fetch from the
table we write the table name using the
from statement
next
we have the where clause to filter out
our table based on some conditions so
you can see here where condition 1
condition 2 and so on
then we have the group by clause that
takes various column names so you can
write group by column 1 column 2 and so
on next we have the having clause to
filter out tables based on groups
finally we have the order by clause to
filter out the result in ascending or
descending order now talking about the
various data types in sql
so we have
exact numeric which has integer small
int bit and decimal
then we have
approximate numeric
which are float and real
then we have some date and time data
type such as date time time stamp and
others
then we have string data type which
includes car this varchar and text
finally we have binary data types
and binary data types have binary
var binary and image
now let's see some of the various
operators that are present in sql
so first we have our basic arithmetic
operators so you have addition the
subtraction multiplication division and
modulus
then we have some logical operators like
all and any or between exists and so on
finally we have some comparison
operators such as equal to not equal to
this greater than less than greater than
equal to or less than equal to not less
than or not greater than now let me take
you to my mysql workbench where we will
learn to write some of the important sql
commands use different statements
functions data types and operators that
we just learned in this session we will
learn how to install mysql workbench and
then we will run some commands
firstly we will visit the official
oracle website that is mysql.com
and now we will move to the downloads
page
now scroll down and click on my sequel
gpl downloads
now under community downloads click on
mysql installer for windows
the current versions are available to
download
i will choose this installer and click
the download button
now here just click on no things just
start my download
once the installer has downloaded open
it
you may be prompted for permission click
yes
this opens the installer
you will be asked to choose the setup
type we will go with custom
click next
now you have to select the products you
want to install
we will install only the mysql server
mysql shell and the my sequel workbench
expand my sql servers by double clicking
on it
and choose the version you want to
install and click on this arrow
now you have to do the same thing for
applications expand applications
and choose the mysql workbench version
you want to install and click on the
arrow
and we'll do the same thing for mysql
shell
and choose the latest version
click on the arrow
these are the products that have to be
installed in a system
now i will click next
now click execute to download and
install the server
this may take a while depending on your
internet speed
as the download is completed
click next
now you see the product configuration
now we will configure our sql server
instance
here we will go with the default
settings and click next
and under authentication select use
strong password encryption for
authentication which is recommended and
click on next
now here set the password for your root
user by the way root is the default user
this user will have access to everything
i will set my password
now i'll click on next
and here also we'll keep the default
settings
and click on next
now to apply configuration we will
execute the process
once all the configuration steps are
complete click finish
now you will see the installation is
complete it will launch my sql workbench
and my sql shell after clicking on
finish
now the shell and workbench has started
now will connect by clicking on the root
user it will ask for a password enter
the password and it will connect
successfully
now the workbench has started
now we'll disconnect the server
so first we'll open command prompt
now we'll reach the path where mysql
files are present
you will go into this pc
local disk c
program files
mysql
mysql server 8.0
bin
and i'll copy this path
now i'll open the command prompt and
write a command cd space
and paste the link and press enter
now i'll write another command that will
be my sequel
minus u
space
root
minus p and press enter now to last for
password
just enter the password
and press enter
now the server has started and now we'll
see some commands in my sql workbench
first we will open my sql workbench
now we'll click on the local instance
mysql 80
and enter the password to connect to the
local host
now the my sequel workbench has started
now we'll see some commands
the first command we will see is show
databases
show databases semicolon
and now we will select the whole command
and click on this execute button
and here we will see the result
in the result grid
these are the databases that are stored
already in the database
now
there are four databases that is
information schema mysql performance
schema and s5s
now i will select one of the database
we'll use
mysql
now we have selected the mysql database
and now in this database we will see
which tables are stored in this mysql
database to see that we will run a
command
show tables
select the command
and click on the execute button
these are the tables that are stored in
this mysql database that is columns
underscore drive component db
and much more
now let me now go ahead and open my
mysql workbench
so in the search bar i'll search for
my sql workbench you can see i'm using
the 8.0 version
i'll click on it and
here it says welcome to mysql workbench
and below under connections you can see
i have already created a connection
which says local instance then you have
the root the local host and the port
number let me click on it
you can see the service the username is
root and i'll enter my password
and hit ok
now this will open the sql editor so
this is how the mysql workbench looks
like
here
we learn
some of the basic sql commands
so first let me show you the databases
that are already present
so the command is so databases
you can hit tab to autocomplete
i'll use a semicolon
i'll select this and here on the top you
can see the execute button so if i run
this
below you can see the output
it says
show databases seven rows are returned
which means
currently there are seven databases
you can see the names
all right
now
let's see i want to see the tables that
are present inside this database called
world
so i'll use the command use
world which is the database name
now let me run it so currently i'm using
the world database
so to display the tables that are
present in the world database i can use
the show command
and write show tables
give a semicolon
and i'll hit ctrl enter this time to run
it
all right so you can see the tables that
are present inside this
world database so we have three tables
in total city country and country
language
now
if you are to see the rows that are
present in one of the tables you can use
the select command
so i'll write select star which
basically means i want to display all
the columns so star here means to
display all the columns
then i'll write my
from
the table name that is
city
so this command is going to display me
all the rows that are present inside the
city table
so if i hit ctrl enter
all right you can see the message here
it says
thousand rows were returned which means
there were total thousand records
present inside the city table
so here you can see there's an id column
a name column this country code district
and population
all right
similarly you can check the structure of
the table by using the describe command
so i'll write describe
and then
i'll give the
table name that is city now let's just
run it
there you go the field shows the column
name so we have id name country code
district population
type here shows the data type of each of
the columns so district is character 20
id is an integer population is also
integer
null says yes or no which means if no
then there are no null values if it's
yes which means there are null values in
your table
key here represents whether you have any
primary key or foreign key
and these are some extra information now
let's learn how to create a table in
mysql so i'll use the create table
command for this and before that
let me create a database
and i'll name it as sql intro so the
command is create
database
and i'll give my database name that is
sql underscore intro
let me give a semicolon and hit ctrl
enter
so you can see i have created a new
database
now
if i run this command that is show
databases
you can see this
newly created database that is sql intro
if i scroll down
there you go you can see the name here
sql intro
okay now within this database we'll
create a table called employee details
now this will have the details of some
employees
so let me first show you how to create a
table
that will be present inside the sql
intro database
so i'll use the command create
table
and then
i'll give my
table name that is going to be employee
underscore details
next
the syntax is
to give the column names so my first
column would be the name column which is
basically the employee name
followed by
the data type for this column since name
is a text column so i'll use var car
and i'll give a value of 25
so it can hold only 25 characters
okay
next
i also want the age of the employee
now age is always an integer
so i'll give int
ok
then
we can have the gender of the employee
so gender can be represented as f or m f
for female and m for male so i'm using
the car data type or character data type
and i'll give the value as one
then let's have the
date of join
or doj
and this is going to be of data type
date
all right
next
we'll have the city name that is the
city to which the employee belongs to
so again this is going to be varchar
finally we'll have a salary column
and salary we'll keep it as float since
salary can be in
decimal numbers as well
now i will give a semicolon
all right so let me just quickly run
through it so first
i wrote my create command then the table
which is also a keyword
followed by
the table name which is employee details
here and then
we gave the column names such as name
age
this gender
date of join city and salary
for each of the columns we also give the
data type
all right so let me just run it
okay
so here you can see we have successfully
created our first table
now
you can use the
describe command to see the structure of
the table
i'll write describe emp underscore
details
i run this
there you go
so under field you can see the column
names then you have the data types
null represents if the table can accept
null values or not and these are
basically empty
and we haven't set any default
constraint
all right
moving ahead
now let's learn to add data to our table
using the insert command
so on a notepad i have already
written my insert statement so let me
just copy it and then i'll explain it
one by one all right
so if you see this
so we have used an insert into statement
or a command followed by
the table name that is emp details
then this is the syntax using values i
have passed in all the records
so first we have jimmy which is the name
of the employee then we have 35 it
basically represents the age
then m means the gender or the sex
then we have the date of join
next we have the city to which the
employee belongs to and finally we have
the salary of the employee so this
particular information represents one
record or a tuple
similarly the next employee we have is
shane
you can see the age and other
information
then we have
mary this duane sarah and amy
all right
so let me go ahead and
run this
so this will help you insert
the values in the table that you have
created
you can see we have successfully
inserted six records
now
to display the records let me
use the select statement so i am using
select star from emp underscore details
if i run this
you can see my table here and the values
it has
so we have the name column the age
column the state of join city salary
and these are the values that you can
see here
moving ahead now let's say you want to
see the unique city names present in the
table
so in this case you can use the distinct
keyword along with the column name in
the select statement so let me show you
how you can print the distinct
city names that are present in our table
now if you notice this table clearly
we have chicago seattle boston austin
this new york and there's seattle
repeated again so i only want to print
the unique values
so for that i can write my select
statement as select
distinct
then i'll give my column name which is
city from
my table name that is emp details
if i run this
you can see
my query has returned five rows and
these are the values so we have chicago
seattle which was repeated twice it's
just been shown once then we have boston
austin and new york now let's see how
you can use inbuilt
aggregate functions in sql
so suppose you want to count the number
of employees in the table for in that
case you can use the count function in
the select statement so let me show you
how to do that
so i'll write
select
i'll use my function name that is count
now since i want to know the total
number of employees i am going to use
their name
inside the brackets from
employee underscore details
now if i run this
this will return the total number of
employees that are present in the table
so we have 6 employees in total
now if you see here in the result it
says count name now this column is
actually not readable at all
so what sql provides is something called
as an alias name so you can give an
alias to the resultant output so here i
can write select count of name
and use an alias as
as
i can give an alias as
count underscore name
and run this statement again
there you go you can see here in the
resultant
output we have the column name as count
name which was our alias name
now suppose you want to get the total
sum of salaries you can use another
aggregate function called sum
so i'll write my
select statement
and this time instead of count i am
going to write sum and since i want to
find the sum of salaries
so inside the bracket i'll give my
salary column
from
my table name that is employee details
if i run this
this will result in the total sum of
salaries
so basically it adds up
all the salaries that were present in
the salary column
now let's say you want to find the
average salary so instead of sum you can
write the average function which is avg
so this will give you the average salary
from the column
salary so you can see it here this says
average salary now if you want you can
give an alias name to this as well now
you can select specific columns from the
table by using the column names in the
select statement
so initially we were selecting all the
columns for example like
you saw here
the star represents that we want to see
all the columns from the employee
details table
now suppose you want to
see only specific columns you can
mention those column names in the select
statement
so let's say i want to select
just the name
age
and the city column
from my table that is employee details
so this will result
in displaying only the name agent city
column
from the table if i run it there you go
it has given only three columns to me
now sql has a where clause to filter
rows based on a particular condition
so if you want to filter your table
based on specific conditions you can use
where clause now where clause comes
after
you give your table name
so suppose you want to find the
employees
with age greater than 30 in this case
you can use a where clause so let me
show you how to do it
i'll write
select star from
my table name that is
employee
details
and after this i'll use my where clause
so i'll write where
age
greater than
30.
if i run this
it will give me the output where the age
is only greater than 30 so it excluded
everything that is less than 30
so we have four employees whose age is
greater than 30 here
now suppose you want to find only female
employees from the table you can
also use a where clause here
so i'll write
select
let's say i want only the name the
gender which is
sex here
comma city
from my table that is employee details
where
i'll give my column name that is sex is
equal to
since i want only the female employees
i'll give
f
and run this statement
okay you can see here
our employee table has three female
employees
now suppose you want to find the details
of the employees who belong to chicago
or austin in this case you can use the
or operator
now the or operator in sql displays a
record if any of the condition separated
by r is true
so let me show you what i mean
so since i want the employees who are
from chicago and austin
i can use
an or operator so i'll write select star
from
emp details which is my table name
then i'll give my where clause where
city
equal to
i'll give my
city name as cicago
and then i'm going to use the or
operator or
city
equal to
i'll write
austin i'll give a semicolon and let me
run it
there you go
so in the output you can see all the
employees
who belong to the city chicago and
austin
now there is another way to write the
same sql query
so you can use an in operator to specify
multiple conditions
so
let me just copy this
and instead of using the or operator
this time i am going to use the in
operator so i'll delete this
after the where clause i'm going to
write where city
and use the in operator
inside bracket
i'll give my city names as chicago
and i want
austin so i'll give a comma
and write my next city name that is
austin
so this query is exactly the same that
we wrote on top
let me run this
you will get the same output there you
go
so we have jimmy and duane who are from
chicago and austin respectively
now sql provides the between operator
that selects values within a given range
the values can be numbers text or dates
now suppose you want to find the
employees whose date of join was between
1st of jan 2000 and
31st of december 2010
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write select star from
emp details where
my date of join that is doj
between
i'll give my two date values that is
first of
jan
and
i'll give my
second value
the date value that is
31st of december 2010.
so every employee who has joined between
these two dates will be displayed in the
output
if i run it we have two employees who
had joined between
2000 and 2010 so we have jimmy and mary
here who had joined in 2005 and 2009
respectively
all right
now in where clause you can use the and
operator to specify multiple conditions
now the and operator displays a record
if all the conditions separated by and
are true
so let me show you an example
i'll write select star from
employee details table
where
i want the age to be greater than 30
and i want
sex to be
male
all right so here you can see i have
specified two conditions so if both the
conditions are true only then it will
result in an output
if i run it
you can see there are
two employees who are male
and their age is greater than 30.
now let's talk about the group by
statement in sql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows like for example you want to find
the average salary of customers in each
department
now the group by statement is often used
with aggregate functions such as count
sum and average to group the result set
into one or more columns
let's say we want to find the total
salary of employees based on the gender
so in this case you can use the group by
clause
so i'll write select
let's say sex
comma
i want to find the total sum of salary
as
i'll give an alias name let's say
total salary
from my table name that is employee
details
next i am going to group it by sex
ok
let me run it
there you go so we have two genders male
and female and here you can see the
total salary so what this sql statement
did was first it grouped all the
employees based on the gender and then
it found the total salary
now sql provides the order by keyword to
sort the result set in ascending or
descending order
now the order by keyword sorts the
records in ascending order by default to
sort the records in descending order you
can use the desc keyword
so let's say i want to sort my employee
details table
in terms of salary so i'll write select
star from
emp underscore
details
and i'll use my order by clause on the
salary column
so this will sort
all the records
in ascending order of the salary which
is by default you can see
the salary column is sorted in ascending
order
now suppose you want to sort the salary
column
and display it in descending order you
can use this keyword that is desc
let me run it
you can see the output now this time the
salary is sorted in descending order and
you have the other values as well now
let me show you some basic operations
that you can do using the select
statement
so suppose i write select
and
do an addition operation let's say 10
plus 20
and i'll given alias name as addition
if i run this
it will give me the sum of
10 and 20 that is 30. similarly
you can use
the subtraction operator
and you can change the alias name as
let's say subtract
let's run it
you get minus 10.
now there are some basic inbuilt
functions
there are a lot of inbuilt functions in
sql but here i'll show you a few
suppose you want to find the length of a
text or a string you can use the length
function so i'll write select and then
use the length function i'll hit tab to
auto complete let's say i want to find
the length of
country india
and i'll give an alias as total
length
if i run it
you see here it returns 5 because there
are 5 letters
in india
there's another function called repeat
so let me show you how repeat works
so i'll write select
repeat
let's say i want to repeat the symbol
that is at the rate
i'll put it in single quotes because it
is a
text character
and i want to repeat this character for
10 times
close the bracket
and let's run it
you can see here in the output it has
printed at the rate 10 times you can
count it
all right
now let's say you want to convert a text
or a string to uppercase or lowercase
you can do that as well
so i'll write select
and use the function called upper
let's say i want to convert
my string that is india to upper case
i am not giving in any alias name
if i run this
see my input was
capital i and everything else was in
small letter
in the output you can see it has
converted
my input to all caps
similarly you can change this
let's say you want to print something in
lowercase you can use the lower function
let's say
this time everything is in
upper case if i run it
it converts india to lowercase
now let's explore a few date and time
functions let's say you want to find the
current date there's a function called
cur which stands for current
and this is the function i'm talking
about which is current date
if i run this you will get the current
date
that is 28th of jan 2021
and let's say you want to extract the
day from a date value
so you can use
the day function let's say i'll use day
and i want to find the day
from my current date
if i run this
you get 28 which is today's day
now similarly you can also
display the current date and time
so for that you can use a function that
is called now
so this will return the current date and
time
you can see this is the date value and
then we have the current time
all right
and this brings us to the end of our
demo session so let me just scroll
through whatever we have learned so
first
i showed you how you can see the
databases present in mysql then we used
one of the databases and checked the
tables in it then we created another
database called sql intro for our demo
purpose
we used that database and then
we created this table called employee
details with
column names like name integer the sex
date of join city and salary
i showed you the structure of the
database let me run this again so you
get an idea you can see this was the
structure of our table
then we went ahead and inserted a few
records so we inserted
records for six employees so you have
the employee name the age the gender the
date of join the city to which the
employee belongs to and the salary of
the employee
then we saw how you can use the select
statement and display all the columns
present in the table
we learned how you can
display the unique city names
we learnt how to use
different aggregate functions like count
average and sum
then we learnt how you could display
specific columns from the table
we learned how to use where clause
then we used
an or operator we learnt about
inoperator
the between operator
then we used an and operator to select
multiple
conditions
finally
we learnt about group by order by and
some basic
sql operations
now it's time to explore some string
functions in
mysql
so i have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case
so i can write select
the function i'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say
i'll write india
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say upper case
i'll give a semicolon
and let's run it
there you go so my input was in sentence
case and using the upper function we
have converted everything into uppercase
similarly let me just copy this
and
i'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lowercase you can use the lower function
and run this you can see the result
everything is in
lowercase now of course i need to change
the alias name to lowercase
now instead of using
lower as the function there is another
function that mysql provides which is
called the
l case
so i'll just edit this and write l case
and let's see
i'll write
india in
uppercase
let's run it it returns me the same
result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the
length of a string you can use the
character length function
i'll write select
use the function character length
and i'm again going to pass in my
string as india as
let's say total length
let's run it this time i'm going to hit
ctrl enter to run my sql command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because india has 5 characters in
it
now these functions you can also apply
on a table now let me show you how to do
it let's say we already have the
students table
and you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
s2 underscore name
and you can give the same alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is students
if i run this
you can see the output
it has given me
total 20 rows of information
it is not readable actually let me also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
i'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so joseph has six
characters niles has six vipul has five
anubhav has seven
similarly if you see akshay has six
tanis cash seven raghav has six
cummins has seven rabada has 6
so on and so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
car length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or care length
now there is another very interesting
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more expressions
together
let's say i'll write select
use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and i'm going to pass in
my
string values let's say india
is
in
asia
let's run this and see our result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable i will give
a space in between so that
you can read it clearly
now this is much more readable india is
in asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's say merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
i'm going to use the same students table
let's say i want to return the student
id
followed by the student name
and then
i am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and i can give an alias as let's say
name underscore age
from
my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here
the result is very clear
we have the student id the student name
and the concatenated column that we
created which was name underscore each
where we have the
student name with the space followed by
the age of the student
if you scroll down you can see the rest
of the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function works
in mysql
so the mysql reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose i write select
reverse
i'll use the same string again let's say
i have
india
let's run it
you will see all the characters printed
in reverse order again you can perform
the same operation on
a table as well let's say i'll write
select
reverse
and i'll pass in the column as student
name
from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been
printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string
within a new substring
so let me show you what i mean
i'll write select
replace
i'll pass in my input string which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect
i am purposely writing this so that i
can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
orange is a fruit
all right
now
mysql also provides some trim functions
you can use the
left trim right trim and just the trim
function
so let me show you how this
left trim works
left trim or l trim removes the leading
space characters from a string passed as
an argument
so say i write select
i'll use the left trim function which is
l trim
and then i'm going to purposely give a
few species
in the beginning of the string i'll give
a word let's say india
and then i'll give some space after the
bird india
and see
how the
l trim works if i run this
it gives me india which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the length of my string
so i'll use my
length function here
and
within this function i am going to
find the length of my string which has
india along with some
leading and trailing spaces i'll paste
this here
give a semicolon and i'll run it
okay
so the entire string is
characters long or the length of the
string is 17
now say i use l trim on my same string
what it returns me is india
and if i
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see
how many spaces were deleted from the
left of the string you can see here
now it says
and
i'm going to use ltrim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so 17 minus
five is
12 which is correct similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these pieces
when you use left trim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace l trim with
r trim which stands for right trim
and see the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here
if i just write trim
and i'll
run it
it gives me five because india is total
five characters long and it has deleted
all the leading and the trailing spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in mysql the position function returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substring in a string
so if the substring is not found with
the original string the function will
return zero
so let's say i'll write select
position
i want to
find
where
fruit is
in my string that is
orange
is
a
fruit
i'll give an alias as name
the sum error here
this should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place
or at the 13th position we have the word
fruit in our string which is oranges of
fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ascii
so the ascii function returns the ascii
value for a specific character
let's say i write select
ascii
of
the letter small a
if i run this
it will give me the ascii value which is
let's say you want to find the ascii
value
of
let's see the result
it gives me
52.
all right
in this session we are going to learn
two important sql statements or clauses
that are widely used that is grouped by
and having
first we'll understand the basics of
group by and having and then
jump into mysql workbench to implement
these statements so let's begin
first
what is group by in sql
so the group by statement or clause
groups records into summary rows and
returns one record for each group it
groups the rows with the same group by
item expressions and computes aggregate
functions for the resulting group
a group by clause is a part of select
expression in each group no two rows
have the same value for the grouping
column or columns
now below
you can see the syntax of group by
so first we have the select statement
and then followed by the column names
that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition and next
we have the group by clause
and here we include the column names
finally we have the order by and the
column names
now here is an example of the group by
clause
so we want to find the average salary of
employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee id
the employee name
the age of the employee we have the
gender
the date on which the employer joined
the company then we have the department
to which each of these employees belong
to we have the city to which the
employees belong to and then we have the
salary in dollars
so actually we'll be using this
employees table on mysql workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your
sql query with group by clause would
look like so we have selected department
and then we are using an aggregate
function that is avg which is average
and
we have chosen the salary column and
here we have given an alias name which
is average underscore salary which
appears in the output you can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see
we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department
now let me take you to my mysql
workbench where we will implement group
by and solve specific problems
okay so i am on my mysql workbench so
let me make my connection first
i'll enter the password
so this will open my sql editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that i have
so i'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here
i'm going to use my
sql underscore intro database so i'll
write
use
sql underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database i'll run it
all right
now you can check the
tables that are present in sql
underscore intro database
if i write show tables you can see the
list of
tables that are already present in this
database to do our demo and understand
group by as well as having let me first
create an employee table
so i'll write create table
employees
next
i'll give my column name as employee
underscore id which is
the id for each employee
i'll give my data type as integer and
i'll assign
employee id as my primary key
next i'll give
employee underscore name
and my data type would be
varchar
i'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then i have
my gender column
i'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1.
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
department column as well this is going
to be of
varchar
and 20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally
we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees
okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
i'll write describe
employees you can see
the structure of the table so far
all right now it's time for us to insert
a few records into this employees table
so i'll write
insert
into
employees
and i'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my emp notepad and you can
see i have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
will paste it here
all right
let me go to the top and verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information
or the records that are present in our
employees table
i'll write select star from employees if
i run it you can see here
i have my employee id the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
incided 20 records
now
let me run a few sql commands to check
how the structure of our table is let's
say i want to see the distant cities
that are present in our table
so i'll write select distinct city from
employees
if i run this
you see here there are total
eight different cities present in our
employees table so we have
chicago the shuttle boston we have new
york
miami and detroit as well
now let's see
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present
so you can use distinct department
if i run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
names so we have sales marketing product
tech i.t finance and hr
all right
now let me show you
another sql command now this is to use
an aggregate function
so i want to find the
average age of all the employees from
the table
so i can write
select
avg which is the
aggregate function for average
inside that i have passed my
age column from employees if i run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is 33.35
now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
i'll give a comment here i want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
i'll write select
department
comma
i'll write
average of age
from
employees
group by
department
now if i run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left
and on the right you can see the average
age of employees in each of these
departments now you can see here
in the output it says evg of each which
is not readable so i can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
i can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
i'll use a round function before the
average function
and
the round function takes two parameters
one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if i run this
there you go you can see here we have
the
average age of all the employees in each
of these departments
all right
now suppose
you want to find the total salary of all
the employees for each department
so
you can write select
department
comma
now i want the total salary so i'll use
the sum function
and i'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
group by
department
let's run this query
you can see here in the output we have
the different departments
and on the right you can see the total
salary of all the employees in each of
these departments
now here also you can give an alias name
as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the
output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by clause
along with the group by clause
let's say you want to find the total
number of employees in each city and
group it in the order of employee id so
to do this i can use my select query
i'll write select
count of let's say employee id
and i want to
know the city as well
from
employees
group by
city
and next
you can use the order by clause
i'll write order by
count of
employee id
and i'll write desc which stands for
descending
if i
run this query
you can see here
on the left you have the count of
employees
and on the right you can see the
city names so in chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had seattle houston
boston
austin and the remaining also had two
employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee id
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that join the company each
year
we can use the year function on the date
of joining column
then we can count the employee ids and
group the result by each year
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select
i'm going to extract here from the date
of join column
i'll give an alias as year
next
i'll
count the
employee
id from my table name that is
employees
and
i am going to group it by
year
date of join
i give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
great you see here in the result we have
the year that we have extracted from the
date of join column and on the right you
can see the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was
one employee similarly we have in 2009
there were two employees
if you scroll down you have information
of other years as well
now if you want you can
order this as well based on year or
count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so
to show you this operation let me first
create a sales table
so i'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product id
which is going to be
of integer type
then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be a
float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so i'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have
the state in which the item was sold
and state i'll put it as var car and
give the size as 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so i've already written
the records in a notepad let me show you
okay so here you can see i have my
sales text file let me just copy these
information
i'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted nine
rows of information
so
let me just
run it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product id column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold then we have the
quantity that was sold and in which
state it was sold so we have california
texas alaska
then we have
another product
id which is one two three
these are the states in which
the products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement i'll write select star
from
sales
where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose
you want to find the revenue for both
the product ids
one two one and let's say one two three
since we have just two product ids here
so for that you can use the select query
so i'll write select
product id
next
i want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but
selling price multiplied by the quantity
so i'll use the sum function to find the
total revenue
and inside the sum function i'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
my quantity column
i'll give this
an alias name as revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally i'll group it by
product id
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product ids one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated
from these two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that i'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
i'll write create table
let's say the table name is c product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
i'll
give my first column as product id
this will be an integer
and i'll have my second column as cost
price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this
so we have successfully created our
product cost table
now let me
insert a few values into the c product
table so i'll write insert into
c underscore
product
i'll give
my values
for one to one let's see the
cost price was
270 dollars
for each
and next we have my
product as one two three
and let's say the cost price for product
one two three was
two hundred and fifty dollars
let's insert these two values okay
next we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the
products
so i'll write select
c dot
product underscore id
comma
i'll write
sum
s dot cell underscore price now here c
and s are alias names
so if i subtract my
cost price from the selling price
that will return the profit that was
generated
i'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
i'll give an alias name as
profit
from
sales as s
so here s stands for the sales table
i am going to use
inner join
c underscore
product table
as
the alias name should be c
where
s dot
product underscore id is equal to
c dot
product underscore id
we are using product underscore id
because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
i am going to
group it by
c dot product underscore id
all right
so let me tell you what i have done here
so i am selecting the product id
next i am calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and i have multiplied
the quantity column
i am using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and i am joining on the
column that is product id and i have
grouped it by c dot product id
let's run this there you go so here you
can see for product id one to one
we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars
and for product id one two three
we made a profit of
eight hundred and forty dollars so now
that we have learnt group by in detail
let's learn about the having clause in
sql
the having clause in sql operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where clause are kind
of similar but where clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the where
conditions next we have the group by
finally we have having
and at last we have order by column
names so you can see here we have a
question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees so you can
see the employee table that we had used
in
our
group by clause as well
so if you were to find the cities where
there are more than two employees so
this is how your sql query should look
like
so we have selected
the employee id and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
city
and then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee id should be greater
than two
so if you see the output we have the
different city names and
these were the cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2
all right so let's go to our mysql
workbench and implement how
having works so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000 dollars
you can use the having clause for this
so let me first run my table which is
employees
if i run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information
and
the last column we had was salary so the
question we have is
we want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
thousand dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write
select
department
comma
i'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
i'll give an alias name as
evg
underscore
salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
group by clause and i want to group it
by each department
and then i am going to write my
having clause so in having clause i'll
use my condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
75 000
let's run it
and see the output there you go
so here you can see
there were total three departments in
the company that is sales finance in hr
where the average salary is greater than
seventy five thousand dollars
okay
next
let's say you want to find the cities
where the total salary is greater than
200 000 dollars
so
this will again be a simple
sql query so i'll write select city
comma
i want to find the total salary so i'll
use the sum function
and i'll pass my column as salary
as
i'll give a
alias name as total
from
employees
group by
city
and then i am going to use my having
clause
i will pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are chicago
seattle and houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
i'll write select
department comma
this time since i want to find the
number of employees i'm going to use the
count function
i'll write count star
as
employee underscore count or emp
underscore count which is my alias name
from
employees
next i'll group it by
department
having
i'll give my condition
count star greater than 2
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product tech and id where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where clause
along with the having clause in an sql
statement so suppose i want to find the
cities that have more than two employees
apart from houston
so
i can write my query as select
city comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
where
i'll give my condition city
not equal to
houston i'll put it in double quotes
since i don't want to see
the information regarding houston
i'll group it by
city
having
count of employees greater than 2.
so if i run this query
you see we have information for
chicago and seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if i want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75
thousand dollars
i can write it something like this
so select
department
comma
count
star
as
emp count
from
employees
group by
department
and in the having clause
i'm going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so i'll write having
average salary
greater than
75 000
this is another way to use the having
clause let's run this
all right you can see we have department
sales finance and hr and you can see the
employee count where the average salary
was greater than 75 000
okay
so let me
run you from the beginning what we did
in our demo so first we created a table
called employee then we inserted 20
records to this table
next we explored a few sql commands like
dixtend then we used average
and finally we started with our
group by clause
followed by
looking at how group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost table to find out the profit
then
you learned how to use the having clause
so we explored several different
questions and
learned how to use
having an sql in this session we will
learn about joins in sql
joins are really important when you have
to deal with data that is present on
multiple tables
i'll help you understand the basics of
joints and make you learn the different
types of joints with hands-on
demonstrations on mysql workbench
so let's get started with what are
joints in sql
sql join statement or command is often
used to fetch data present in multiple
tables sql joins are used to combine
rows of data from two or more tables
based on a common field or column
between them now consider this example
where we have two tables
an orders table and a customers table
now the order table has information
about the order id which is unique here
we have the order date
that is when the order was placed then
we have the shipped date this has
information about the date on which the
order was shipped then we have the
product name which basically is the
names of different products
we have the
status of delivery whether the product
was delivered or not or whether it was
cancelled then we have the quantity
which means the number of products that
were ordered and finally we have the
price of each product
similarly
we have another table called customers
and this customer table has information
about the order id
which is the foreign key here
then we have the customer id which is
the primary key for this table we also
have the phone number customer name and
address of the customers
now suppose
you want to find the phone numbers of
customers
who have ordered a laptop
now to solve this problem
we need to join both the tables the
reason being the phone numbers are
present in the customers table as you
can see here
and laptop which is the product name is
present in the orders table which you
can see it here so using a join
statement you can find the phone numbers
of customers who have ordered a laptop
now let's see another problem where you
need to find the customer names who have
ordered a product in the last 30 days
in this case we want the customer name
present in the customers table and the
last 30 days order information which you
can get from the order date column that
is present in the orders table
okay
now let's discuss the different types of
joints one by one so first we have an
inner join
so the sql inner join statement returns
all the rows from multiple tables as
long as the conditions are met from the
diagram adverb you can see that there
are two tables a and b
a is the left table and b is the right
table
the orange portion represents the output
of an inner join
which means an inner join returns the
common records from both the tables
now you can see the syntax here
so we have the select command
and then
we give the list of columns from table a
which you can see here is the left table
followed by the inner join keyword and
then the name of the table
that is b
on
a common key column from both the tables
a and b
now let me take you to the mysql
workbench and show you how inner join
works in reality
so here
i'll type
mysql
you can see i have got
my sequel workbench
8.0 version installed i'll click on it
it will take some time to
open
okay
i'll click on this local instance
and here i'll give my password
okay
so this is how an sql editor on mysql
workbench looks like
so first of all
let me go ahead and create a new
database
so i'll write
create
database this is going to be my command
followed by the name of the database
that is going to be sql underscore joins
if i give a semicolon and hit ctrl enter
this will create a new database you can
see here one row affected
now
you can check whether the database was
created or not using show databases
command
if i run it
here you can see i have sql joins
database
created
now i'll use this database so i'll write
use sql underscore joins
okay
now to understand
inner join consider that there is a
college
and in every college you have different
teams for different sports such as
cricket football basketball and others
so let's create two tables cricket and
football
so i'll write
create
table
and my table name is going to be cricut
next
i'm going to
create two columns
in this table the first column is going
to be cricut
id
then
i'm going to give
the data type as int and use the auto
increment operator
i'm using auto increment because my
cricut id is going to be
my primary key
then i'm going to give
the name of the students who are part of
the cricut team
and for this i'll use
varchar data type and give the length as
30.
i'll give another comma
and
i'll assign my cricut id as primary key
within brackets i'll give
cricut underscore id
cricket id is nothing but a unique
identifier for each of the players like
you have role numbers in college
okay
let me just run it
all right so we have successfully
created our cricket table
similarly let me just copy this and i'll
paste it here
i'll create
another table called football
this will have the information of all
the students who are part of the
football team
and instead of cricket i am going to
give this as football id
all right
and
the name column will have the names of
the students
i'll change my primary key to football
id
all right
let me run this okay
so now we have also created our
football table the next step is to
insert a few player names into both the
tables
so i'll write my insert into command
first let's load some data to our cricut
table
so i'll write cricket and
i'll give my
name column
followed by
values and here i'll give some names
such as
let's say stuart
give another comma
the next player i'll choose is let's say
michael
similarly i'll add a few more let's say
we have
johnson
the fourth player i'll take is let's say
hidden
and finally we have
let's say fleming
okay
now i'll give a semicolon and run this
okay so let me just check if all the
values were inserted properly for this
i'll use
select star from table that is cricket
if i run it you can see i have created a
table and have successfully inserted
five rows of information
now similarly
let's
insert
a few student names
for our football table
so i'll change this to
football
and
obviously there would be students who
will be part of both cricket and
football team
so
i'll keep a few
repeated names let's say stewart
johnson and let's say hayden are
part of both cricket and football team
then we have let's say
langer
and
let's say we have another player in the
football team that is astral
i'll just run it
okay you can see there are no errors so
we have successfully
inserted values to our football team as
well
let me just recheck it
i'll write select star from
football
all right
so we have five players in the football
team as well
okay
now the question is
suppose you want to find the students
that are part of both the cricket and
football team in this case you can use
an inner join
so let me show you how to do it
so i'll write select star from
cricket
as i'm using an alias name as c which
stands for cricket
then i am going to write inner join
my next table is going to be football
as f which is an alias name for the
football table
then i am going to use the on
command or operator
and then
i will give the
common
key that is name here so c dot name is
equal to f dot name
so based on this name column from both
the table my inner john operation will
be performed
so let's just run it
there you go so stuart johnson and
hayden are the only three students who
are part of both the teams
all right
now you can also individually select
each of the columns from both the tables
so let's say i write select c dot
cricut underscore id
comma
c dot
name
comma
f dot
football underscore id
comma
f dot name
from
i'll write
cricket as c
inner join
football as f
on
c dot
name
is equal to f dot name
now if i run this you see we get the
same output here as well
all right
now let's explore another example to
learn more about inner joins so we have
a database called classic models let me
first
use classic models
i'll run this
okay
now let me just show the different
tables that are part of classic tables
all right
so here you can see there are tables
like customers there's employees office
there's office details
orders payments products and product
lines as well
all right
so
let me use
my select statement to show
what are the columns present in the
products table
okay
so this product table has information
about different
product names you have the product code
now this product code is unique here
we also have the product vendor
a little description about the product
then we have the quantity in stock
buying price and msrp
let's see what we have in
product lines
if i run it you see here we have the
product line which is the
primary key for this table then we have
the
textual description for each of the
products this is basically
some sort of an advertisement
all right now suppose
you want to find the product code the
product name and the text description
for each of the products you can join
the products and product lines table
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my select statement and
choose my columns as product code then
we have
product name
and let's say i want the text
description
so i'll write this
column name
okay
then i'll use from
my first table that is
products
inner
join product lines
i can use using
the common key column that is product
line
close the bracket i'll give a semicolon
and if i run it there you go so you can
see the different product codes
then we have the different product names
and the textual description for each of
the products
so this we did by joining the products
table and the product lines table
all right
now suppose
you want to find the revenue generated
from each product order and the status
of the product to do this task we need
to join three tables that is orders
order details and products so first let
me show you what are the columns we have
in these three tables we have obviously
seen for the products table now let me
show you for orders and order details
table
so i'll write select star from
orders fire on it you can see it has
information about the order number
the date on which the order was placed
we also have the shipment date we also
have the status column which has
information regarding whether the order
was shipped or cancelled
then we have some comments column we
also have the customer number who
ordered this particular product
similarly
let's check what we have under order
details
so i'll write select star from
order
details if i run it
you can see it has the order number the
product code quantity of each product we
have the price of each product then we
have the order line number okay
so using the product
orders and order details let's perform
an inner join
so i'll write select
o dot
order number
comma
o dot
status
comma
i need the product name which i'll take
from the products table so i'll write p
dot
product name
now here o
p are all
alias name for the tables orders
products and i'll use od for order
details comma
since we want to find the revenue
we actually need to
find the product of quantity ordered
into
price of each product so i'll use a sum
function and inside the sum function i
will give
quantity
ordered
multiplied by
the price of each item
i'll use an alias as revenue
then i'll use my
from clause
from orders as o
inner join
order
details as i'll use an alias name as od
on
i'll write
o dot
order number
is equal to
od dot
order number
i'll use another inner join
and this time we'll join the products
table so i'll write inner join
products as
p
on
p dot
product code
is equal to
[Music]
od dot
product code
and finally i'll use the group by clause
and group it by order number
all right
let me run this
okay there's some mistake here we need
to debug this
it says
you have an error in your sql syntax
check the manual all right
okay i think the name of the tables is
actually orders and not order
all right now let's run it
okay there's still some error
it says
classic models dot product doesn't exist
so again the product name is
i mean the table name is products and
not product so let's run it again
all right there you go so we have the
order number the status
the product name and the revenue
this we got it using
inner join from three different tables
now talking about left joins
the sql left join statement returns all
the rows from the left table and the
matching rows from the right table so if
you see this diagram you can see we have
all the rows from the left table that is
a and only the matching rows from the
right table that is b so you can see
this
overlapped
region
and the syntax
for sql
left join is something like this so you
have the select statement and then you
give the list of columns from table e
which is your left table
then you use the
left join
keyword
followed by the next table that is table
b on the common key column so you write
a dot key is equal to b dot key
okay
now in our classic models database we
have two tables customers and orders so
if you want to find the customer name
and their order id you can use these two
tables so first let me show you the
columns that are present in
customers and orders
i think orders we have already seen let
me first show you
what's there in the customers table
okay so you can see we have the customer
number
the name of the customer then we have
the contact last name the contact first
name
we have the phone number then there's an
address column there are two address
columns actually
we have the city name the state
and we have other
information as well and similarly we
have
our orders table
so i'll write select start form orders
so i'll write select star from orders
but on this you can see these are the
information available in the
orders table
okay
so
let's perform a left join
where we want to find the customer name
and their order ids
so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
or let's say first we'll choose the
customer number comma
then i want the customer name so i'll
write c dot customer name
then we have the
order number column which is present in
the orders table and let's say i also
want to see the status
then i'll give my left table that is
customers
as c
left join
orders
as o
on
c dot
customer number equal to
o dot
customer number
let's run it
okay again there is some problem
all right so the table name is customers
let's run it
so there's another mistake here this is
customer number so b is missing cool
let me run it
all right so here you can see we have
the information regarding the customer
number
then
the respective customer names we have
the order number and the
status of the shipment so if i scroll
down you'll notice one thing there are a
few rows you can see which have null
values
this means
for customer number 125 and for this
particular customer name there were no
orders
and similarly if i scroll down you will
find a few more null values
you can see here there are two null
values here for
customer number 168 169 there were no
orders available
all right
now to check those customers who haven't
placed any orders
you can use the null operator so what
i'll do is here
i'll just continue with this i'll use a
where clause and write where
order
number is
null
now let me run this
okay so here you can see there are
24 customers from the table
that don't have any orders in their
names
okay
now talking about right joins
so sql right join statement returns all
the rows from the
right table and only matching rows from
the left table so here you can see we
have our left table as a and the right
table as b
so the right join will return all the
rows from the right table and only the
matching rows from the left table
now talking about the syntax so here you
can see we have the select statement
followed by the select statement you
will have the list of columns that you
want to choose
from table a
right join table b on the common key
column from both the tables
all right
now to show how right join works i'll be
using two tables that is customers and
employees so let's see
the rows of data that are present in the
customer table first so i'll write
select star from
customers
let's run it so here you have the
customer number the customer name
then we have the phone number the
address of the customers
you also have the country to which the
customer belongs to the postal code
and the credit limit as well similarly
let's see for
the employees table
here i'll change customers to employees
let's run it
okay so we have the employee number the
last name the first name
we have the extension the email id
the job title
and also
reports to here means the manager
okay
so based on these two tables we'll find
the customer name
the phone number of the customer
and the email address of the employee
and join both the tables that is
customers and employees
so let me show you
the command so i'll write select
c dot
customer name
comma
then we have c dot
phone i'll give a space here
next
i want
the employee
number from the employee table so i'll
write e dot
employee number
comma
e dot
email
from
customers as c
right join
employees
as e
on
e dot
my common key column is employee number
here so i'll write e dot
employee number is equal to
c dot
we have
sales
representatives
employee number
and i'm also going to order it by
the employee number column
okay
so you can see i have
my customer name selected from the
customers table the phone number of the
customer then we have the employee
number and the email address
so let me run it
okay
there's some problem
all right so the table name is customers
actually
let's run it once again
there you go
so you can see here
we have
all the values selected from our right
table which is the employees table you
can see writes on employees which means
your employees table is to the right
and then we have
the customer name and phone numbers of
the customers from the customer table
which is actually your left table
so you have a few
employee numbers such as one zero zero
two this one zero five six which don't
have any customer name or phone numbers
okay so there's another popular join
which is very widely used in sql known
as self joins so self-joints are used to
join a table to itself
so in our database we have a table
called employees let me show you the
table first
all right
so here you can see we have the employee
number the last name the first name of
the employee we have the email id
and here if you see we have a column
called reports2 now this you can think
of as
the manager column so the way to read is
for example
for employee number 1056
the manager is 1 0 0 2 so if you check
for 1 0 0 two we have
day in murphy
then
if i scroll down
let's see for employee number
yeah for employee number 1102 the
manager is one zero five six so here you
can see
who is at one zero five six you have
mary patterson
similarly if i scroll down let's see
for employee number one one eight eight
we have
the manager as one one
four three now if i check the table at
one one four three we have anthony bow
so
so the employee julie ferelli reports to
anthony bow
all right
now suppose you want to know who is the
reporting manager for each employee so
for that you can use a self join
so let me show you how to join this
employees table
i'll write select
and then i'm going to use a function
called concat
within brackets i'll start with my alias
name that is m dot then i'll write
last name
i'm going to concat last name
followed by a comma
then i'll have my
first name
i'll close this bracket
and then i'm going to give my
alias name let's say manager
comma
next
i'm going to concat
the same
last name and first name and this time
i'm going to use a separate alias let's
say
e which stands for employee so i'll
write e dot
last name
comma and within
single quotes
i'll
give my comma and then i'll write e dot
first name
i close this bracket i'll give an alias
as let's say
employee
from
i'll write
employees
as e
inner join
employs
as
m
on
m dot
i'll use my
common key column as employee number so
i'll write
m dot
employee
number
is equal to e dot
here i am going to use the reports two
column
and then
i'll
order it by
let's say manager
okay
now let's run this
there you go so you have your two
columns as manager and employee
so for employee louie
bonder
the manager is zerat bonder
similarly if i scroll down
you have there are multiple
employees reporting to this particular
manager similarly we have our manager as
anthony bow and we have
different employees who are reporting to
this particular manager
and so on
all right now moving ahead
now let's see what a full join is
so sql full outer join statement returns
all the rows when there is a match in
either left or right table now you must
remember that mysql workbench does not
support full outer join by default but
there is a way to do it
so
by default this is how the syntax of
full outer join looks like
now this statement will work on other
sql databases like microsoft sql server
but it won't work on mysql workbench
i'll show you the right way of using
full auto join on mysql workbench
so to show full outer join i am going to
first use a left join and then we'll
also use a right join and finally we'll
use a union operator so the union
operator is used to combine the result
set of two or more select statements
so first of all let me write
c dot
customer name so for this example i am
using the customer table and the order
table
comma
o dot
order number
so i just want to know the customer name
and the
order number related to the customer
from
i have
customers
as
c
left join
i'll write
orders as o
on
c dot
customer number
is equal to
o dot
customer number
let me just copy this
and after this i am going to use my
union operator
so union operator is used to merge
results from
two or more
tables
so basically this performs a vertical
join
and next i am going to use my right join
operation
so here instead of left join i'll write
right
restore looks fine
let me just run it
there you go so we have successfully run
our
full outer join operation you can see we
have the different customer names
and
the order that each customer had placed
all right
so that brings us to the end of our demo
session
so let me just run through whatever we
did in this session so first we created
a database called sql joins
then we created two tables like cricut
and football
then we had
inserted a few
rows to each of these tables then we
used this table to learn about inner
join
next
we used a database called classic models
it had multiple tables so we explored
all of these tables like products there
was product lines orders customers and
employees and learned how to use inner
join left join self join
right join as well as full outer join
in this video
we will learn what is a sub query and
look at the different types of sub
queries
then we learn sub queries with select
statement followed by sub queries with
insert statement
moving further we will learn sub queries
with the update statement and finally we
look at sub queries with delete
statement
all these we will be doing on our mysql
workbench
so before i begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update so
let's start with what is a sub query
so a sub query is a select query that is
enclosed inside another query
so if i show you
this is how
the basic structure of a sub query looks
like
so here
whatever is present inside the brackets
is called as the inner query and
whatever is present outside is called
the outer query
so first the inner query gets executed
and the result is returned to the outer
query and then the outer query operation
is performed
all right now let's see an example
so we have a question at hand which is
to write a sql query to display
department with maximum salary from
employees table
so this is how our employees table looks
like it has the employee id the employee
name age gender we have the date of
joint department city and salary
now to solve this query
my sub query would look like this
so i'll first select the department from
my table that is employees
where
i'll use the condition salary equal to
and then i'll pass in my inner query
which is select max of salary from
employees
so what this does is it will first
return the maximum salary of the
employees in the table
then a router query will get executed
based on the salary returned from the
inner query
so here the output is
department sales has the
maximum salary so one of the employees
from the sales department earns the
highest or the maximum salary if you see
in our table
the
employee is josef who earns
115 000
all right
and joseph is from the sales department
now let's see how this query works
so here we have another question which
is to find the name of the employee with
maximum salary in the employees table so
this is our previous employees table
that we saw and to find the employee who
has the maximum salary
my sub query would look something like
this so i'm selecting the employee name
from my table that is employees where
i'm using the condition salary equal to
and then i'm passing in my sub query or
the inner query so first i am selecting
the maximum salary
this will return a particular value that
is the highest salary from the table
and if you see our table the highest
salary is 115 thousand dollars
so our query becomes select employee
name from employees where salary equal
to hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
so the employee name is
joseph here and
that's the output
now if you want to break it down
here you can see first the inner query
gets executed
so our sql query will first execute the
inner query that is present inside
brackets select maximum salary from
employees the result is 115 000
and then based on the return result our
outer query gets executed so the query
becomes select employee name from
employees where salary equal to 115 000
and that employee is joseph
all right
now we'll learn the different types of
sub queries
so you can write sub queries using
select statement update statement delete
and insert statement
we'll explore each of this with the help
of example on my mysql workbench
so let's learn sub queries with the
select statement
so sub queries are majorly used with the
select statement and this is how the
syntax looks like you select the column
name from the table name then you have
the
where condition followed by the columns
that you want to pass the operator and
inside that
you have this sub query so here is an
example that we will perform on our
mysql workbench so in this example we
want to select all the employees who
have
a salary
less than average salary for all the
employees
this is the output so let's do this on
my mysql workbench
all right so let me login to my local
instance
i'll give my password
okay so you can see i'm on my mysql
workbench
so let's start by
writing our sub query using the
select statement
okay so for this demo session we'll be
using a database that is sub queries you
can see it here i have a database called
sub queries
so i'll
use this
sub queries database
and we'll create a few tables as well
okay
if i run it
now we are inside the sub queries
database
so
let me just show you the tables that are
present inside this database i'll write
show tables
if i run it
okay there are two tables employees and
employees underscore b
we'll use this table throughout our demo
session
all right
now for our select sub query
we want to fetch the employee name the
department and the salary whose salary
is less than the average salary
so we will be using the employees table
so let me first show you
the records and the columns we have in
the employees table
so i'll write select star from employees
and run it okay you can see here we have
20 rows of information
we have the employee name the employee
id age gender data joint department city
and salary so this is the same table
that we saw in our slides
okay
now for our sub query i'll write select
i want to choose the employee name
the department
and the salary
there should be a comma here instead of
a period
next
i'll give my table name that is
employees
where
my salary is less than
and after this i'll start my inner query
or the sub query i'll write select
average salary so i'm using the evg
function to find the average salary of
all the
employees
from my table that is employees
if i give a semicolon
and run this
you'll see the output
so we have total 12 employees in the
table whose salary is less than the
average salary now if you want you can
check the average salary
so the average salary is 75 350 dollars
now the employees who have a salary
less than the average salary
so these are the people
all right
now moving back to our slides
okay
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the insert statement
now the insert statement uses the data
returned from the sub query to insert
into another table
so this is how the syntax looks like so
you write insert into table name
followed by select individual columns or
star from
the table
use the where clause and then you give
the operator followed by the inner query
or the sub query
so here
we will explore a table called products
table
we are going to fetch few records from
the products table based on a condition
that is
the selling price of the product should
be greater than 100
so only those records will fetch and put
it in our orders table
all right
so we are going to write this query on
my
my sequel workbench so let's do it
i'll give my
comment as
update sub query
all right
so first of all let's create a table
that is
products so i'll write create table
products
then we'll give our column names the
first column would be the product id of
type
integer
then we have the column as item or the
product
which is of type worker 30
next we have the
selling price of that product the
selling price will be of type float
and finally we have another
column which is called the product type
and again product type is of
the data type backer i'll keep the size
as 30
close the bracket and give a semicolon
now let's just um run it it's like
okay so we have successfully created our
products table all the year that
possible now let's insert a few records
to our products table
so i'll write insert into
click here to watch similar
if you like to watch similar videos turn
it up and get certified click
fully recorded the first product id is
101.
the product is
let's say jewelry
then the selling price is let's say 800
and the product type is it's a luxury
product
next let's insert one more
product detail
the product id is one zero two
the product
is let's say t showed
the price is let's say hundred dollars
and
the product type is
non-luxury
[Music]
next
i'll just copy this
to reduce our task
we'll edit this
the third product's id is 103
the product is
laptop
and let's say the price is 1300
and it's a luxury product
i'll paste again and finally i'll enter
my fourth product
which is let's say
table
and the price is
and it's a non-luxury product
give a semicolon and we'll insert these
four records to our products table you
can see
we have inserted four records let's just
print it now so i'll write
select
star
from
products
if i run it
you can see we have our four products
ready
now
this is where we need for innovation in
cell therapy manufacturing we see a
tremendous benefit to bringing parties
together to collaborate in this case
we're bringing together
the academic excellence that exists in
ucsf and thermal fisher's expertise in
cell and gene therapies
therapy
cell therapy are alterative instead of
the other therapy like small molecules
antibodies they treat the symptoms
i believe it's the next big revolution
in medicine where we're going
that people with devastating diseases
have cell therapy is mostly used what we
call for liquid tumors but the next
frontier is really getting into solid
tumors scientists at ucsf have developed
very exciting therapies that may be
effective against solid tumors and so
we're excited about the potential of
these networks
this is not a problem that can be
addressed by one person in one company
it's something that needs to be done
together here at ucsf we're one of the
leading health research
universities in the country while we are
extraordinarily skilled at discovering
new targets for therapeutic intervention
and
indeed actually discovering drugs
we are ill-prepared to actually develop
those
we knew we needed a partner thermo
fisher can work with our partners to
help translate all of this exciting work
done in the collaboration center into
commercially available therapies the
ability of those cell engineers to talk
directly with the thermofisher
technicians and scientists who have the
skills of
taking those discoveries and
manufacturing cells for human use
that close proximity can't be overstated
i think it's going to be a unique
collaboration unlike virtually anything
that i'm aware of
that will push this field further and
faster
products are coming from the insert
one around the center
facility items
so the ability to work closely with
thermo efficiencies
and then dose them into patients
literally across the street at our
precision cancer hospital
that is truly exactly this will be a
resource for patients literally around
the world because we'll be doing first
in kind of
is focused on addressing this challenge
by working with our partners to develop
more standardized approaches
i'm just incredibly excited to begin
work on what i think is the next big
revolution in medicine
if i run it there you go so there were
two products from a product table that
were jewelry and laptop which have a
selling price greater than one thousand
dollars so the selling price for jewelry
was eighteen hundred dollars and for
laptop it was
thirteen hundred dollars so this is how
you can
use a sub query using the insert
statement all right now going back to
our slides again
all right
now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the update statement
now the sub queries can be used in
conjunction with the update statement
so either single or multiple columns in
a table can be updated when using a
subquery with the update statement
so this is how the basic syntax of an
update sub query looks like so you write
update table followed by the table name
you set the column name to give the ware
operator
and then you write your inner sub query
so we are going to see an example
where we will use this employees table
and using this employees table we will
update the records of the salaries of
the employees
by multiplying it with a factor of 0.35
only for those employees which have age
greater than 27
so we are going to use a new table
called employees underscore b for this
as well so let's see how to do it
so i'll give my comment as
update
sub query
before we see the sub query let's see
what we have in the table employees
underscore b
this is basically a replica of the
employees table
there you go
it has the same records that our
employees table has we are going to use
both the employees table and the
employees underscore b table
to update our records
so i'll write
update
employees
set
salary equal to
let me bring this to the next line
i'll write set salary equal to
salary
multiplied by point
three five where
age
in
then i'll write select
age from
my other table that is
employees underscore b
where
age is greater than equal to
let's say 27
all right
so let me run through this query and
tell you what we are going to do so i am
going to update the records of the
employees table specifically for the
salary column so i am checking
if the age is greater than 27 then
will multiply the salaries of the
employees with a factor of 0.35
in the employees table
let me just run this
then we'll see our output
okay so it says 18 rows affected which
means there are total 18 employees in
the table out of the 20 employees whose
age is greater than 27.
now if you see i'll write select star
from
employees
you can see the difference in the
salaries
if i scroll to the right you can see
these are the updated salaries
okay
now if you check for employees who have
an age
less than or equal to 27
for example markus whose age is 25 his
salary is the same we haven't updated
his salary
then if you see
if we have okay there is one more
employee maya
we haven't updated the salary of maya
because the age is less than
all right
now let's go back to our slides again
as you can see we got the same output
on our my sequel workbench
now let's explore
how you can write sub queries for the
delete statement
now sub queries can again be used in
conjunction with the delete statement so
this is how the basic syntax of a delete
query using sub query would look like
you write delete from the table name
where clause the operator value followed
by the inner query and within brackets
so here we are going to use the
employees table and
what we are going to do is we will
delete the employees whose age is
greater than equal to 27
so let's see how you can do it
all right
so i'll
give my comment
as
delete sub query
so we'll follow the syntax that we saw
i'll write delete
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write
where
age
in
and then i'll start my inner query or
the sub query i'll write select
age
from
employees underscore b
where
age is
let's say
greater than equal to
32 or let's say the age is less than
equal to 32
close the bracket and i'll give my
semicolon
let me first run the inner query for you
so that you
get an idea of the employees who are
less than
32 years of age
so there are nine employees in the table
who have an age less than equal to 32
so we are going to delete the records
if i run this
okay it says nine records deleted
now let's
print or display what we have
in the employees table
if i run this
there you go so if you see the age table
we have total 11 employees now
and all the ages are greater than
32 because we have deleted all those
employees who had an h less than equal
to 32
okay
so
let me show you from the beginning what
we did so first we used our
sub queries database then
we used our employees table
so we started by
looking at how you can use the sub query
with a select statement this should be
insert instead of update
so we learnt how to write an insert
subquery
we use two tables products and our
orders table
moving ahead we saw how to write
sub queries using the update command
so we updated the salaries of the
employee by a factor of 0.35 for those
who had an age greater than equal to 27
and finally we saw how to use the sub
query using the delete statement so we
deleted all those records for the
employees whose age was less than equal
to 32. in this video we will discuss an
advanced sql concept called triggers
we will learn what triggers are
and how they can be used to solve
problems
we look at how trigger queries are
written on mysql workbench
so let's get started
first
what are triggers in sql
so a trigger is a user defined sql
command that is invoked automatically
when an event occurs
an event can be related to inserting
updating or deleting records in a table
in mysql triggers can be executed
automatically by the oracle server
below is how the syntax of writing a
trigger is
so you write create trigger
followed by the trigger name
now the trigger name should be a valid
sql name
then we have the trigger time
the trigger event and then on the name
of the table then we write for each row
begin
followed by the list of sql statements
and finally we write end
now in the syntax
the trigger time represents either
before or after an event
and a trigger event can be an insert
update or delete operation
now let me take you to mysql workbench
where we will learn how to create
triggers and explore more on how it
works so i am on mysql workbench so
first let me go ahead and create my
connection
i'll give my password
all right now this will take you to my
sql editor okay so first and foremost
let me create a new database called
triggers
so
i'll write my sql command as
create
database
triggers
let me
run this
okay so you can see here one row
affected i have created my database that
is triggers
next
i'm going to move inside this database
so i'll write the command use triggers
let's run this
okay
now inside this triggers database we'll
be creating our different tables
so
let's check if we have any tables i'll
use the command show tables
now you see there are no tables in this
database
all right
first let's see how before insert
trigger works
so for before insert trigger will create
a table called customers and verify the
age of each customer
so i'll give a comment
before
insert
trigger
so let me go ahead and create my
customers table i'll write create table
customers
and i'll give my
column names as
cust underscore id which is
customer id
this is going to be an integer
then we have the age of the customer
this is again an integer
and we'll have the name of the customer
the name of the customer will be a
varchar type i'll give the size as 30
all right
let's create this table okay so we have
successfully created our customers table
now moving ahead i am going to write my
before insert trigger command so we'll
start with a delimiter
so a delimiter is a marker for the end
of each command
next
i'll write my
create trigger
followed by the trigger name
i'll give a valid trigger name such as
age underscore verify
i'll write
before
trigger
it should be before insert
on
my table name would be
customers
then i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot age
is less than
zero
then
set
new dot age
equal to zero which means
while inserting your
values to the age column in case the
each value is negative will convert the
age to zero
i'll give a semicolon
and then i'll write end if
i'll give another semicolon
and
i'll close the delimiter
now let me run this
okay so we have created our trigger
now
let's insert a few values
on to customers
so i'll write insert into customers
values
101 which is the customer id i'll give
the age as 27 and let's say the name of
the customer is
james
let's insert another record
give the value as one zero two
and this time
i'm purposely giving the age as minus 40
which is less than zero so that you can
see the output clearly
i have given the customer name as ami
let's insert two more records the
customer id with one zero three has an
ease of 32 and let's see the name is ben
i'll give another comma
and finally we'll insert our fourth
customer record
the customer id is one zero four
the age i'm giving as minus 39 which is
less than zero again and let's say
the customer name is angela
all right
now let me run this
okay so we have successfully inserted
four
rows of information to our customers
table
now let's see the difference since we
had created a
each verify trigger
which would
change the values of the each column
in case the age value is less than zero
so now that we have inserted four
records to a customer
so
let's see what we have in the customers
table
now let me run it
there you go
so if you see this
for those customers
where the age was less than 0 such as
102 and 103 you can see here
our trigger has automatically converted
those values to 0.
if you can see the trigger we had
created
we had set our new age to zero
if
the age was less than zero
and this is the output we get
so here we looked at how a before insert
trigger works all right now moving ahead
let's understand how an after insert
trigger works so i'll give a
comment here
as
after
insert trigger
now in this example we'll create two
tables customers and message
now the trigger will be fired if the
birthday column has a null value in the
customers table
you will get a message to update your
date of birth
okay
so first let me create
my customers table
now since we already have one customers
table i'll name it as customers1
and
let me give the column names
so the first column would be the id
column this is going to be an integer
and i'll use the
auto increment parameter
and this will be my primary key as well
next we'll have the name of the customer
this is going to be of type varchar
and i'll use
not null constraint
next
we'll have the email id of the customer
this is again going to be of varchar
type and
the column we are interested in is the
birthday column
so i'll write birth date
this is going to be of type date
okay
so let's create our table
all right
now we'll create our second table
which is going to be
message
let's create the columns this will have
id
int and
i'll use the
auto increment operator
next we'll have the
message id
this is going to be of integer type
we'll
have a column called message
this will be a varchar type let's say
300 characters
and not null
and i'm going to set
my primary keys
as
id
and
message id
let's create our second table then
so we have some error here let's debug
the error
okay so i forgot to
close the bracket here all right
now let me
run this table all right so we have
created our message table as well
next
i'll write my
after insert trigger command so i'll
write
delimiter
next i'll use
create trigger command so i'll write
create
trigger
my trigger name would be
check
underscore null underscore date of birth
after
insert
on
customers
for
each
row
begin
if
new dot
birth date
is
null
then
we are going to insert
into our message table
we'll give the columns as
id
and
message
values
new dot id
comma i am going to use the concat
function
where i'll
give my
message let's say hi
followed by the name
followed by
let's say please
update
your
date of
birth
okay
now i'll write end if
i'll
close the
delimiter okay
so let me go to the top and recheck
if you have created a trigger
correctly so i have my
trigger name after insert on customers1
for each row begin
if our
new birthday has a null value then we'll
pass in a message saying hi
the name of the customer
then the message would be please update
your day to birth
all right
so let's
run the
trigger
okay
now
the next step is to
insert a few records to customer table
so my name of the table is customers1
okay
i'll give the column names as name
email
and birth
okay
we'll
pass in a few values
so our first customer's name let's say
is nancy
comma
i'll give my
email id let's say
nancy at the rate
abc.com
now
let's say i'm purposely passing the date
of birth as null
i'll give a comma
my next customer let's say
the name of the customer is
ronald
and then i'll give the
email id
such as ronald at the rate
xyz.com
and this time i'm going to pass in the
date of birth let's say 1998
november
and let's say 16th
okay
now we'll
add another customer let's say krish
will give the email id of chris
so chris
xyz.com
and let's see
we'll give the date of birth as 1997
0 8
20.
and finally we'll add
one more record for another customer
let's say alice
i'll give the email id as alice
at the rate abc.com
and this time i'll purposely pass
the date of birth as null
all right
so let's run the insert query okay
now
let me display the
message table for you so that you can
see the output
and how our
after insert trigger works
there you go
so if you see this we had inserted four
rows of information out of which the
first customer id and
the fourth id had null
date of birth
so for those two values you have the
messages hi nancy
please update your date of birth and
then you have high alice please update
your date of birth
now you can give a space between hi and
the name of the customer
all right now moving ahead let's
understand how before update trigger
works so i'll give a comment here as
before update
okay
now
to show you how before update works
first we'll create
a table called employees
all right so let me create my table that
is create
table
employees
i'll give my column as employee id
this is going to be an integer type
and
it will be my primary key
next we'll have the employee name
this will be of
varchar type
and let's say the size would be 25
comma
then we'll have the age of the employee
age will be of integer type and finally
we'll have the
salary of the employee
salary will be of type float
let's create this table
all right
now the next step is to insert a few
records to
our employees table
okay so here on the notepad i have
already
written my insert query so i have
inserted nearly seven records
so let me paste it here all right
i'll just go ahead and run this insert
query so that we'll insert
seven employees to our table
okay
next
we'll write our
before update trigger command
so first and foremost i'll write
my delimiter
followed by the create trigger command
i'll give
trigger name as update underscore
trigger
let's
bring this to the top
okay
i'll use
before update
on
my
table that is employees
for
each
row
i'll write begin
my condition would be if
new dot
salary
is equal to let's say
ten thousand dollars
i'll write
then
set
new dot
salary
equal to
eighty five thousand dollars
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll use
else if
new dot
salary
is less than
ten thousand dollars then
i'll set
new dot
salary
to let's say
seventy two thousand dollars
i'll give a semicolon
end the
if statement
i'll close the delimiter
by giving a semicolon
okay
so
if you see the employees table we have
the salary values here
now in case
while updating the table
if the salary is equal to
ten thousand dollars will set the new
salary to eighty five thousand dollars
else if the salary is less than ten
thousand dollars we'll set the salary
column values to seven to two thousand
dollars
so let's go ahead and run this
trigger query
all right
now let me use my
update command so i'll write update
employees
i'll write set
salary is equal to
let's say eight thousand dollars
now if you see our trigger query
we are setting the salary to eight
thousand dollars which is clearly less
than
ten thousand dollars so our new salary
would be seven to two thousand dollars
so let me
run this
okay
so you can see here six rows affected
so i'll right now select star from
employees
let's run this
okay
if you see this
we have converted our salary column to
seventy two thousand dollars since we
updated the salary to eight thousand
dollars and according to our trigger
query if it's less than ten thousand
dollars the salary should be seven to
two thousand dollars
which you can see here
all right now moving to our final demo
this time we are going to explore how
before delete trigger command works
so in this example we'll create a table
called salary
we'll store the deleted record in a new
table using the before delete trigger
so first
i'll give my comment as
before trigger
comments are always useful
since they make your query more readable
so let me now create my salary table so
i'll write create
table
salary
i'll give my
column names as
eid which is
employee id
and i'll set it as primary key
comma
i'll give another column let's say valid
from
which means the date from which this
salary was effective
is going to be of type date and not null
and then i'll have the amount
amount will be of type float
and again not null constraint
let me run the create
table command okay so we have created
our salary table now the next thing is
to insert a few values
so i'll write insert into
salary
i'll give my column names as eid
comma
valid from
comma amount
i'll write values
[Music]
my first employee id would be one zero
one
followed by a date let's say 2005
may
zero 1 is
let's say the amount is 55 000
i'll give another row of information
this time the employee id is 102
[Music]
i'll give another employee id let's say
0 9
0 1
and let's say the amount is 75 000
okay
let's run this
all right
you can verify also so i'll write select
star from salary
[Music]
the next step is to create
another table that will store the
deleted rows so i'll write create table
[Music]
let's say the name of the table is
create
or let's say salary
delete salary
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll also use the auto increment
operator
next we have the eid
which is of type integer
i'll write valid from
date
and
not null
then i have the amount
[Music]
my final column would be
deleted
at
the data type will be timestamp
i'll use the
default constraint as now
so this will return the time and the
date at which the record was deleted
all right
let me create this table
okay
finally
let me write my before delete trigger
command
so i'll first declare my delimiter
let's say this time i'm using the dollar
symbol
i'll write create
trigger
my trigger name would be
salary underscore delete
before
delete
on my table that is salary
for
each
row
i'll write begin
next
let's insert
into
salary
delete
i'll give my columns as
employee id
valid from
and amount
now will insert a few values
i'll write values
old dot
eid
comma
old
dot
valid
from
comma
old dot amount
i am going to
close
with the delimiters
all right
so let's
run our
before delete trigger
all right
now let me go ahead and delete one of
the records from the salary table
so i'll write delete from salary
where
employee id is let's say 103.
let me run this query
okay so you have successfully deleted
one of the
records in the table
now if you see
our other table that is salary delete
you will find
this information present in the salary
delete column so we have deleted one row
of information that is for employee id
103 which you can find it here now
the final column that is delete add
shows the time at which the information
was deleted or the row was deleted
all right so let me go to the top and
just
give you a recap of what we did in this
demo
so first we created a database called
triggers
then
we started with before insert trigger
where we inserted customer table
and then
we verified the age of the customers
so we saw if the age was less than zero
then we set these to zero
we inserted a few records to the
customers table and purposely we
inserted some negative
age records and then we converted this
age request to zero
then we learned how an after insert
trigger works so we created two tables
customers one and message
so wherever
the customer's date of birth was missing
we passed in a message saying hi
the name of the customer please update
your date of birth
all right
now moving ahead
we saw how before update trigger works
and finally we learnt about
before delete trigger
so in this video we will learn some
queries in sql we'll also have a look at
stored procedures
and learn about triggers in sql we'll
cover views in sql and look at some of
the important windows functions in sql
now to learn all of these we'll be using
the mysql workbench on windows
so let's get started with sub queries in
sql
so let me head over to my mysql
workbench
so currently i am on my mysql workbench
let me connect to the local instance
so i'll give my password
and click on ok
all right so this is my
my sql workbench query editor so first
we are going to learn sub queries let me
give a
comment and write
sub queries
all right
so first of all let's understand what a
sub query is so a sub query is a query
within another sql query that is
embedded within the where clause from
clause or having clause
so we'll explore a few scenarios where
we can use sub queries so for that
i'll be using my
database that is sql underscore intro so
i'll write my command use sql underscore
intro
now this database has a lot of tables
i'll be using the employees table that
is present inside sql underscore intro
let me just expand this and you can see
here we have an employees table so let
me first show you
the contents within this table i'll
write select star from employees
let me execute it
okay you can see here we have the
employee id employee name age gender
this
date of joint department city and salary
and we have information for
20 employees if i scroll down you can
see there are 20
employees present in our table so let's
say
you want to find the employees whose
salary is greater than the average
salary
in such a scenario you can use a sub
query
so let me show you how to
write a sub query
i'll write the select statement
in the select statement i'll pass
my column names that i want to display
so the column names i want are the
employee name
then i want the department of the
employee and the salary of the employee
from
my table name that is employees
next
i'll use a where condition where
my salary should be greater than the
average salary of all the employees so
i'll write salary greater than
after this i am going to write my sub
query
so i will give
select
average of salary
from
my table name that is employees
and i'll close the bracket and give a
semicolon
so what it does is
first it is going to find the average
salary of all the employees that are
present in our table
once we get the average salary number
we'll use this
where condition
where salary is greater than the average
salary number
so
the inside sub query let me run it first
if i run this
this gives you the average salary of all
the employees which is
75 350
now
i want to display all the employees who
have salary greater than
three hundred 75
fifty dollars
so let's run our
sub query
there you go
so there are eight employees in our
table who have
a salary greater than the average salary
of all the employees
all right
next
let's see another example
suppose this time you want to find the
employees whose salary is greater than
john's salary
so we have one employee whose name is
john
let me
run the table once again
okay if i scroll down
you see we have an employee
as
john
you see this
our employee id 116 is john and his
salary is
67 000
i want to display all the employees
whose salary is greater than john's
salary so basically all the employees
who are earning more than 65 000 dollars
i want to print them
so let's see how to do it
i'll write
select
i want the employee name
comma
the gender of the employee
i also
want the department and salary
from
my table name that is employees
i'll write where
salary is greater than
i'll start my
opening bracket inside the bracket i'm
going to give my inner query that is
select
salary
from employees
where
the employee name is
john
so within
single quotations i'll give john as my
employee
i'll end with a semicolon
so
let me first run my inner query
so this will give us the salary that
john has which is 67 000
now i want the employees who are earning
more than sixty seven thousand dollars
so let's run our
sub query
okay so you can see
12 rows returned which means there are
12 employees in our table who are
earning more than sixty seven thousand
dollars you see here
all these employees have a salary
greater than sixty seven thousand
dollars
okay
now
you can also use sub queries
with two different tables so suppose you
want to display some information that
are present in two different tables you
can use sub queries to do that
so
for this example we'll use
a
database that is called classic models
you can see the first database
so let me use this database called
classic models i'll write use classic
models
now this database was actually
downloaded from the internet there's a
very nice website i'll just show you the
website name so this is the website that
is mysql
tutorial.org
you can see here they have
very nice
articles
blogs from where you can learn
my sequel in detail
so we have
downloaded they have a mysql sample
database if you click on this
it will take you to the link where you
can download the database so they have
this download link which says download
mysql sample database
and the name of the database is classic
models
all right
so we are going to use this classic
models database throughout our demo
session
if i expand the tables
section you can see there are a lot of
tables that are present inside this
classic models database we have cricket
customers as employees office there's
orders order lines and many more
so for our sub query we'll be using two
tables that is order details and
products table
first let me show you the content that
is present inside
the product table first
if i run this
you see here it says 110 rows return
which means there are 110
different products that are present in
our table which has the product code the
product name
product line
we have the product vendor
description quantity in stock by price
msrp
the other table we are going to use is
order details which has the
details of all the orders
let me show you
the records
order details tables has
okay so there are thousand records
present in this table you have the order
number the product code
quantity ordered price of each item you
have the order line number as well
okay
now
we want to know the product code the
product name
and the msrp of the products whose price
of each product is less than 100 dollars
for this
scenario we are going to use two
different tables
and we are going to write a sub query
okay
so
if you see here
in the order details table we have a
column called price each
i want to display the product code the
product name and the msrp of the
products which have a price of each
product less than hundred dollars
so the way i'm going to do is
i'll write select
product code comma
product name
now one thing to remember
that this product name is actually
present inside our products table
and product code is present in both the
tables that is products and order
details here you can see this is the
product code column
comma
msrp which is present inside the
products table again
from my table that is
products
where
i'll write
product code
i'm going to use the in operator
next i'll write my inner query that is
select
product
code
from
my table
order details
where
my price of each product
is less than
let me run this
okay so you can see
there are total 83 products in our table
which have
a price
less than hundred dollars you can see
the
price here
okay
now
we learn another advanced concept in sql
which is known as stored procedures
i'll just give a comment saying
stored procedure
okay
so first let's understand what is a
stored procedure
a stored procedure is an sql code that
you can save so that the code can be
reused over and over again
so if you want to write a query over and
over again
save it as a stored procedure and then
call it to execute it
so in this example i want to create a
stored procedure
that will return the list of players who
have scored more than six goals in a
tournament
so i have a database called
sql underscore iq
these are a few databases that i've
already created
so this database has a table called
players if i expand the
tables
option you see we have a table called
players
and you can see the columns player id
the name of the player the country to
which the player belongs to
and the number of goals each player has
scored in a particular tournament
so i'll write a stored procedure that
will return the list of
top players who have scored more than 6
goals in a tournament
so first of all let me begin by
using my sql underscore iq database
will run it
so now we are inside the sql underscore
iq database
let me
select
star from players to show the
values that we have in the players table
you can see there are
six players in our table
we have the player id
the names of the players the country to
which these players belong to and the
goals they have scored
so i'll write a stored procedure
so the stored procedure syntax is
something like this
it should
start with a delimiter
okay
in the delimiter i'll write
amberson amber send
next i'll write
create
procedure
followed by
the procedure name
let's say i want to
name my procedure as top underscore
players
next statement is begin
after begin i'll write my select
statement
i want to select the name of the player
the country
and the goals
each player has scored
from
my table that is
players
where
i'll write goals is greater than
will give a semicolon
then
i'll end my
procedure with a
delimiter
that was double ampersand
next
i'll write
delimiter and give
a semicolon
now the semicolon suggests
this is a default delimiter
and there should be a space
okay
now let's run our
stored procedure
there you go so you have successfully
created our stored procedure
now the way to run a stored procedure is
you need to use these call method and
give the procedure name that is top
underscore place in our case
with brackets and a semicolon we have
some videos showing here let's execute
it show you the ranks of each one okay
that is some problem here i'll tell you
if it's going up or down in ranks in the
past
so we made a mistake while creating a
procedure
the name of the column is goals are not
analytics let me create that procedure
again um so let's just go right in okay
it says the procedure
top underscore player already exists
let's just
edit the procedure name instead of top
player we'll write it as top players and
similarly we'll add it here as well
now let's create it again that last part
of the code all right hey guys my name
is
now to
call my procedure i'll write call
space followed by
the procedure name which is top
underscore clears
if i run this you can see
we have two players in our table who
have scored more than six goals so we
consider them as the top players in a
particular tournament
all right
now there are other methods that you can
use while creating a stored procedure
one of the methods is by using an in
parameter
so when you define an in parameter
inside a stored procedure the calling
program has to pass an argument to the
stored procedure
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using
in parameter
all right
so for this example i'll create a
procedure that will fetch or display the
top records of employees
based on their salaries
so we have a table
in our sql underscore iq database which
is called employee details
i am going to use this table you can see
we have the name of the employee the age
sex then we have the date of join city
and salary
using this table i'll create a procedure
that will fetch or display the top
records of employees based on their
salaries
and we'll use the in parameter
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write
delimiter
this time i'm going to use
forward slash
i'll write
create
salary is the name of my procedure
and inside this procedure i will give my
parameter position in security phase
i'll create a variable var and assign
a data type integer
[Music]
then i'll write beginning chord
followed by my select statement where
i'll select the name
age
salary
from
now my table name that is
emp details or employee details
i am going to order this by cycle we
return our salary as a server descending
and
i want to
display
limited number of
records so i'm using this
limit keyword and my variable var which
i
created here
i'll end my select statement
i'll end my stored procedure with
forward slash
and i'll go back to my default delimiter
that is semicolon
all right
so let me
run this
there should be a space here
all right
so let's run this
okay you can see we have successfully
created our
second stored procedure which is sp
underscore sort by salary
now you can also check whether the
stored procedure was created or not
here
you have an option
to see
the stored procedures let me just
refresh this
and you can see we have
three stored procedures that we have
created so far one is sp underscore sort
by salary
the other two were top underscore player
and top underscore players
okay now let's call our stored procedure
i'll write call
space followed by the stored procedure
name which is sp underscore
sort
by
salary
and inside this i'll give my parameter
which was actually var and this var
we have used in
limit
let's say i want to display only the top
three records of the employees
who have the top three highest salaries
okay
so let me run it
there you go so ami sara and jimmy were
the
top three employees who have the highest
salary
so you saw how you could use the in
parameter in a stored procedure
we created a variable and that variable
we used in our select statement
and we called our stored procedure and
passed in that
variable
okay
now
instead of a select
statement inside a stored procedure you
can also use other statements let's say
update
so i'll create a stored procedure to
update the salary of a particular
employee
so in this procedure instead of select
statement we'll use the update command
in this example we'll use the
in operator twice
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write my delimiter first which is
going to be
forward slash
then i'll write create
procedure
my name of the procedure is going to be
update salary
and inside the
update salary name
i'll write in
and then
temp
underscore name which will be a
temporary name variable
and the type i'll assign is varchar 20.
i'll again use my in parameter i'll
write in
next
my other variable would be new
underscore salary
and the data type would be float
i'll write begin
and write my update
command or update statement i'll write
update
table name that is employee details
set
salary
equal to
new underscore salary
where
name is equal to
my temporary variable that is temp
underscore name
so this is my
update command and i'll
end the delimiter
all right
so let's run this
okay we have successfully created our
stored procedure
if i repress this
you can see i have my stored procedure
update underscore salary
okay
now let's see
first of all i'll
display
my
records that are present inside
employee underscore details table
okay so we have six rows of information
let's say you want to update the
salary of employee
jimmy or let's say
mary
from 70 000 to
let's say 72 000
or let's say
80 000
so i'll
call my stored procedure that is update
underscore salary and this time i am
going to pass in
two parameters the first parameter will
be the
employee name
and next with a comma i'll give my new
salary that i want to
so my
employee name let's say is
mary
and the salary i want
to be updated is let's say 80 000
i'll give a semicolon
and i'll run it
you can see it says one row affected now
let's check our table once again
there you go
if you see this
record
for mary we have successfully updated
the salary to eighty thousand dollars
now moving ahead
we learn to create a stored procedure
using the out parameter
so i'll give a comment
stored procedure using out parameter
okay
so suppose we want to get the count of
total female employees
we will create total employees as an
output parameter and the data type would
be an integer
the count of the female employees is
assigned to the output variable which is
total underscore emps using the into
keyword
let me show you how to write a stored
procedure using the out parameter
so first i'll declare my delimiter
to forward slash
i'll write
create
procedure
followed by the procedure name
it is going to be sp underscore
count
employees
and inside this i am going to give my
out parameter
and the variable name that is total
underscore
emps which is total employees and the
data type will be integer
next i am going to write
begin
followed by
my select statement that is select
i want the
count of total employees
and the output i am going to put into
my new variable that is total underscore
emps
from my table that is emp underscore
details
where
sex
is equal to
f which means
female
i'll give a semicolon
next
i'll end it
with the dv limiter and i'm going to
change the delimiter to a default
delimiter that is
colon
so let me tell you what i am doing here
i am creating a new stored procedure
that is sp underscore count employees
using this stored procedure i am going
to count the total number of female
employees that are present in our table
emp underscore details so i've used my
out parameter and i'm creating a new
variable called total underscore emps
the data type is integer
here in the select statement i'm
counting the names of the employees
and the result i am storing it in total
underscore emps
i have
used my where condition where the gender
or the sex is female
so let's run this
okay so we have created our stored
procedure
let's
refresh this
okay you can see we have our new stored
procedure sp underscore count employees
now
to call it i'll write call
the name of the procedure that is count
underscore sp underscore count
employees
within brackets i'll pass in the
parameter as
at the rate
f underscore emp
i'll give a semicolon
then i'll write
select
add the rate f underscore
emp as female employees
okay
so as is an alias name
let's run this one by one first i'll
call my procedure
and then will display the total number
of female employees you can see in our
table we have three female employees
all right
now with this understanding
let's move on to our next topic in this
tutorial on advanced sql now we are
going to learn about triggers in sql
so i'll give a
comment here
triggers in sql
so first let's understand what is a
trigger
so a trigger is a special type of stored
procedure that runs automatically when
an event occurs in the database server
there are mainly three types of triggers
in sql we have the data manipulation
trigger we have the data definition
trigger and login triggers
in this example we will learn how to use
a before insert trigger
so we will create a simple students
table that will have the students roll
number the age the name and the students
marks
so before inserting the records to our
table we'll check if the marks are less
than zero
so in case the marks are less than zero
our trigger will automatically set the
marks to a random value let's say 50.
so let's go ahead and create our table
that is
students
all right
so i'll write
create
table
student
now this table will have the student
role number
the data type is integer
it will have the age of the students
again the data type is integer we have
the
names of the students so the third
column would be
name
the data type would be variable
or varying character
size i am giving it as 30
finally we have the marks as floating
type
so let's create this table which is
student
so we have created our table
now
i'll write my
trigger command
so trigger command will start with
delimiter like how our usual stored
procedures have
next
this time i'll write create trigger
then you need to give the
name of the trigger that is mark
underscore
let's say verify
i am going to use a before insert
trigger so i'll write before
insert
on my table name that is student
next i'll write for
each
row
if
new dot
marks
is less than 0
then
we'll set
new dot
marks
equal to 50.
so this is my
condition
first we'll check
before inserting if any student has
marks less than 0
will assign a value 50 to that student
because
usually the marks are not less than zero
in any exam
i'll write end if
semicolon and i'll close the delimiter
so this is my
trigger command i'll run it
it says triggle already exists
in this case we need to update the
trigger name let's say
i'll write marks underscore verify
underscore
student for st
let's run it again
okay there is an error here because
in our table the column name is mark and
not marks
so here we need to change it as
mark instead of marks
all right
let's run it
okay so we have created a trigger
now
let me insert
a few
records to the student table
so i'll write insert into
student i'll write
values
i'll give the values as
501 which is the student roll number the
age is let's say 10
the name is it's a ruth
and the marks is let's say 75.0
give a comma we'll insert our second
student record
student roll number is 502.
age is 12
the name is let's say mike
and this time i'm purposely giving a
value of minus 20.5
give another comma
we'll insert the third
record
for student role number 503
age is 13
the name is dave
and
let's say the marks obtained by dave is
90.
now we'll insert our final record for
student number
the age is 10
name i'll enter as jacobs
and this time again i am purposely
giving the marks in negative
12 point let's say five
close the bracket and give a semicolon
and i'll run my insert statement okay so
we have
inserted four rows of information to our
student table
now
let me run the select query i'll write
select star from student
if i run this you see the difference
there you go
so
originally we had inserted
for 502
the marks was minus
20.5 and for 504
for jacobs the marks was minus 12.5
our trigger automatically converted the
negative marks to 50 because
when we created our trigger we had set
our marks to 50 in case the marks were
less than zero
so this is how a trigger works
now you can also
drop a trigger or delete a trigger you
can just write drop trigger followed by
the trigger name
in this case our trigger name is
marks underscore verify underscore st
i'll just paste this here
and if you run this it will
automatically delete your trigger
give this as a comment
okay
now moving on
now we are going to learn about another
crucial concept in sql which is very
widely used
this is known as views
so views are actually virtual tables
that do not store any data of their own
but display data stored in other tables
views are created by joining one or more
tables
i'll give a
comment as views in sql
ok
now
to learn views i am going to use my
table which is
present inside classic models database
now this database as i mentioned we had
downloaded
we had downloaded it from the internet
so first of all let me write
use
classic models so i'll switch my
database first
all right now we are inside classic
models
so here
let me show you one of the tables which
is called customers so i'll write select
star from customers
okay
i missed s here
let's run it again so this is my
customer table which is present inside
classic models database it has the
contact last name the contact first name
the customer name
customer number we have the address
state country and other information
now i'll write a basic
view command
using this customer table
the way to write is
i'll write create
view
followed by the view name which is cust
underscore details
then you write as
select
i'm going to select a few
column names from my original customer
table which is this one so i need the
customer name
let's say i need the phone number and
the city so you have this information
here you have the phone number
and the
city
all right
i'll write from my table that is
customers
if i run this
my view that is cust details will be
created
let's run it
there is some error here because the
name of the table is customers and not
customer
i'll give an s and i'll run it again
all right so you can see we have created
our view
and
to display the contents that are present
inside our view i can write select star
from followed by the view name that is
cursed underscore details
let's run it
there you go so we have the customer
name
the phone number and the city of the
different customers that we have in our
table
all right
now let's learn how you can create views
using joins so we'll join two different
tables and create a view
so for that i am going to use my
products table and the products lines
table
i am talking about the products table
and the product lines table present
inside classic models database
so before i start let me display the
records that are present inside the
products table
let's run it so these are the different
products you can see here
now let's see what we have in product
lines table
so we have the product line the text
description
and there's some html description and
image
so
i'll create a view by joining these two
tables and will fetch specific records
that are present in both the tables
so let me first start by writing
create
view
followed by the view name that is
product underscore
description
as
i'll write
select
product name
comma
then i'll write
quantity
in stock
i also want the msrp
now these three columns
are present inside the products table
and next from the
product lines table i want the text
description
of the products
so i'll write from
products table
i'll give an alias as p
followed by
inner join
my other table that is
product lines as let's say pl
on
the common column that is product line
so p dot
product line
is equal to
i'll give a space
pl dot
product line
okay
so here we have used an inner join to
fetch specific columns from both the
tables
and our view name is product underscore
description
let us run it
all right so we have our
view ready
now let me
view
or display what is present inside our
product underscore description
view
and select star from
product underscore description
let's run it
there you go so we have the product name
the quantity in stock msrpn textual
descriptions of the different products
in the table
okay
now there are a few other operations
that you can perform let's say you want
to rename a view
instead of product underscore
description you want to give some other
name
so i'll just give a comment rename
description
so to rename a description you can use
the
rename statement i'll write rename table
product
underscore description which is my
old name
i want to change this name to let's say
i'll give vehicle description
since
all our products are related to some of
the other vehicle so i'll write vehicle
description
okay
let us run it
all right so here you can see i have
renamed my
view
so here if i just refresh it
and i'll expand this you can see we have
the cast details view and we have the
vehicle underscore description view
okay
now either you can view all the views
from this panel
or you can use a command let's say
i'll write display views
is the comment
now to show all the views you can use
show
full tables
where
table
underscore
type is equal to within single quote
i'll write view
so this is the command that will display
all the views that are present inside a
database
there is some
error here let's debug the error this
should be
okay so instead of table types it should
be table type equal to view
let's run it
you can see the two different views that
we have one is customer details another
is vehicle underscore description
okay
now you can also go ahead and delete a
view
for that you can use the drop command
so i'll write drop
view followed by the view name let's say
i want to delete
customer underscore details or cast
underscore details view
i'll write drop view cust underscore
details
let's run it
you can see
here we don't have the cust underscore
details view anymore
all right
now moving to our final section in this
demo
here we will learn
about windows functions
windows functions were incorporated in
mysql in the 8.0 version
so windows function in mysql are useful
applications in solving analytical
problems
so using the employees table present
inside my sql underscore intro database
so we will find the total combined
salary of the employees for each
department
so
first let me switch my database to sql
underscore
intro database
i'll run it ok
i'll display my table
that is employee
so here we have 20 employees in our
table
using this table
we are going to find the combined salary
of the employees for each department so
we will partition our table by
department and print the total salary
and this we are going to do using
some windows functions in mysql
so i'll write select
i want the employee name
the age of the employee
and the department of the employee
comma
next i'll write
the sum of salary
over
i want to partition it by
department
so i'll write partition by department
which is dept
and i'll give an alias as
total salary
so that it will create a new column with
the name total salary
from my table that is employees
the output will be a little different
this time
let's execute it and see the result
there you go so here we have created
another column in our result that is
total salary and for
each of the employees and the respected
departments you have the highest salary
so in finance the highest salary of one
of the employees was
155 000
similarly if i come down we have the
highest salary from hr
if i scroll further we have the highest
salary from it marketing product sales
and
the tech team
all right
now we'll explore
a function which is called row number
now the row number function gives a
sequential integer to every row within
its partition
so let me show you how to
use the row number function
i'll write select
row underscore number function
over
my
column would be
salary so i'll write order by salary
i'll give the
alias as row num
give a comma
and i want to display the employee name
and the salary of the employee from my
table that is employees
and i'll order by
salary
so let's see how our row number function
will create
sequential integers okay you can see
here we have a row num column and we
have successfully given row numbers to
each of the records you can see it
starts from 1 and goes up till 20.
okay
now this row number function can be used
to find duplicate values in a table
to show that first i'll create a table
i'll write create table
let's say i'll give a random name that
is demo
and let's say we have in this table the
student id which is of type integer and
we have the student
name
which is of type
varchar
the size is 20.
i'll create
the small table with a few records
let's create this table first
now we are going to insert a few records
to our demo table so i'll write insert
into
demo
values
i'll give one zero one
the name is
shane
give a comma
i'll insert the second student name 102
the name is
bradley
we give a comma
this time
for 103 we have two records
let's say the name of the student is
herath
we'll give a comma i'll copy this
and we'll paste it again so we have
duplicated 103.
next we have 104
the name of the student let's say is
nathan
then again let's say for
the fifth student which is kevin we have
two records
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me give a semicolon and we'll insert
these records to our table demo
all right
now
let me just
run this table for you i'll write select
star from demo
if you see this
we have a few information that are
duplicated in our table
that is for student id 103 and student
id 105.
now i am going to use my
row number function to find the
duplicate
records present in my table i'll write
select student underscore id comma
student underscore name
i'll give another comma and write
row underscore
number
over
within brackets
i'll write partition
by
st underscore id
comma
sd underscore name
okay
then i'll write
order by
st underscore id
close the bracket i'll give an alias as
row num
from my table that is demo
let's just run it
you can see here
okay
let me just
delete n from here and do it again
all right now if you see here
there is just one student in the name
shane we have one student in the name
bradley
but here if you see for here earth
the second record it says two which
means there are two records for hirath
and if i scroll down there is one record
for nathan and there are two records for
kevin which means kevin is also repeated
ok
now
we are going to see another windows
function that is called rank function
in mysql
so the rank function assigns a rank to a
particular column
now there are gaps in the sequence of
ranked values when two or more rows have
the same rank
so first of all let me create a table
and the name of the table would be
a random name we'll give it as let's say
demo1
and it will have only one
column
let's say variable a of type integer
we'll create this table first
okay
now let's go ahead and insert a few
records to our
table
which is demo one so i'll write
value
one zero one
one zero two
let's say one zero three is repeated
i'm doing this purposely so that in the
output you can
clearly distinguish what the rank
function does
next we have one zero four
one zero five
we have one zero six
and let's say one zero six is also
repeated
finally we have
one zero seven
okay
let me insert these values to my table
that is demo1 ok this is done
now
if i write
select
var underscore a
and use my
rank function i'll write rank
over
then i'll
order by my variable that is var
underscore a
as
an alias name let's say test rank
from
my table that is demo1
let me execute this and show you how the
rank function works
now if i run this
there you go
so here if you mark
so for variable
a101
the test rank is one for one zero two
the test tank is two but
for this value which is 1 0 3 the test
rank is repeated because there was a
repetition for 1 0 3
so we have skipped the rank 4 here for 1
0 4 the rank is 5 now for 1 0 5 the rank
is 6 now for one zero six again since
the record was repeated twice
we have skipped the eighth rank and
our rank function has signed the same
value which is seven for one zero six
and for the last value one zero seven
the rank is 9
all right
now moving ahead we'll see
our final windows function which is
called
first value
so first value is another important
function in
mysql so this function returns the value
of the specified expression with respect
to the first row in the window frame
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to select
the employee name
the age and salary
and i'll write
first underscore
value which is my function
and pass in my employee name
and then i'll write over
order by
my
column that is salary descending
i'll give an alias as highest underscore
salary
from my table that is
employees
so let me run this and see how the
first
underscore value function works all
right so in our table
joseph was the employee who had the
highest salary which was
115 000 dollars
so
the first value function populated the
same employee name throughout the table
you can see it here
now you can also use the first
underscore value function
over the partition
so let's say you want to display the
employee name who has the highest salary
in each department so for that you can
use the partition
i'll write select emp underscore name
comma
i want the department
and the salary
comma
i'll use my function that is first
underscore
value
followed by
the name of the employee inside my first
value parameter
i'll write
over
here i am going to use partition
i am going to partition it by
department
since i want to know the employee name
who has the highest salary in each
department
and i'm going to order by
salary
descending
and i'll give my alias again as highest
salary
from
my table that is employees
so let's
run this and see the difference in the
output
okay
so as you can see here
we have
the employee who had the highest salary
from each department so for finance
jack had the highest salary from hr it
was
marcus
similarly in it it was william
if i scroll down for marketing it was
john for product it was alice who had
the highest salary similarly in sales we
had joseph
and in tech we had angela
so this is how you can use the first
underscore value function using
partition
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on our tutorial
so let me just scroll through and show
you what we did from the beginning first
we learnt about sub queries in
sql so we initially wrote a
simple sub query and then we used our
classic models database which was
downloaded from the internet i'd also
shown you the link from where you can
download this database here we used two
different tables and we performed a sub
query operation
we learnt how to create stored
procedures
so we learnt how you can use the in
operator or the in parameter as well as
the out parameter in stored procedure
after stored procedure we learned
another
crucial concept in sql which is called
triggers now triggers are also special
kind of stored procedures so we saw how
to
write a before insert trigger you can
see it here
next
we learned how to delete a trigger
we also saw how to work with views in
sql so views are basically virtual
tables that you can create from existing
tables
we also saw how you can use views using
two different tables and an inner join
and
we learnt how to display views how to
rename
view names
how to delete a view and finally we
explored a few windows function
in this tutorial we will learn how to
work with databases and tables using sql
with python
to do this demo we will be using our
jupyter notebook and the mysql workbench
you can see it here
so we will write our sql queries in the
jupyter notebook with python like syntax
if you don't have mysql or jupyter
notebook installed so please go ahead
and install them first while installing
the mysql workbench you will be asked to
give the username and password let me
show you
so i am on my mysql workbench so once
you connect it will ask for the username
and the password so i have given my
username as root and password you can
give
while installing it
we will be using the same user id or the
username and the password to make our
connection
so let's get started with our hands-on
demonstration part
and foremost let me go ahead and
import the necessary libraries
i'll give a comment as import libraries
all right
so first
i'll import
mysql dot connector
next
from
mysql dot connector
i am going to import
my error
method or the error module
next
i want to import
pandas as pd
so let's run this
okay there is some error here
this should be capital e and not small e
all right
you can see i have imported my important
libraries
now
i'm going to create a function
that will help us
create a server connection
so i'll write my user defined function
by using the def keyword
i'll write create underscore
server underscore connection
this is going to be my
function name
and it will take in
three parameters first is the host name
next is the user name
and then we have the user password
all right
i'll give a colon
and then
in the next line i'm going to define a
variable
which is going to be connection and i'll
assign it to a value called none
now we'll be using
exception handling techniques to connect
to our mysql server
the try block lets you test a block of
code for errors and the accept block
will handle the errors
so i'll write
try and give a colon
and then
i am going to reassign the connection
variable
to
a method which is
mysql dot
connector
dot connect
now this
mysqlconnector.connect method sets up a
connection so it establishes a session
with the mysql server if no arguments
are passed it uses the already
configured or default values
so here
we are going to pass in
three parameters the first is the
hostname
i'll write host
equal to
host name which is host underscore name
i'll give a comma
then i'll write
user
equal to
user underscore
name next will be my
password
and
i'll assign the value user underscore
password
all right
now
i'm going to
use a print statement
and write
mysql
database
connection
successful
after this
i'll give my
accept block so i'll use the keyword
accept
here
i'll write error as
err
give a colon and then i'm going to use
the print statement
here i'm going to use some
print formatting techniques using the f
letter
i'll write error colon
and i'll use curly braces
give err
and then
i'll close the
double quotes
after this
i'm going to
return
my connection
all right
let me give a comment here
we are going to assign our password
so we need to put our
mysql
terminal password
so this password you assign it while
installing mysql workbench
i'll write
p
w
and i'll give my password which is
simply
at the rate one two three four five
and then
i'm going to
give my database
name so i'll give
database
name
here
i'm going to write
db
equal to this is the database i want to
create which is going to be
mysql underscore python
let me just scroll this down
okay
now
i'll say
connection
equal to
i'll pass in my
user defined function name which is
create
server
connection and the
parameters which are going to be
localhost that is my
hostname
my username which is root
and then i'll give pw
which is my password that is exactly
simply at the rate one two three four
five
let's just run it now
okay
there is an error here we need to remove
this
double quotation
all right
made another mistake here this this
should be root
okay you can see here mysql database
connection successful
all right
next
we are now going to create a database
that is mysql underscore python so i'll
give a comment create
mysql underscore
python
database
again to create this database i'm going
to create another user-defined function
using the def keyword
i'll write
the function name as create
database
passing the parameters as
connection comma
query
give a semicolon
and in the next line
i'll write cursor equal to
i'm going to make the connection so i'll
write connection dot
cursor
and i'll give the parenthesis
so this mysql's cursor of mysql
connector python is used to execute
statements to communicate with the mysql
database the mysql cursor class
initiates objects that can execute
operations such as the mysql statements
ok
next
i'm going to again use my
try and accept block so i'll write
try
give a colon and here i'm going to use
cursor
dot execute
within that i am going to pass in my
query
next i'll use a print statement
and the message i am going to display is
database
created
successfully
after this
i'm going to write my accept block
i'll write accept
error as
give a colon and then i'll use a print
statement i'll write print
i'll use the
formatting again
error
colon
and i'll write
within single codes i'll give curly
braces
err and then i'll close the double
quotes
next
let's
use the variable
to create
underscore
database
underscore query
and
here i'm going to write my
sql query to create the database so i'll
write create
database
and followed by that i'll give my
database name which is going to be mysql
underscore python
okay after this
i'll call my function which is create
database
and i'll pass in the
parameters the first one is
connection
and next
the query is create underscore database
underscore query let me just copy it
and i'm going to paste it here
all right so what i am doing here is
i am creating a new function
that is to create a new database with
the name
mysql
underscore python which you can see it
here
now this function takes in two
parameters connection and query
i am using the connection dot cursor
function which is often used to execute
sql statements using
python language and then i have created
my try and excerpt blocks
so this try block statements will try to
create my new database which is mysql
underscore python
in case it fails to create the new
database
the excel block will work so here i am
writing my sql query to create a new
database which is create database
followed by the database name and i am
assigning it to a variable which is
create database query and then i am
calling my function create database and
passing in the two parameters connection
and
the query
all right so let's just run it
all right you can see here it has
created my database successfully
now
you can verify this by checking the
mysql workbench or the mysql shell
you can see on the mysql workbench here
on the
left panel under schemas there is a
database called mysql underscore python
let me just expand it now we haven't
created any table so it's not showing it
now
the next step we are going to connect to
this database
so let's go ahead and connect to our
database that we have just created i'll
write the comment as connect to
database
now to connect to a database i'm again
going to create a user defined function
using the def keyword i'll write create
underscore
db which is for database underscore
connection
and the parameters it will take is the
host name
followed by the username
then we have the user password
and finally we have the
database name
i'll give a colon
in the next line i'm going to create my
variable
which is connection and then i'll assign
it to a value
none
after this i'm going to use my
exception handling techniques so i'll
write my
try block first
i'm going to reassign my connection
variable
using the
mysql connector method so i'll write
mysql dot
connector dot
connect
so this method
will take in the
parameters
so first
it will take the
host
name i'll write
host equal to
host underscore name
i'll give a comma
next it will take the
user name so user equal to user
underscore name
give another comma
next
it will take the user password
i'll use passwd equal to
user underscore password
we'll give another comma
and this time
it is going to be the database name so
i'll write database equal to db
underscore name
now
let's use the print statement
and the message we are going to print is
mysql
database
connection
successful
all right
finally
we'll write my
accept block
i'll write accept
error as err
give a colon and then i'll use the print
statement
f
within double quotes i'll write error
colon
within single quotes curly braces i'll
write err
and will close the double quotes
finally
this function
will return
the connection value
all right
let's run it and there you go
it has run successfully so we have
connected to our database
now
it's time for us to execute sql queries
i'll give another comment saying
execute
sql
queries
all right
now to execute our sql queries i'll use
another user defined function which is
execute
underscore
query
and i'll pass in the parameters as
connection and
query
give a colon
i'm going to write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
now this is used to establish a
connection and run sql statements
next we'll use the
try and accept block so i'll write try
cursor
dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
going to be my query
and then i'll write
connection
dot
commit
which is another
method now let's use the print statement
so i'll write
print
let's say the message would be query
was successful
and then
we'll write our accept block which is
accept
if the try block doesn't work throw an
error
using the print statement
within double quotes inside the
inside the curly braces i'll write err
and close the double quotes
all right so let's run it
okay so we have successfully created our
various functions that were needed to
create a database establish a connection
and to execute our queries
all right
now it's time for us to create our first
table inside the mysql underscore python
database
so to do that
i am going to write my
create command in sql
so first we are going to assign our sql
command to a python variable using
triple quotes to create a multi-line
string
so let me show you how to do that
i'll write my
variable name
which is going to be create
orders
table
it is always recommended to use relevant
variable names to make it more readable
and now
i am going to use triple quotes
so the triple quote
will ensure
i can create my multiline string
inside the triple quote i am going to
write my
create command which is create table
here i am going to create an orders
table first
and
inside the orders table i am going to
create my
column names the first column would be
the order id
it is going to be of type integer and
i'll assign this order id as my primary
key column
will give a comma
next
the second column would be
customer
underscore name
the customer name column would be of
type
varying character so i'll write varchar
and i'll give a size of 30
and
this is also going to be
not null
moving ahead my fourth column would be
the product name column
so i'll write product underscore name
product name will be of type
varying character the size is let's say
and it is also not null
next
i'm going to create my
fourth column which is the date on which
the item was ordered or the product was
ordered
so i'll write date ordered
the data type will be date
next
i'll create
a quantity column to keep track of the
number of quantities that were ordered
this is of type
integer
my next column would be unit price which
will basically have information about
the price of each unit of product
unit price can be of type float
and finally i'll have the
phone number of the customer
i'll write phone number phone number can
be kept as of type
varying character
i have assigned a size of 20.
now let's give a semicolon and
will
close the
triple quotes
all right
so this is how the syntax would look
like
next
to run this we are first going to
call our create db function so let me
give a comment as
connect to the database
i'll write connection
equal to
create underscore db underscore
connection
my parameters would be
my host name which is localhost
my username which is root
comma my password
and then my database name which is
mysql underscore python so i'll write
just db
all right
finally let's execute this query using
the execute underscore
query function that we had created
earlier
this takes in two parameter the first
one is connection
followed by
the variable name which is create
orders underscore table
let us run it
okay there is some error here let's see
what's the error
okay so here we have put four
double quotes this should be triple
quotes now let's run it
okay there is another here let's debug
it
it says name cursor not defined
let me just roll it to the above cell if
you see here in our
execute underscore query
function instead of
cursor
i have written cursor so r is missing
let's read on this
and now let's run this again
there you go you can see here mysql
database connection successful even our
query was also successful
now if you want to recheck if the table
that is orders was created or not you
can check it on the mysql workbench so
let me show you how to do it so i am on
my mysql workbench and under mysql
underscore python database you have
something called as tables let me just
right click and i'll select
refresh all there you go you can see
this arrow just click on this arrow
and here you can see we have a table
called orders so we have created a table
called orders
now you can check the columns as well
you have the order id you have the order
id the customer name product name
ordered
date quantity unit price and phone
number
now it's time for us to insert a few
records to this table which is orders
now to insert records i'll give a
comment as insert
data
i'll start with the
variable name let's say the variable
name is data underscore
orders
i'll give triple quotes
next
i'll write my insert into command so
i'll write insert
into
my table name that is orders
followed by
values
and now i'll start entering
my records for each of the rows so first
i'll give 101 which is the order id
then i'll give the
customer's name let's say steve
and the product he had ordered is let's
say laptop
then i'll give my date in which the item
was ordered
let's say it is 2018
i'll choose
0 6 as the month and the date is let's
say 12
will give another comma this time we'll
pass in the quantity which is two
let's say the price of each laptop
number this is random let's say six 2
let's say
all right similarly i am going to insert
five more records of different customers
and their items that they have purchased
to this table orders
so here on my notepad i have my rest of
the five records let me just copy it and
we'll
paste it in the
cell here this will save us some time
okay
let me recheck if everything is fine
i'll give a comma here all right so we
have
six customers in our table which have
their customer ids from 101 to 106. we
have steve
jaws stacy nancy maria and danny you
have the different items they have
purchased laptop books trousers t-shirts
headphones and smart tv is the date on
which they had ordered this item the
number of quantities they had ordered
and then we have the unit price and some
random phone numbers
so let's
create the connection now i'll write
connection
equal to
i'll write create underscore db
underscore connection
then i'm going to give my same
parameters let me just copy it from the
top which is localhost
the hostname
root is my username then we have
password and the database name
and then
i'll use the same query as above which
is execute query
i'll copy this
paste it here and instead of create
orders table variable i'll put as data
underscore orders
so this will store my
insert into command you can see the
variable i have used here is data
underscore orders
now it's time let's just run it all
right
there was some mistake here let's debug
it
again this should be triple quotes and
not
four now let me rerun it again there you
go you can see here mysql database
connection successful and my query was
also successful
now
we'll create
another user defined function which will
help us read query and display the
results
so i'll write
my function name as
df
read underscore
query
this will take in two parameters
connection and query
then i'll write
cursor
equal to
connection dot cursor
i'll put my
result as none
and then i'll use my
try and accept block i'll write try
cursor dot
execute
this will take in one parameter which is
query and then i'll
give another variable which is result
equal to
cursor dot
fetch
all now this fetch all method
will return
all the
results in the table
i'll write return
result
next
we'll use the accept block
so i'll write accept
error as er give a colon and i'll use my
print statement
scroll this down
i'll use my formatting f
error
give a colon followed by a space
within single quotes
inside curly braces i'll give err and
close my double quotes
let's run it
all right
so now we are all set
now we are going to use our select
clause having whereby
then we'll see how to use order by
clause
some inbuilt functions we'll update some
records delete some records and do a lot
of other stuff
so
let's start with our first query
so our first query is going to be using
the
select statement
all right
so suppose
i want to display all the records that
we have inserted into our orders table
so the way to do is
i'll
assign my query to a variable let's say
q1
i'll give
triple quotes
within triple quotes i'll write select
star from orders
will give a semicolon followed by the
triple quotes
now we'll establish the connection so
let me just go to the top
and i'll copy this line
which is to connect to our database
i'll paste it here
now we'll
create a variable called results that
will store the result of this query
and we are going to assign this variable
to our function that is read query and
this read query will have
two parameters the connection and the
variable name which is q1 for the query
next to display i am going to use a for
loop i'll write for
results
for result
in
results
print
i'll say result
now we are done
let's just run this query
there you go you can see here you have
successfully printed
all the rows in our table which is
orders you can see we have six records
in total
now we are going to explore a few more
queries so let me just copy this and we
are going to edit in the same query i'll
paste it here
next
let's say you want to display
individual columns from the table and
not all the columns so let me
let me create the variable q2
now instead of star i am going to
display only the customer name
and let's see the phone numbers of the
customer so i'll write phone underscore
number
all right the rest all remains the same
let me just recheck it and here instead
of
q1 we'll put q2
and
let's run this cell all right you can
see here now we have displayed only two
columns the first column is the customer
name and then we have the respective
phone numbers
okay
now let me just paste that query again
now we are going to see how you can use
an inbuilt function
that is
in our table we have the
order date and from the order date we
are only going to
display the different years that are
present in the order date
so to do that i am going to use the year
function i'll add this query instead of
q1 i'll make it q3
and here i'm going to write select
here which is my function name from my
column which is date ordered
from orders and here i'll change this to
q3
q1 q2 q3 are basically query 1 query 2
and query 3 let's run it
there you go so we have successfully
extracted the different years present in
the order date column
now if you want to display the distinct
or the unique dates present in the
column
you can
use the extent keyword in the select
statement
so the way to do it is i'll write select
distinct
give a space
the rest of the query remains the same
and here instead of q3 i'll write q4
i'll make this as q4
let's run it
you can see 2018 and 2019 are the unique
year values that are present in the
order date column
okay now moving ahead
let's write our fifth query and this
time we are going to explore how you can
use the where clause
so i'll change this to q5
before i write my query
so let's say you want to display all the
orders
that were ordered before
31st of december 2018.
so to filter this we are going to use
the where clause
so i'll write select
star
from orders
next i'll write where
my date underscore ordered
is less than
within course i'll give my date value
which is 2018 december
31st
so all the items or the products that
were ordered before 31st of december
2018 will be displayed so let's run it
all right you can see here there are
three orders in our table which have
been ordered before
31st of december
now moving ahead
we want to display
all the orders that were made after 31st
of december
so here
what you can do is i'll just copy the
above query again i'll copy this line
so instead of less than
31st of december 2018 i'll make it as
greater than so every order that was
placed after
31st of december will be displayed
if you run it so you can see here there
are three orders in our table which were
ordered after 31st of december 2018.
now moving ahead
let's write a seventh query
now let's see
how the order by clause works in sql so
you can filter your results based on a
particular column or sort it based on a
particular column
so this is going to be my query seven
i'll write it from scratch again let's
see
you want to display all the columns from
the table so i'll write select star from
orders
then i'm going to use order by
unit price
i'll give a
semicolon let's run this query and see
the output
if you see the result here
and you mark the
unit price column
the result has been ordered in ascending
order of unit price you see here it
starts with the lowest price and then
goes on with the highest price towards
the end now if you want to order it in
descending order you can use the keyword
desc
so this will ensure your top
or the most expensive products appear at
the top and the least expensive products
appear at the bottom
all right
next
now let's see how you can create a data
frame
from the given table
so as you know
using jupyter notebook and pandas you
can create data frames and work on it
very easily so with this table also we
can create our own data frame
so for that let me create an empty list
first i'll write from
db
equal to i'll assign this as an empty
list
so we are going to return a list of
lists and then create a pandas data
frame
next i'll write my for loop i'll write
for result in
results
i'll assign result
to
list of results so i'm converting the
result into a list
and then i'm going to append it to the
empty variable or the empty list which
is from underscore db dot
append
i'll append the result to
my empty list
next
we need to pass in the
columns now that will be part of our
data frame so i'll write
columns equal to
this column i'll pass it
within
a list so i'll give my first column as
order id
then we have the
customer name
next i have my
product name
good grammar and spelling are important
but if you want to write these sentences
ordered
give a comma and then we'll have the
quantity column
let me write it in the next line
next we have the unit price column
and
finally we have the
phone number column so i'll write within
double course
phone number
and this
we are going to assign it to a data
frame so i'll be using
pdot data frame which is my function to
convert a list into a data frame
my variable i'm going to pass is from
underscore db
and i'll write
my next argument is columns equal to
[Music]
my
variable name that is columns
finally let's display
the data frame which is df
all right
so here i'm creating a empty list first
and then
i am creating a
for loop and i am appending the results
to my empty list
here you can see i have created
kind of data frame ready or this is the
index column it starts from zero onwards
and then we have the differences
okay so that you think now let's see how
to use the update command button
fingerprint
do i have to take them all out
well suppose power button thinks that
it's permanently pressing change the
unit price of one of these turning
itself it doesn't even turn on you can
use the update command so the way to do
it
now we're gonna close this thing create
my variable let's say update it take
your overall crease
give three
codes or triple quotes
then i'll use my update command which is
update followed by the table name that
is orders
next i'll write set
let's say unit underscore price
if you see this
let's say i want to set the unit price
of trousers from 50 dollars to let's say
45 dollars i want to update this
particular record so i am going to write
set unit price column
equal to
45 dollars where
the order id equal to
so this query will update the
third row in our table which is order
id103
so it will update from 50 to 45
i'll close the triple quotes
and now
i'll use the
connection
queries again
let me just paste it here
all right
i'll delete
these three lines of code and instead of
that i'll put execute
underscore
query
and this will take in two parameters as
always which is going to be connection
followed by the variable name that is
update
let's run it you see here it says mysql
database connection successful query was
successful
now you can recheck that
to do it let me just go to the top and
we'll
just copy our first query which is q1
i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let me just rename this now
this will be
q8
and i'll change this as well i'll write
select star from orders where
my order id equal to 103.
let's see the unit price of 103 now
you can see here instead of 50 now we
updated it to 45
all right
now the last command we are going to say
is how you can delete a record from the
table
i'll write delete command as my comment
now to delete a query
i'll first
give my variable name which is delete
underscore order
and i'll pass in within
triple quotes
next i'll write my delete query which is
delete from my table name that is orders
then i'll give my where clause where
let's say i want to delete my order id
105.
let me just go to the top and explain
you again
so if you see this we want to delete
the order id 105 which was for customer
name maria and she had ordered
headphones we want to completely remove
this particular record
so
i have my delete query ready
now let me just
create my connection and display the
results
so i'll go to the top and i'll copy this
connection command
which also has the execute query command
and i'll paste it here
and i'm going to make a change here
instead of update we'll write
delete underscore order
everything looks good let's just run it
you can see our query was successful
and now
if you want to
print it let me just show you
i'll just copy this
we'll paste it here
i'll make this as q9
i want to verify if
my order id 105 was deleted or not
instead of
the statement i'll write select star
from orders
and here i'll change this to q9
if i run this
you can see it here you can mark order
id 105 was deleted and it no more
appears in this table
all right so this brings us to the end
of the demo session on sql with python
let me just
scroll you through what we did so first
we imported the important libraries
mysql connector then we imported the
error function then we imported pandas
using pd
we learned how to create a server
connection to mysql database we created
a new database that is mysql underscore
python
and now we connected to that database
we created a function to execute our
queries we saw how you can write a
create table command
then we inserted a few records to our
orders table
we created a read underscore query
command to read the queries and display
the results then we started exploring
our
different sql commands one by one we saw
how to use
select query
then we selected a few individual
columns from our table
followed by using a
inbuilt function which was here then we
saw how to use the dixtend keyword
after that we used our where clause to
filter a table based on specific
conditions
we saw how to order your results based
on a particular column
then we saw how you could convert the
table into a data frame using
pd.dataframe function
finally we learned how to use the update
command and the
delete command postgresql is a very
popular and widely used database in the
industries in this tutorial we will
learn postgres sql or postgresql in
detail with an extensive demo session
so in today's video we will learn what
postgres sequel is and look at the
history of postgres sql
we will learn the features of postgres
sql and jump into performing postgres
sql commands on the sql cell and pg
admin so let's begin by understanding
what is postgresql
postgresql is an open source object
relational database management system
it stores data in rows with columns as
different data attributes
according to the db engine's ranking
postgres sql is currently ranked fourth
in popularity amongst hundreds of
databases worldwide it allows you to
store process and retrieve data safely
it was doubled by a worldwide team of
volunteers
now let's look at the history of
postgres sequel
so in 1977 onwards the ingress project
was developed at the university of
california berkeley
in 1986 the post chris project was led
by professor michael stonebreaker in
1987 the first demo version was released
and in 1994 a sql interp
customer name
next i have my
product name
good grammar and spelling are important
but if you want to write
give a comma and then we'll have the
quantity column
[Music]
let me write it in the next line
next we have the unit price column
and
finally we have the
phone number column so i'll write within
double quotes
phone number
and this
we are going to assign it to a data
frame so i'll be using pd dot
data frame which is my function to
convert a list into a data frame
[Music]
that will help you display all the
databases that are already there so if i
hit
sql or postgresql in dt
with an extensive demo session
so in today's video we will learn what
postgres sql is and look at the history
of postgres sql
we will learn the features of postgres
sql and jump into performing postgres
sql commands on the sql cell and pg
admin so let's begin by understanding
what is postgresql
postgresql
is an open source
object relational database management
system it stores data in rows with
columns as different data attributes
according to the db engine's ranking
postgres sql is currently ranked fourth
in popularity amongst hundreds of
databases worldwide it allows you to
store process and retrieve data safely
it was developed by a worldwide team of
volunteers
now let's look at the history of
postgresql
so in 1977 onwards the ingress project
was developed at the university of
california berkeley
in 1986 the post chris project was led
by professor michael stonebreaker in
1987 the first demo version was released
and in 1994 a sql interpreter was added
to postgres
the first postgres sql release was known
as version 6.0 or 6.0 on january 29 1997
and since then postgres sql has
continued to be developed by the
postgres sql global development group a
diverse group of companies and many
thousands of individual contributors
now let's look at some of the important
features of postgres sql
so postgres sql is the world's most
advanced open source database and is
free to download
it is compatible as it supports multiple
operating systems such as windows linux
and mac os
it is highly secure robust and reliable
postgres sql supports multiple
programming interfaces such as c c plus
java and python
postgres sql is compatible with various
data types it can work with primitives
like integers numeric string and boolean
it supports structured data types such
as date and time array and range
it can also work with documents such as
json and xml
and finally postgres sql supports
multiversion concurrency control or mvcc
now with this theory knowledge let's
look at the postgresql commands that we
will be covering in the demo
so we will start with the basic command
such as select update and delete
we will learn how to filter data using
where clause and having clause in sql
we will also look at how to group data
using the group by clause and order the
result using the order by clause you
will learn how to deal with null values
get an idea about the like operator
logical operators such as and and or
we will also explore some of the popular
inbuilt mathematical and string
functions
finally we'll see some of the advanced
concepts in postgres sql that is to
write
case statements sub queries and user
defined functions
so let's head over to the demo now okay
so let's now start with our demo so
first we'll connect to postgresql using
psql cell
so here
under type here to search i'll search
for
psql
you can see this is the sql cell i'll
click on open
let me
maximize this okay
so for server i'll just click enter
database i'll click enter port number is
already taken which is
5432 i'll hit enter username is already
given and now it is going to ask for
password so here i'll give my password
so that i can connect to my postgresql
database so it has given us a warning
but we have successfully connected to
postgresql
all right
so now to check if everything is fine
you can just run a simple command to
check the version of postgre sql that we
have loaded so the command is
select
version
with two brackets
and a semicolon
i'll hit enter
okay you can see the version postgresql
13.2
okay
now
let me show you the command
that will help you display all the
databases that are already there so if i
hit
slash
l
and hit enter
it will give me the list of databases
that are already there so we have
postgresql there's something called
template 0 template 1 and we have a test
database as well
ok
now for our demo i'll create a new
database so first i'll write
create
space
database
and i'll give my database name as sql
underscore demo
i'll give a semicolon and hit enter
you see we have a message here that says
create database so we successfully
created our
sql demo database
now if you want to
connect to that database you can use
backslash c
space
sql underscore demo
there you go it says you are now
connected to database sql underscore
demo so here we can now create tables we
can perform insert operation select
operation update delete alter
and much more
now i'll show you how to connect to
postgresql using pg admin
so when you install the postgresql
database
you will get the sql cell and along with
that you also have the pg admin
so i'll just search for
pg
you can see here
it has prompted pg admin i'll click on
open
this will open on a web browser
you can see it has opened on chrome
and this is how the interface of pg
admin looks like it is a very basic
interface so on the top you can see the
files we have
object there's tools and we have the
help section as well and here you have
dashboard properties sql statistics
dependencies
dependence
and here on the left panel you have
servers let me just expand this so it
will connect to
one of the databases
all right
so if i go back
you see
when i had run backslash l to display
the databases it had shown me postgres
sql and test
now you can see here we have the
postgresql database and the test
database
all right
now
we also created one more database which
was sql demo
so
let me show you how to work on
this pg admin and the query tool
all right so i'll
right click on
sql demo
and i'll select query tool
i'll just show you how to run a few
commands on the query tool so let's say
you want to see the
version of postgresql that you are using
so you can use the same command that we
did on psql cell which is select version
closed with brackets and a semicolon
i'll select this
and here you can see we have the
execute button so if i
hit execute or press
f5
it will run that query you can see we
have the
output at the bottom and it says
postgresql 13.2
compiled
by visual c plus plus it has a 64-bit
system
okay
now let me tell you how to perform a few
basic operations using postgresql
commands
so here
let's say i'll write
select 5
into
i'll give a semicolon
select this and hit
f5
so this will run the query and it
returns me the result that is the
product of 5 and 3 which is 15
similarly let's
edit this
let's say i'll write 5 plus 3
plus
let's say 6
i'll select this
and hit
f5 to run it
it gives me the sum of 5 plus 3 plus 6
which is 14. now the same task you can
do it on this cell as well
let me show you how to do it here
so let's say i'll write select
let's say i want to multiply
into
let's say 10
you know the result it should be 70 if i
hit enter it gives me
70.
now this question mark column question
wall we'll deal with this later
all right
let me go back to my pg admin again
let me
do one more operation let's say this
time i'll write select
five multiplied by
and within brackets i'll write 3 plus 4
i'll give a semicolon
so what sql will do is first it will
evaluate the expression that is there
inside the bracket that is 3 plus 4
which is 7 and then it will multiply 7
with 5.
now let me select this and i'll hit
execute
so you can see 7 multiplied by 5 is 35
all right now
we'll go back to our
shell and here i'll show you how to
create a table
so we are going to create a table called
movies on the cell that is psql cell
so here we will learn how you can create
a table and then you can enter a few
data into that table
all right
let me just scroll down a bit okay
so my create command
goes something like this
so i'll write create
table
followed by the table name that is
movies
next
my movies
table will have a few columns let's say
i want the movie id
after the column name
we need to give the data type so movie
id i'll keep it as integer
so integer is one of the data types that
is provided by postgresql
next
my
second column the table would be
the name of the movie so i'll write
movie underscore name
so
all the variables or the column name
should be
as per sql standard so there shouldn't
be any space between the column name so
i have used underscore
to make it more readable
so
my movie name
will be of type
var car or variable character
or varying character
and i'll give this size as 40 so that it
can hold 40 characters maximum
next
my third column will have the genre of
the movie so i'll write movie underscore
genre
again genre is of type worker
i'll give the size as let's say 30
and
my final and the last column will have
the imdb rating so i'll write
imdb
underscore
ratings
now the ratings will be of type real
since it can have floating or decimal
point values
if i close the bracket
i'll give a semicolon and i'll hit enter
there you go so we have successfully
created a table called
movies
now let me go back to my pg admin
all right so here i have my database
that is sql demo i'll just
right click on this and click on refresh
now let me go to
schemas
i'll just scroll down a bit
here under schemas we have something
called as tables
let me
expand this
okay so you can see we have a table
called
movies
in the
sql demo database now
and here you can check the columns that
we have just added so our movies table
has movie id movie name genre and
ratings
all right now there is another way to
create a table
the previous time we created using the
sql cell
now i will tell you how to create a
table using the pg admin
so here under tables i'll right click
and
i have the option to create a table so
i'll select table
okay
so it's asking me to
give the name of the table so this time
we are going to create a table called
students so i will write my table name
as students
all right
these will be
default as it is
now i will go to the columns tab
so here you can create the
number of columns that you want
so
you can see on the right i have a plus
sign i'll just
select this so that i can add a new row
so my first column would be let's say
the student roll number
i'll write student underscore role
number again the
column name should be as per
sql standards
the data type i am going to select is
integer
all right
now if you want you can give these
constraints such as not null so that
student roll number column will not have
any null values
and
i'll also check primary key which means
all the values will be unique
for roll numbers
all right if you want to add
another column
you can just click on that plus sign and
let's say this time i want to give the
student name
as my second column so i'll write
student underscore name
student name will be of type
let's say
character
varying
if you want to give the length you can
specify the length as well let's say 40
i'll click on the plus sign again to add
my
final column the final column would be
gender
so gender i'll keep this time as type
character
okay
now you can
click on save so that will successfully
create your students table
there you go so here on the left panel
you can see earlier we had only one
table that was movies and now we have
two tables so one would be added that
was students so if i expand this under
columns you can see
we have the three columns here student
rule number student name and gender
you can also check the constraints
it will tell you if you have any
constants so you can see it says
students
roll number there's one primary key all
right
all right now let me run a select
statement
to show the columns that we have in the
movies table
so i'll write select star from
movies
give a semicolon
and let me execute this
okay so here on the at the bottom you
can see we have the movie id the movie
name movie genre and imdb ratings
now the next command we are going to
learn is how to delete a table
so
there is one way by using the
sql command that is drop table
followed by the table name let's say you
want to delete students
you can write drop table students and
that will
delete the table from the database this
is one of the methods so you just select
and run it now the other way is to
you just right click
on the table name and here you have
delete slash drop
if i select this you get a prompt are
you sure you want to drop table students
i'll select yes
so you can see
we have successfully deleted our
students table
all right
now
let's perform a few operations and learn
a few more commands in postgresql
so to do that i'm going to insert a few
records to my movies table
so for that i'll use my
insert command
so i have my insert
query written on a notepad i'll just
copy this
and i'll
paste it
on my query editor
okay
so let me just scroll down
all right so here you can see i have
used my
insert command so i have written insert
into
the name of the table that is movies and
we have the movie id the movie name
movie genre and imdb ratings
and
these are
the records
or the rose so we have the first record
as movie id101 the name of the movie is
a very popular movie which is vertigo
then we have the movie genre that is
mystery
it is also
a romance movie and then we have the
imdb ratings the current imdb rating
that is 8.3 similarly we have sawshank
redemption we have 12 angry men there's
the matrix 7 interstellar and the lion
king so there are total eight records
that we are going to insert into our
movies table
so let me just select this and hit
execute
okay you can see it has returned
successfully
eight records
now
if i run
select star from movies you can see
the records
that are present in the table so i'll
write select star from movies
i'll select this and i'll execute it
there you go at the bottom you can see
eight rows affected if i scroll this
down you have the
eight records of information in the
movies table
all right
now if you want to
describe the table you can go to
the sql cell
and here
if you write
backslash d and the name of the table
that is movies this will describe the
table so here you have the column names
this has the data type and here you can
specify if there are any null values or
any
constraints like default constraint or
primary key or foreign key and others
let me go back to my pg admin
okay
now first and foremost
let me tell you how to
update records in a table so suppose you
have an existing table and by mistake
you have
entered some
wrong values and you want to
update those records later you can use
the update query for that
so
i am going to update my movies table and
i'll set the genre of movie id 103 which
is 12 angry men
from drama to drama and crime
so
in our current table we only have
genres drama for 12 angry men i am going
to update this column which is the movie
genre to drama and crime
okay
so let me show you how to do it
i'll write
update
followed by
the name of the table that is movies
go to the next line
i'll write set
then i'll give the column name which is
movie
underscore genre
equal to i'm going to set it as
drama
comma
crime earlier it was only
drama
and i'll give my condition
using the where clause
will learn where clause in a bit so i'll
write where
movie underscore
id is equal to 103
so here our movie id is the unique
identifier so it will first look for
movie id103 it will locate that movie
and it'll change the genre to drama and
crime so now you can see the difference
earlier we had 12 angry men as drama as
the movie genre now if i
run this update statement
okay you can see we have successfully
updated one record now let me run the
select statement again
okay so here you can see if i scroll
down
there you go so movie id 103 movie name
12 angry men we have successfully
updated the genre as drama comma crime
okay
now
let me tell you how you can delete
records from a table
so for that you can use the
delete command so you'll write delete
from
the table name that is movies
where let's say i want to delete
the movie id 108 which is the lion king
so i'll write where
movie underscore id
is equal to
108. this is one of the ways to delete
this particular movie or you can give
let's say
where movie name is equal to the lion
king
let me
select this and i'll hit
execute
now if i run my select query again
you see this time it has returned seven
rows and you cannot
find
movie with movie id108 that was the lion
king so we have deleted it
all right
next
we are going to learn about where clause
in postgres sql
so
to learn where clause
i'll be using the same movie table again
let's say
we want to filter only those records for
which
the imdb ratings of the movies is
greater than 8.7
so this is my updated table now
i want to
display only those records or those
movies whose imdb ratings is greater
than 8.7
so we'll display 12 angry men which is 9
then we are going to display
the dark knight which is again 9 and we
are also going to display the saw shank
redemption which has 9.3 the rest of the
movies have
an imdb rating
less than 8.7 so we are not going to
display those
all right so let me show you how to
write a where clause
so i'll write select
star
from
movies
where
i'll give my column name that is imdb
underscore ratings
is greater than i'll use the greater
than symbol
then i'll pass my value that is 8.7
i'll give a semicolon and let's run it
i'll hit
f5
there you go so we have returned the
shawshank redemption dark knight and 12
angry men because only these movies had
imdb ratings greater than 8.7
okay
now let's say
you want to return only those movies
which have imdb ratings between 8.5 and
9.
so for that i am going to use another
operator called between along with the
where clause
so let me show you how to use between
with where clause
i'll write select star from
movies
where
my imdb underscore
ratings
is between
i'll write
8.5
i'll give an and operator
and 9.0
so all the movies that are between 8.5
and 9.0 ratings will be displayed
so let's select this and i'll run it
there you go so we have returned
the dark knight the matrix the seven
interstellar and we have the 12 angry
men
so a few of the records that we missed
out were i think vertigo which has 8.3
and there's one more
all right
now moving ahead
let's say you want to display the movies
whose movie genre is action
so you can see in our table we have a
few movies
whose genre is action movie so you can
do that as well
i'll write select star from
movies
where
the movie genre i am writing this time
in one line
you can break it into two lines as well
i'll write movie underscore genre which
is my column name
equal to
i'll give within single quotes action
now why single quote because action is a
string hence we need to put it in
single quotes
if i run this
there you go so we had one
movie in our table whose movie genre was
action that is the dark knight
okay
now
you can also select
particular columns
from the table by specifying the column
names now here in all the examples that
we saw just now we are using star now
star represents it will select all the
columns in the table if you want to
select specific columns in the table you
can use the
column names so you can specify the
column names in the select statement
let me show you let's say you want to
display the movie name and the movie
genre from the table so you can write
select
movie
underscore name
comma
i'll give the next column as movie
underscore
genre
from
my table name that is movies
where
let's say the imdb underscore
ratings
is
less than
9.0
so this time in our result it will only
show two columns that is movie name and
movie genre let me run it there you go
so these are the movie names and the
movie genres you can see
that have an imdb ratings less than 9.0
all right
like how you saw the between operator
there is one more operator that you can
use with the where clause that is the in
operator so the in operator works like a
or clause or an or operator
so let's say
i want to select
all the columns from my movies table
where
the imdb
ratings
is in
8.7
or
9.0
if i run this
it will display only those records whose
imdb ratings is 8.7 or 9.0
all right
so up to now we have looked at how you
can
work on basic operations in sql like
your mathematical operations you saw how
a select statement works we created a
few tables then we inserted a few
records to our tables we saw how you can
delete a table from your database
and we have performed a few operations
like update delete and we saw how a
where clause works
now it's time to load a
employee csv file
or a csv data set to postgres sql so
i'll tell you how you can do that but
first of all before loading or inserting
the records we need to create an
employee table
so let me first go ahead and
create a new table called employees in
our sql underscore demo database
so i'll write
create
table
my name of the table would be
employees
next
i'm going to give my
column names
so my first column would be employee id
so the employee id will be of type
integer
it is not going to contain any null
values so i'll write
not null and i'll give my
constraint as
primary key so the employee id as you
know is unique for all the employees in
a company
so once i write primary key it will
ensure that there are no repetition
in the employee ids
okay
next i'll have my employee name
so my employee name is going to be of
type var car
and i'll give my size as 40.
okay
next we'll have the email address of the
employee again email address would be of
type
barcar and the size is 40 again
i'll give another comma
this time we'll have the gender of the
employee
gender is again worker of size let's say
okay
now let's
include a few more columns we'll have
the department column so i'll write
department
barcar
let's say the size is 40
then let's say we'll have another column
that is called address
so the address column will have the
country names of the employees
address is also varchar
and finally we have the salary of the
employee salary i'm going to keep it as
type real
so real will ensure it will have decimal
or floating point values
okay so now let me select this
create table statement and execute it
all right so we have successfully
created our table
if you want you can
check
by using select star from employees
let me select this and i'll hit execute
all right you can see we have our
employee id as primary key there's
employee name email gender
this department address and salary but
we don't have any records for each of
these columns now it's time for us to
insert a few records to our employees
table
now to do that
i am going to use a csv file so let me
show you how the csv file looks like
okay so now i am on my microsoft excel
sheet and on the top you can see this is
my employee data.csv file
here we have the employee id the
employee name email gender this
department
address and salary now this data was
generated using a stimulator so
this is not validated and you can see it
has a few missing values
so under email column you have a few
employees who don't have an email id
then you can see under department also
there are some missing values here as
well all right so we'll be importing
this
table
or the records present in this csv file
onto postgresql
all right
so here in the left panel under tables
let me right click and first
refresh this
there you go so initially we had only
movies table and now we also have the
employees table
now what we need to do is i'll right
click again and here
you see we have the option to import or
export
let me click on this
and
i don't want to export i need to import
so i'll switch on import
all right
now it is asking me to give the file
location so let me show you how to get
the file location
so this is my file location actually so
my
excel file which was this
is present
in my e drive under the data analytics
folder i have another folder called
postgresql
and
within the postgresql folder i have my
csv file that is employed csv
so i'll just
select this
you can either
do it like this or you can browse and do
okay
now my format is csv
next
i'm going to
select
my headers as yes
and then
let me go to columns and check if
everything is fine all right so i have
all my columns here let's click on ok
you can see i have a message here which
says import underscore export
all right so here you can see
successfully completed
we can verify this by using select star
from employees again
if i run this
all right let me close this
there you go it says 150 rows affected
which means we have inserted 150 rows of
information to our employees table
you can see we have the employee id
these are all unique we have the
employee name the email we have the
address and the salary
let me scroll down
so that
okay you can see we have 150 rows of
information
that means we have 150 employees in our
table
okay
now we are going to use this employees
table and explore
some advanced sql commands
now there is an operator
called extinct
so
say if i write select
address
from
employees
this is going to give me 150
address of all the employees
there's some problem here i did a
spelling mistake there should be another
d
if i run this again
i'll query will return 150 rows
you can see we have the different
country names under address that is
russia we have france there's united
states
we have germany
okay and i think we have israel as well
yeah
now suppose you want to display only the
unique address or the country names you
can use
the distinct
keyword
before the column name so if i write
select distinct address from employee
it will only display the unique
country names present in the address
column if i run this
see it has
returned us six rows of information so
we have israel russia australia united
states france and germany
all right
now as i said there are a few null
values which don't have any information
so you can use
the is null operator in sql to display
all the null values that are there
suppose i want to display all the
employee names
where the email id has a null value so i
write select star from
employees
where
email is
null
so this is another way to use your where
clause
if i
select and run this
there you go
so you see here
for all these employee names
there was no email id present in the
table
so it has returned us
16 rows of information so around 10
percent of employees do not have an
email id
and if you see a few of them do not have
an email id and also they don't have a
department so if you want to know for
those employees which do not have a
department you can just replace where
department is null instead of where
email is null
now if i select this
okay it has returned us nine rows of
information
which means
around five percent of employees do not
have a department
moving ahead
now let me show you
how the order by clause works in
sql now the order by is used to
order your result in a particular
format let's say in ascending or
descending order
so
the way to use is
let's say i want to select
all the employees from my table so i'll
write select star from
employees
order by
i want to order the employees based on
their salary
so i'll write order by salary
let me
select and run it
okay there is some problem i made a
spelling mistake this should be
employees
let me run it again
okay now if you mark the
output
a result has been ordered in
ascending order so all the
employees which have salary
greater than
forty five thousand dollars appear at
the top
and the
employees with the
highest salaries
appear at the bottom so this has been
ordered in ascending order which means
your sql or postgresql
orders it in ascending order by default
now let's say you want to display the
salaries in descending order so that all
the top ranking employees
in terms of salary appear at the top
so you can use the desc keyword which
means descending if i run this
you can see the difference now
so all the
employees with the highest salary appear
at the top while those with the lowest
salaries appear at the bottom
so this is how you can use an order by
clause
okay
so now i want to make a change in my
existing table so here if you see
under the address column we only have
the country names so it would be better
if we change the
name of the address column to
country
so i want to rename a column you can do
this using the alter command in
postgresql so let me show you how to
rename this column that is address so
i'll write
alter
table followed by the table name which
is employees
then i'm going to use a rename
column
address
i'll write 2 i want to change it to
country if i give a semicolon and hit
execute
it will change my
column name to
country now you can verify this if i run
the select statement again
there you go earlier it was address
column and now we have successfully
changed it to country column
okay
let me come down
now it's time for us to explore a few
more commands
so this time i'm going to tell you how
an and and an or operator works in sql
so you can use the and and or operator
along with the where clause so let's say
i want to select the employees
who are from france and their salary is
less than eighty thousand dollars
so let me show you how to do it
and right select
star
from
employees
where
i'm going to give two conditions so i'll
use the
and clause or the and operator here i'll
write where country
is equal to
france
now mark here i'm not using address
because we just updated our table and
changed the column name from address to
country so i'll write country equal to
france
and
my next condition would be my salary
needs to be
less than eighty thousand dollars
i'll give a semicolon
let me
run this
all right so it has returned 19 rows of
information you can see
all my country names of france and the
salary
is
less than eighty thousand dollars
so this is how you can use
or give multiple conditions in a where
clause using the and operator
now let's say you want to use the or
operator and
let's you want to know the employees who
are from country germany
or the department should be sales
so i'll write select star from
employees
where
country
is equal to
germany
and
instead of and i'm going to use or
the department
should be sales
okay
now let's see the output i'll hit f5
this time to run it
all right so we have 23 rows of
information now
let me scroll to the right you can see
either the country is germany or the
department is sales you see
one of them
in the table so here for the first
record the country was germany the
second record the department was sales
against seals again for the fourth
record the country is germany so this is
how
the or condition works so if one of the
conditions are true it will return the
result it need not be that both the
conditions should satisfy
now
in postgresql there is another feature
that is called limit so postgresql limit
is an optional clause on the select
statement now this is used as a
constraint which will restrict the
number of rows returned by the query
suppose you want to display the top five
rows
in a table you can use the limit
operator suppose you want to
skip the first five rows of information
and then you want to display the next
five you can do that using limit and
offset
so let's explore how limit an offset
works
i'll write
select
star from
employees
let's say i'll use my order by clause
i'll write order by
salary
let's say in descending
and limit it to
this is going to display
the top five employees which have the
highest salary if i run this there you
go you see
it has given us five rows of information
and these are the top five employees
that have the highest salary
okay
so this is one method of or one way of
using the limit
clause
now in case you want to skip a number of
rows before returning the result you can
use offset class placed before the limit
clause
so i'll write select star from
employees
let's say
order by
salary
descending
this time i am going to use limit 5
and
offset
so what this query will do is it will
skip the first
3 rows and then it will print the next 5
rows
if i run this
there you go so this is how the result
looks like
okay
now there is another clause which is
called fetch let me show you how that
works i'll copy my
previous sql query i'll paste it here
and
here
after descending
i'm going to write
fetch
first
three
row only
so my fetch is going to give me the
first three rows from the top
there you go it has given us the first
three rows
and you can see the top
three employees that have the highest
salary since we ordered it in descending
order of salary
all right
you can also use the offset along with
the
fetch clause
i'll copy this again
and let me paste it here
now
after descending i am going to write
offset
let's say three rows
and fetch
first
five rows only
so what this sql query is going to do is
it will skip the first three rows of
information and then it is going to
display the
next five rows it is going to work
exactly the same
as we saw for this query
let me run it
there you go so these are the first
five rows of information after excluding
the top three rows
all right
we have
another operator that is called as like
in postgresql so like is used to do
pattern matching
so suppose you have a table that has the
employee names you forgot the
full name of an employee but you
remember the few initials so you can use
the like operator to get an idea as to
which employee name it is
now let's explore some examples to learn
how
the like operator works in postgres sql
so suppose you want to know the
employees whose name starts with a so
for that you can use the like operator
let me show you how to do it so i want
to display the
employee name
and let's say i want to know their email
ids
from
the table name that is
employee
where
since i want to know the employees whose
name starts with a so i'll write
employee name
like now to use the pattern is within
single cores i'll write a and then
followed by percentage now this means
the employee name should have an a in
the beginning and percentage suggests
it can have any other letter
following e
but in the beginning
or the starting should be a
if i run this
so there is an error here the name of
the table is employees and not employee
let's run this again
there you go you can see there are 16
employees in our table whose name starts
with a you can see this column employee
name all of them
have a letter a in the beginning
okay
now let me just
copy this command or the query
i'll paste it here let's say this time
you want to know the employees whose
name starts with s so instead of a i'll
write s
so this means the starting letter should
be s and followed by it can have any
other letter
if i run this
so there are 10 employees in the table
whose name starts with s
okay
let's copy the query again and this time
i want to know the employees whose name
ends with d
now the way to do it
is
instead of a percentage i'll write this
time percentage d
which means at the beginning it can have
any letter but the last letter in the
string or in the name should be
ending with d
now let me copy and run this
so there are 13 employees in the table
whose name ends with a d you can see it
here
all right now let's say you want to
find the employees
whose name contains ish or have ish in
their names so the way to do is
something like this so i'll copy this
now here instead of
a percentage i'll replace this with
percentage
ish
now this means
that
in the beginning it can have any letter
and towards the end also it can have any
letter but
this ish should appear
within the name
let me run and show it to you
okay so there is one employee whose
name contains ish you can see here
there is an ish in the last name of the
employee
all right
now suppose you want to
find the employee name which has you as
the second letter
it can have any letter in the beginning
but the second letter of the employee
name should have u now the way to do is
i'll copy this and instead of a percent
i'll write underscore
u
followed by
percent now this underscore you can
think of a blank that can take
any one letter
so the beginning can start with a b c d
or any of the 26 alphabets we have
then
then it should continue as the second
letter followed by any other letter
or letters
let me run
this
okay so there are 10 employees in the
table whose
name has a u
as the second letter you can see these
ok
now moving ahead
let me show you how you can use basic
sql functions or inbuilt functions
so
we'll explore a few mathematical
functions now
so let's say you want to find the total
sum of salary for all the employees so
for that you can use this sum function
that is
available in sql so i'll write sum
and inside the sum function i'll give my
column name that is salary
from
my table name that is
employees
let's see the result this will return
one unique value
there you go
now this is the total salary since the
value is very large it has given in
terms of e
now one thing to note here is
if you see the output
the column says sum
real so this
output column is not really readable
so sql has a method which can fix this
that is called an alias so since we are
doing an operation of summing the salary
column we can give an alias to this
operation by using the as
keyword so if i write sum of salary as
let's say total salary
then this becomes
my output column you can see the
difference if i run this
okay you can see now
in the output we have the total salary
now this is much more readable than the
previous one
so this is
a feature in excel where you can use or
give alias names to your columns
or your results
now similarly let's say you want to find
the average of salary for all the
employees now sql has a function called
avg which calculates the mean or the
average salary
if i write avg
and i can
edit my alias name as well let's see
i'll write mean salary
let's run it
you can see the average salary for all
the employees it's around 81 000
okay
now there are two more important
functions that sql provides us which is
max and minimum
so if i write
select
maximum
or max which is the function name of
salary as
let's say instead of total i'll write
maximum
so this will return me the maximum
salary of the employee
let's run it and see what is the maximum
salary that is present in the salary
column
all right so we have one like 19
616 dollars as highest salary of one of
the employees
similarly you can use the main function
as well i'll just write
minimum
and this will return me the minimum
salary
of one of the employees in the table
i'll replace the alias name as minimum
okay now run it this will give me the
minimum salary that is present at our
table so it is 45 685 dollars
okay
now let's say
you want to find
the count of department
in the employees table you can use the
count function
so if i write select
count
let's say i want to know the distinct
department name so i can write
inside the account function distinct
department
as
total departments
from
employees
let's run this
this will return me the total number of
departments that are there so it gives
me there are 12 departments
okay
now let me show you one more thing here
if i write select
department
from employees
let's run this
okay so it has returned me 150 rows of
information but what i'm going to do is
i'll
place my distinct keyword here just
before the column name so that i can
verify how many departments are there in
total
there you go so there are 13 departments
and one of them is null
so
moving ahead we'll replace this null
with
a department name by updating our table
okay
so now let's update our department
column so what we are going to do is
wherever
the department has a null value we are
going to assign a new department called
analytics so earlier we have also learnt
how to use the update command so i am
going to show it again
so we'll write update followed by the
table name that is employees
i am going to set
my column that is department
equal to
within single quotes
my name of the department would be
analytics
where
department
is
i'll say null
so wherever the department has a null
value will replace
those
information with department that is
analytics
let's run this
you can see query returned
successfully now let's say
i'll run this command again and this
time you can see the difference there
you go so we have 13 rows of information
and
there is no null department now we have
added a new department that is analytics
okay
now
we are going to explore two more crucial
commands or clauses in
sql that is grouped by and having
so let's learn how group by clause works
in postgresql
so the group by statement groups rows
that have the same values into summary
rows for example you can find the
average salary of employees in each
country or city or department
so the group by clause is used in
collaboration with the select statement
to arrange identical data into groups
so
suppose you want to find the average
salary of the employees
based
on countries you can use the group by
clause so let me show you how to do it
i'll write
select
i want the countries
and
the average salary
for each country so i'll use the average
function that is evg
and inside the function i'll pass my
column that is salary
i'll give an alias name as
let's say
average underscore salary
from my table name that is
employees
next i'm going to use my group by clause
so i'll write group by
since i want to find the average salary
for each country so i'll write group by
country name
let's give a semicolon and let me run it
i'll use
f5
there you go so here on the left you can
see the country names we have israel
russia australia united states france
and germany
and
on the right the second column you can
see the average salary for each of these
countries now you can also order the
result in whichever way you want suppose
you want to arrange the results based on
the average salary so you can use the
order by clause after the group by
clause so i'll write order by
here you can use the
alias name
that is
average salary
this is actually average underscore
salary
and let's say i want to arrange it in
descending order so i'll write dsc
now let's run this you can mark the
difference in the average
salary column
there you go
so
as per our result in united states the
average salary is the highest and if i
scroll down the average salary is the
lowest in germany now let's see one more
example using group by suppose this time
you want to find the maximum salary of
male and female employees you can do
that too
so let me show you how to do it so i'll
write select
this time we want to find the maximum
salary based on gender so i'll select my
gender column
comma and this time i'll use my max
function since i want to find the
maximum salary for male and female
employees
i'll give an alias name as
maximum
underscore
salary
from
my table that is
employees
group by
i'll write gender
okay
so let's run this
there you go you can see
so one of the female employees had a
highest salary of
one lakh nineteen thousand six hundred
and sixteen dollars while of that of a
meal was one lakh seventeen thousand six
hundred and fifty four dollars
all right now suppose you want to find
the count of employees based on each
country you can use the count function
along with the group by clause
so
i'll write the select statement select
since i want to
count the employees based on each
country so i'll first select my
country column and then i'm going to use
the count function
i'll write count emp underscore id
from
my table name that is employees
i am going to group it by
country
so this query will give me the total
number of employees from each country
you can see here israel there are
four employees
in australia there are four employees in
russia we have 80 employees in france
there were 31
in united states we have 27 so on and so
forth
now let me scroll down
okay
now it's time to explore one more clause
a very important clause
that is used in postgresql that is
having
so the having clause works like the
where clause the difference is that
where clause cannot be used with
aggregate functions the having clause is
used with the group by clause to return
those rows that meet a condition
so suppose you want to find the
countries in which the average salary is
greater than 80 000 dollars so you can
use the group by clause and the having
clause to get the result
so i'll write my select statement as
select
country comma
i want the average salary so i'll write
evg
of salary
i can give an alias name as
average
salary from
employees
now i am going to
group it by
each country so group by
country column
since i want to find the
countries in which the average salary is
greater than 80 000 so i'll use having
clause
after the group by clause
i'll write having
average of salary
is greater than
80 000
now this condition cannot be specified
in the where clause so we need a having
clause you cannot use aggregate
functions along with where clause
let me just run it now
there you go so we have
russia and united states where the
average salary is greater than 80
thousand dollars
all right
now let's say
you want to find
the count of employees in each country
where there are less than 30 employees
so for this i am going to use the count
function first let me select the country
column
then
i'm going to use the count function and
in the count function i'm going to pass
my employee id so that we can count the
number of employees
from
my table that is employees
now if you want you can use an alias
name for this as well
but i am just keeping it for the time
being
i'll write group by
country
next
i'll write having
count of
employee id
less than 30.
so this will return me
the countries in which there are less
than 30 employees
let's run it
you can see here israel australia united
states and germany are the countries in
which there are less than 30 employees
ok
now if you want you can use the order by
clause as well so suppose i will write
here
order by
count of employee id
so what this will do is it will arrange
my result
in
ascending order of
employee id count
there you can see we have successfully
arranged our result in ascending order
of
employee ids
ok
next
we are going to explore
one more feature of postgresql that is
of using a case statement
now in postgresql the case expression is
same as a file statement in any other
programming language
it allows you to add if else logic to
the query to form a powerful query
now let me just scroll down and i'll
show you how to use a case statement
this is very similar to your file
statement that you use on excel in c
plus plus in python or any other
programming language
so what i am going to do is
i am going to write a sql query that
will create a new column
and the name of the column would be
lets say salary range
so i am going to divide my salary
suppose if the salary is greater than 45
000 dollars and if it's less than fifty
five thousand dollars
in the new column that is salary range
we are going to assign a value low
salary
now if the salary is greater than fifty
five thousand dollars and if it is less
than eighty thousand dollars we are
going to assign a value that is medium
salary if the salary is greater than 80
000 will assign a value high salary
so all this we are going to do using our
case expression in postgresql
so i'll start with my select statement
but before that let me show you how to
write a comment in postgresql
so you can write a comment by giving a
double dash
comments are very helpful because they
make your codes or the scripts readable
i'll write case expression
in postgres sql
similarly if you want you can go to the
top and
let's say here you can write
with double dash
having clause
okay
let's come down
so i'll write my select statement as
select
i want the department
the country
and the salary column
i'll give a comma
and i'll start with my
case statement i'll write case
when
my salary is greater than
and
my salary is less than
55 000
then
the result would be
within single quotes i'll write low
salary
so this is exactly like an if else
condition
next
i'll write another
case when
salary
is greater than 55 000
and
salary
is less than
let's say 80 000
then the result would be medium salary
and finally i'll give my
last condition that is when
salary is greater than 80 000
then
the result will be
high salary let me write this in a
single line
then
high salary
now one thing to remember in postgresql
the codes are insensitive so you can
write your select statement in capital
in lowercase or in sentence case
similarly i can
write case as
small c
or you can write as capital c
all right
now moving ahead
after this
i'm going to write end
i'll give an alias name as
salary range now this is going to be
my new column in the output
let me just come down
after this we need to give our table
name from employees
i'll order it by
salary
descending
okay so what i'm going to do here is
i'll first select department country and
salary column from my employees table
and then i'm creating a
new column that is salary range and i'm
specifying the range
so i have three conditions here
first low salary for medium salary and
high salary
so let's run this
and see the output
there you go
here
you can see we have added a new column
known as salary range
and we have
order our salary in descending order so
all the highest salaries appear at the
top if i just scroll down you can see we
have
medium salaries here and if i scroll
down further you can see these low
salaries
so case statements are really useful
when you want to create a new column
based
on some conditions in the existing table
all right
now moving ahead
we are now going to see how to write sub
queries in postgresql
so sub queries
we write a query inside another query
which is also known as
so suppose it's like uh
department country and salary of those
employees
the best players in the world so coma i
mean this is also going to display this
by the name but it's it's
motivation is to be better than this
salary than them year after year
all this happened
because the reason the reason is
i'm unbelievable inside the pitch this
is why the people have employees so much
interesting on me are you the best
footballer take it down for you i think
so yes so in my mind i'm always the best
we are going to select
ourselves
from the employees what they say is in
my mind
the department country and their
original salary so if you want you can
run the statement as well let me strike
this statement almost every day this is
why and run it for the top level many
many years you can see we have written
the average style by all the
nearly employees one thousand four
hundred and sixty six dollars so we want
the salaries of these employees to be
greater than this average value we are
very very good at having done this
and see how many employees have a salary
greater than the average salary
to use some inbuilt functions we learn
some inbuilt mathematical functions and
straight functions that are available in
custody that kind of work so i'll just
give a half comment because there's
another way to write a comment instead
of a double dash you can use
the forward slash i'm always competitive
uh playing an asterisk and then inside
the asterisk you can write let's see
with my sql your mom would do my name
always
try to competitive hards and try to win
and you need to close this so i'll give
another asterisk
i'm going to change a forward because i
like i like this so this is also a
commenting
person all right so
first of all we'll explore a few math
functions
so there is a function called eps which
is used to find the absolute of a
backing
so if i write select is part of my abs
of
let's say
my signature
speak with the ball it is going to
return me though it's the right positive
100 or just 100 because
as you know the absolute of any value
will remove the negative sign involving
the thousands
there you go this is what that original
input was minus
the absolute minus 100
so suppose i write select
greatest most important thing i knew it
and inside the greatest function
a few numbers let's say
we have everything i'm just randomly
passing a few numbers i have
millions billion food but the most
important thing it's the family keep
your family
healthy good and take care of your
family because
the most important
part of that of
again you can use an alias for each of
these statements i'm always saying it
was
like greatest
i have in my life
as a result
in a different
so the result is two people in the same
country but it looks like the least
number that is present different part of
in this city i was crying almost every
day
to miss my family but i'm not sure
54 divided by 10 the remainder is 4.
all right
scroll down
now let's see how to use the power
function
so
i'll write select
power hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learning youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos which is certified click here let
me just
run this
there you go so the result is 8
you can also check let's say power of 5
comma 3 it should be 125 all right
next
you can use the sqrt function that is
available in postgresql to find the
square root of a number
i'll write sqrt
and let's say i want to find the square
root of 100
you can
guess the result the output should be
10.
if i run this
you can see the output here 10
let's say i want to find the square root
of
let's say 144
you can again guess the result it should
be 12 let's verify it
okay there is some error let me verify
it again
there you go
it is 12.
now
there are a few trigonometric functions
as well you can use the sine function
the cos function and the tan function
let's say i want to know the sine of
0 if you have studied high school
mathematics you would know the sign of 0
is 0 you can see the result it is 0
let's say you want to know sine
if i run it
you can see the output here 0.89
all right
now there are other functions like
ceiling and floor that you can use
so let me show you
what the ceiling and floor function does
i'll write
ceiling
let's say
i'll pass my floating value as 6.45
and let me run it
you can see the ceiling function returns
the next highest integer that is seven
in this case since the next highest
integer after six point four five is
seven
let's see what the floor function does
and let me run it
as you can see the floor function
returns the next
lowest integer that is 6 in this case
or the nearest lowest integer to any
provided decimal value
okay
now that we saw how to use mathematical
functions there are a few string
functions available in postgres sql so
let's explore them as well i'll write
string functions
okay
scroll down cool there's a function
called character length that gives you
the length of a text string
suppose i write select
give the
function as character length
and inside this function i am going to
pass in a text lets say
india
is a democracy
this is my text
let me run this
okay you can see the result here which
is 20 cents there are 20 characters in
my string that i have provided
all right
now there's another function called
concat in postgres sql so concat is
basically used to merge or combine
multiple strings
so i'll write select
concat
within brackets
i'll give the
text string now let's say i want to
[Music]
combine
postgres
sql
[Music]
i'll give a space
comma i want
to merge postgres sql
is
i'll give
another comma and write my final
word that is
interesting
now what we have done is inside the
concat function we have passed in
separate strings
and now using the concat function we
want to merge
the three strings let's see what the
result is
i'll run it
all right let me just expand this you
can see here we have concatenated the
three string successfully so the output
is postgres sql is interesting
okay
now there are functions like left right
and mid in postgres sql
so what the left function does is it
will extract the number of characters
that you specify from the left of a
string
let's see i'll write select
left
and i'll pass in my
text string as
india is
a democracy i'll copy this
and i'll paste it here
let's say i want to extract the
first five characters from my string
so i'll give five so what it will do is
it will count
five characters from left so one two
three four and five
if i run this
it should ideally print india for me
there you go it has printed india for us
all right
similarly you can use the right function
to
extract
few characters from the right of a
string let's say you want to extract
let's say i'll give 12 characters from
right so from here onwards it will count
12 characters
i'll change left to right now
let me select this and run it
so you can see here this is the output
from the right it has counted 12
characters and returned a democracy
okay
now there is
a function called repeat
so the repeat function is going to
repeat a particular string
the number of times you specify
let's see
i want to select
and use my repeat function
and inside the repeat function
i'm going to pass in let's say india
and i want india to be displayed five
times
i'll give a semicolon and run it
in the output you can see
india has been printed five times
okay
let's scroll down
there is another function a string
function in postgresql called as reverse
so what reverse function is going to do
is it is going to print any string
passed as an input in reverse order
so if i write select
reverse
and inside the reverse function i'll
pass in my
string
that is
india is a democracy i'm going to use
the same string
i'll copy this and i'll paste it here
i close the codes and the brackets let's
print this
you can see it here india is a democracy
has been printed in reverse order
there you go
all right
now this time we explored a few
inbuilt functions that are already
present in postgres sql
now postgresql also has the feature
where you can write your own user
defined functions
so now we will learn how to write a
function of our own in postgresql
let's create a function to count the
total number of
email ids that are present in our
employees table
so for this
we'll write a function a user defined
function so let me give my comment as
user defined function
okay
so let me start by first
writing create so this is the syntax to
write a
function in postgresql so i'll write
create or
replace
function
then i'll give my function name as count
emails
and as you know
functions have brackets
then i'll write
returns the return type
as integer
then
an alias
with dollar symbol i'll write
total emails since i'm going to display
the total number of email ids that are
present in my table
i'll close the dollar symbol
then i'm going to declare a variable
the variable name is going to be
total
underscore
emails
this is of type integer
i'll write
begin
and
inside begin
i'll write my select statement so i'll
write
select
i want to count the email ids that are
present so i'll pass my column name that
is email
into
total emails
from
my table name that is employees
i'll give a semicolon
and then we'll write
return
total emails
as you know
user-defined functions often return a
value so hence we have mentioned the
return statement as well
and now i am going to end my function
then
the next syntax would be
let me just scroll down okay
so here i'll give my
dollar symbol again
followed by
total underscore
emails
next
i'll write my language
as
postgres sql so the way to mention is pl
p
g
sql let's give a semicolon and end it so
this is my
user defined function that i have
written so i created a function with the
function name count underscore emails
and this would return integer as
an alias which is total underscore
emails we declared
that variable as an integer then we
started with a begin statement that has
my select statement where i am selecting
the count of email ids that are present
in the employees table
and i am putting the value into total
underscore email so i've used the into
keyword
and this returns the result as total
underscore emails and i've ended
let's run
this okay there is some problem there is
an
typo so this should be integer
okay
let me run it once again
there you go so you've successfully
created a user defined function
now
the final step is to
call that function now to call this
function i am going to use my select
statement
and the function name that is count
underscore emails
i'll give a semicolon
let's execute this there you go so here
you can see there are 134 email ids
present
in our employees table now one thing to
mark is there are total 150 employees in
the table but out of them 134 employees
have email ids the rest of them
so they would ideally have null values
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on postgres sql tutorial
let me go to the top we have
explored a lot so we started with
checking the version of postgresql
then we saw how to perform basic
mathematical operation that is to add
subtract multiply
then we saw how to create a table that
was movies we inserted a few records to
our movies table
then
we used our select clause we updated a
few values then we deleted
one row of information
then we learnt how to use the where
clause
we learned how to use the between
operator
we also learned how to use the in
let me scroll down
we created a table called employees
and then we learnt how the distinct
keyword works
we also learnt how to use is null with
where clause
we learnt about the order by clause
we saw how to alter or rename a column
then we explored a few more examples on
where clause we learnt about and and our
operator
then we learnt how to use
limit and offset
as well as the fetch operator or the
fetch keyword in postgresql
moving further we learnt about
the like operator in sql which was used
to perform pattern
recognition or pattern matching you can
say
here we saw how to use basic
inbuilt postgresql functions like sum
average minimum count maximum
next we saw how to update
a value in a column using
update command
we learned how to use group by
then we learned how to use having clause
then we learnt how to use case
expressions in postgre sql so we saw how
case expression is similar to our
effects in any other programming
language
we explored a few mathematical and
string functions
and finally we wrote our own user
defined function
so that brings us to the end of this
tutorial on postgresql now if you want
to
get this sql file that we have used in
the demo you can
give your email ids in the comments
section and our team will share this sql
file with you over email sql is a very
important technology that is used in the
id industry
professionals working as application
developers web developers data analysts
data scientists software testers and
cyber security experts need to know sql
in this video we will cover 30 important
sql questions that are most frequently
asked in the interviews
now these questions consist of a set of
theoretical and practical questions
so we will use different commands
functions joints and other
functionalities in excel to solve the
problems
so let's get started with the first
question
so the first question is to state the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
now wear and having are very widely used
in sql to solve specific problems
now let's look at the difference one by
one
so where clause is used to filter the
records from the table based on the
specified condition and can be used
without the group by clause on the other
hand having clause is used to filter the
records from groups based on specified
conditions
now where clauses cannot have aggregate
functions so you cannot use some count
average min and maximum functions in the
where clause
while in the having clause you can
operate on aggregate functions
and those aggregate functions are used
to filter values from a group
now where clause is implemented on rows
or at row level
so for each row of data you have the
where condition applied
having clauses are implemented on
columns so for each column of data you
have the having condition applied
now another important difference between
wear and having is that the where clause
is executed before the execution of the
group by clause and after the execution
of the from clause
on the other hand the having clause is
executed after groups are created
now we will learn more about wear and
having and understand the usage better
when we tackle practical problems in
this video
now moving to our next question
which is
how is drop different from truncate
so drop and truncate are two different
commands
so drop command is used to drop the
whole table removing the table
definition and its contents while
truncate deletes all the rows from the
table
we can drop the whole table structure in
one go so the view of the table does not
exist
by using the truncate command the
existence of all the rows in the table
is lost but the view in the table exists
now integrity constraints
will be removed in drop command while
the integrity constraints will not be
removed when you use the truncate
command
now moving to our third question now
this is a practical question so we will
be using a
table which is present in my mysql
database so the table name is called
employees and i want to find
the lowest salary of the employees in
each department
you can see here this is how my
employees table
looks
and
the output query would be something like
this
so here since i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees so i'm using a
min function to find the lowest salary
in the table
and then
i'm grouping
all the employees and the results by
department so let's do this on mysql
workbench
okay so here i am on my mysql workbench
first let me go ahead and create a new
sql script so i'll click on this
and that will create a new script
okay so here we'll write our commands
all right
so
our question was to
find the
lowest salary
for each department
okay so i have given my comment to make
my
commands
and whatever i am doing more readable
so
first before i proceed
i need to
select my database so i'm going to use
my sql underscore intro database
so i'll write use sql underscore intro
now this database has a lot of tables
that we'll be using in this
interview questions
video i'll run it
okay
we are in our sql intro database
now there is a table called
employees let me show you the table
first
if i write select star from employees
okay so here you can see this is the
table i'm talking about
now these are the
rows
that are present in the table we have 20
rows and here you can see the different
columns we have the employee id employee
name each gender
we have the department city and salary
now this is the same table that we have
also used
in our other videos that are already
live on youtube
okay
so
let's solve our question to find the
lowest salary for each department
now
for that
i'll write select
i'll select my department column which
is dept
comma
and then
to calculate the lowest salary or to
find the lowest salary i'm going to use
the min function so that will return the
minimum salary
present in the salary column
so i'll write min salary as i'm giving
an alias name as let's say
lowest
underscore salary
from
my table name that is employees
then i'll write
group by
department
i'm grouping it by department because we
want to find the lowest salary of the
employees in each department
now let's run and see the result
there you go
i'll just
move it to the top so that you can see
the results clearly
okay so here we have total seven
departments you can see at the bottom
and
in these seven departments you can see
in sales seventy thousand let's say
dollars was the lowest salary in
marketing we had fifty five thousand
dollars as the lowest salary similarly
if i scroll down we have other
departments like
tech i.t finance and hr so
these are the lowest salary
in each department
all right
now moving to our next question
so our fourth question is
which query will help you fetch unique
values from a column in a table
so this is a multiple choice question
which is another type of question that
is often asked in the sql interviews
now we have multiple queries here and
you need to choose the right query that
will solve our problem
so
since i want to
get the unique values from a column
in a table
so the right option
would be to use the distinct keyword in
the query so if i write select
distinct followed by the column name
let's say you want to find the distinct
cities or the distinct departments in
the employees table
so the query would be select distinct
city or let's say department from the
table name that is employees
hence this is the right option if you
want to find any unique values from a
column
now moving to the
fifth question
now the fifth question says
it is actually a similar question here
we want to write the sql query to fetch
unique departments from the employees
table
so as we saw this is our employees table
and if you want to find the unique
departments from the employees table you
can just write select
distinct
then followed by the column name
which is departments here so dept from
employees
let's
do this
on our mysql workbench
okay so let me just scroll down
and
i'll give a comment here
that is we want to find the unique
departments
so the query would be
select
then i'll use the distinct keyword if i
hit tab it will auto complete
then
i have my column that is department
from
my table name that is employees
if i run this
the query will give us
the unique departments that are present
in the table so here we have total
seven unique departments in the table
you can see here we have sales marketing
product
tech i.t
finance and hr but
if you see our original table which is
the employees table
so there are total
20 records
and if you see the department column
there
are multiple departments to which each
of these employees belong to
okay
now moving ahead
now the sixth question is to write an
sql query to fetch the unique values of
departments and print their length
now
this question consists of two parts
first we need to fetch the unique values
of departments that we saw in our fifth
question
and then we want to print the length of
each of the departments so for that i'm
using the distant keyboard to find the
unique departments and then
i'm using the
inbuilt length function that is present
in mysql to find the length of the
department and then i am
using an alias that is length underscore
department from employees so let's say
this on
our workbench
okay
so let me
give a comment
i'll say
unique
departments and length
okay so the query would be
i'll write
select
distinct
department
and then
let me just scroll down i'll give a
comma
and use my inbuilt length function see
i'm hitting tab to autocomplete
and inside the length function i'll give
my column name that is department
i'll give an alias as
department underscore
length
from my table that is
employees this is pretty simple
so first i am finding the unique
departments and then using the length
function i am finding the
length of each department
let's run and see
okay you can see the result here so
seals the length is 5
marketing the length of marketing is
nine so basically you are counting the
number of characters that are present in
each of the departments so in sales
there are total five characters in
marketing there are total nine
characters in product there are total
seven characters in it we have just two
letters i and t so hence the
length is 2 similarly finance is
7 and hr is 2 because we have just two
letters h and r
ok so this is another variation of using
distinct along with
any inbuilt function
all right
now moving to the seventh question
the question is what is the use of
datif function in sql now datif
returns the number of days between two
date or date time or time stamp values
so d diff is another
crucial
inbuilt function
that is present in mysql
so here is how you can use the datedif
function so it will return the
number of days between two dates or
datetime or timestamp values so here i
have
two date values that is
10th of
april 2021 and
i have
30th of
march 2021
so this query will give us the
total number of days that lie between
these two dates and similarly
here is another example of using the
datedif function
so i want to calculate the total number
of days that are present between today's
date so i am using the now function and
between
20th of april 2021
so let's do this demo on the workbench
all right
first i'll give a comment
saying
d d function
okay
now the way to use this
i'll write select
and then
you can see here once i type date
mysql workbench is automatically
suggesting some of the
inbuilt functions i am going to use
datedif
and within datedif i am going to pass in
two values so i am passing in two date
values let's say 2021
april
so i'll write 0 4 and let's say
10th of april
i'll give another comma
and i'll pass in my second date value
that is going to be
30th of
march
all right
now another thing to note here is
the
date value should be present inside
quotations
if you want you can given alias as well
i'll write as
total days
let's run it
there you go it has given us the output
as 10 so there are total 10 days between
31st of march
to
10th of april now let's see another
example
i'll write select
date diff
and we'll pass in
my now function so the now function
returns the current date that is today's
date
and i'll give another date value let's
say
april 20th
now we'll see the results
if you want you can give an alias name
so that the output is more readable here
i'll run it
okay
so between
today's date and
my previous date that was 20th of
april
there are total 49 days
so today's date is actually
8th of june so between
20th of april and 8th of june there are
total 49 days
all right
now moving ahead
now in the eighth question
we want to write
an sql query to display the departments
that have
more than two employees
so
this is our employees table that we have
been using
and here is how the
command looks like so here
we are using both group by and having
now i am grouping by department because
i want to
display the departments that have more
than two employees now for the second
filter i am using the
count function of the employee ids
and checking if the employees
in each department are more than two or
not
let's do this
let me
move down a bit
and i'll give a comment
departments with
more than
two employees
okay
now let's write our
query so i want to select
the department
and then
i'm using the count function to count
the
employee ids in each department or the
employees
present in each department
from my table that is employees
i'm going to group by
department
and then i'll use having
my count of
employee id
this should be greater than 2
so
our query will return only those
departments which have more than 2
employees
let's run and see
there you go
so we have total four departments that
is sales product tech and i.t
where we have more than
two employees you can see here sales has
four employees product has three
tech has four
and it has 3 the rest of the departments
like finance hr and others have less
than 2 employees
now if you want you can give an alias as
well
let's say as
total employees
okay
let me run it again
and here you can see i have the
column name as total employees
okay
so moving ahead
the ninth question we want to display
the details of the employees for all the
departments except marketing
now
here i have my employees table
now if i were to display all the details
of the employees apart from
marketing department
i can give a condition like where
department
not equal to marketing so this is the
way how you write not equal to so you
use the less than and greater than
symbol
another way to do is use the exclamation
mark and give equal to so this means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
now let's do this
i'll move down a bit
and we'll give a
comment as
details of employees apart from
marketing
so the query would be select
star from employees
i am using star because i want to
display all the details that means i
want to display all the columns
then i am going to use my where
condition where
department
not equal to
marketing
i'll put marketing under
quotes
let's run it and see the results
there you go
so
we have
total
18 rows of information
and if you see the department column we
have
all the departments apart from marketing
now if you remember
our employees table had total 20 rows of
information out of which two are missing
which means there were two employees who
were from marketing department and those
departments were
not displaying
now
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees but department
is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving apart
the employees from the marketing
department
all right
now moving ahead
so our tenth question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using
just a where condition to filter our
results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after 31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010.
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write
employees
joined
before
april
[Music]
and
after
may 2005
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
this is one of the formats to use
date values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d value
and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write
march
31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005 and date of join less
than
31st of march
2010 this means
employees joined before 2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
apartment column we have
all the departments apart from marketing
now if you remember our employees table
had total 20 rows of information out of
which two are missing which means
there were two employees who were from
marketing department and those
departments were
not displaying
now
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving a part the employees from the
marketing department
all right
now moving ahead
so our 10th question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using
just a where condition to filter our
results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after 31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write
employees
joined before
april
[Music]
and
after
may 2005
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
this is one of the formats to use
date values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d value
and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write
march
31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005
and date of joined less than
31st of march
2010 this means
employees joined before
2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can
see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
okay
now moving ahead to the 11th question
so here we want to find the employee
with the
third highest salary from the table
so i have my employees table here
and my command would look something like
this
so here we are going to explore how to
write
sub queries in sql so
i am using a sub query here where i am
trying to find
the
employees who have the
top three salaries or the top three
employees who have the highest salaries
and from that i am going to filter out
my third highest salary employee so
let's do it on our workbench
okay so i'll come down and let me give a
comment as
third highest salary
okay
so
let me first write down my sql query and
then i'll explain so i'll write select
star from
after that i'll start a bracket and
write my inner query so i'll write
select
star from
employees
order by
salary
descending
then i'll use my limit keyword
and i'll write limit 3
as i'll give an alias name let's say t
and then
i'm
again going to use
my order by
salary
limit
1.
okay now let me explain you the flow so
first let me run the inner query i'll
select my inner query
and i'll run it
so the inner query returns
my top three employees who have the
highest salary and this is ordered in
descending order since i used salary
descending
now let me just
use this okay now you can see it clearly
so these are my top three employees who
have the highest salary so joseph has
the
maximum salary followed by
angela and then we have jack
now from this i want to return only
the record for jack because jack is the
employee
who earns the third highest salary so
for that
i am going to
use the result written by my
sub query or the inner query and on top
of this
i am going to order the salary and say
limit equal to 1 so i am again
ordering this salary in ascending order
so what will happen
jack will appear at the top angela will
be at the second place and joseph will
come to the third place and from there i
am using limit1 so that i can only get
the record for jack
now if i run the entire query
you see the result i have my
employee name as jack who earns the
third highest salary
okay
now moving ahead to the 12th question
the question is to print all the
alternate records in a table so here is
my employees table and from this table i
am going to print all the alternate
records for example i am going to print
my employee id 101 then i am going to
skip 102 and print 103 followed by one
zero five one zero
seven one zero nine so all the
employee ids that have an odd value
and you can look at this example in
another way of displaying the employees
which have an employee id
of even numbers so 102 104 106 and so on
now the way to do is
either you can use a simple select
clause and say employee id
percentage or modulus 2 equal to 0 which
means i want to filter only those
employees which have an even employee id
else
what you can do is you can use a cte as
you can see here
so cte or the common table expression is
a temporary named result set that you
can reference within a select insert
update or delete statement now it is
used to simplify complex joints and sub
queries and to provide a means to query
hierarchical data
now let's
write this query on our workbench and
see how it works
before that let me explain you i am
using a few
new functions such as row number this
will
create a row number for each of the rows
or the records present in my table
and then
from this cte i am going to use my
filter class or the where clause
where rn which is row number percentage
2 equal to equal to 1 so this will
return
only the odd records from the table
let's see how to do it
okay
so
i'll give a comment
print
alternate
records
okay
now i'll start with my
simple query which is select star from
employees
where
let's say i want to find only the even
employee ids
or the employees who have an even
employee id
so i can use employee id
percentage 2 equal to 0 so it has to be
a perfect division
and the result should be 0 only then i
can get only the even employees if i run
this
okay there was an error here should be
employees
i'll run it again
you can see here i have printed the
alternate records in a table so we have
skipped 101 because it is not divisible
by two
i've started with one zero two followed
by one zero four one zero six one zero
eight
and then finally we have
one two zero or hundred and twenty
now if you want
to print only the
odd records in the table you can use
employee id percentage to equal to one
so you can see here i have one zero one
one zero three one through five one zero
seven up to
one one nine
now the
best way to do this is
to use a common table expression or cte
so i'll start with
my command that is with cte
as
i'll
start with my bracket i'll write select
star
comma
then i'm going to use my row number
function
so i'll write
row number
then
i'll write over
then i'll use order by
employee id
so this row number for each of the rows
is going to be created over my employee
id column
and that is sorted in
ascending order i will give an alias as
rn which stands for row number
from
my table that is
employees
i'll scroll down
and then i'm going to
close my bracket
i'll write select
let me remove the space here
okay and let's select star from
cte
where
my
row number
percentage 2 equal to
1.
now
let's
see this from the top
so i have my common table expression
where
i am
going to create a
row number column named as rn
and this row number column is based on
my employee id column which is sorted in
ascending order and from that
i am going to filter only those row
number values that are not divisible by
2 or i am going to print only the
odd records from the table so let us run
it and see the results there you go so
here if you mark i have my row number
column created
and i am filtering only the odd records
in the table so it starts with 1 3 5 7
and goes up to 19
and similarly here you can see the
employee ids the name the age gender and
other information
now if you were to print
the even records in the table
the alternate even records you can use
rn percentage 2 equal to 0 let's see the
difference
and run this
there you go
so i have my even row numbers starting
from 2 which goes up to
okay so this is how you can print
alternate records in a table
now moving to the next question
now in the 13th question we want to
write an sql query to fetch
all the duplicate rows in a table now
this is another crucial interview
question that is often asked in most of
the interviews
now i have a table which is named as
duplicate table and here you can see i
have some employee id name and each and
a few records are duplicated for example
101 sam
40 the first record is duplicated and
you can see here
it has the same
values
now if you mark
mary and 28 is not duplicated because
here the age is different so this is a
different person
than
compared to the third
name that we have
so this is how you can find
the duplicate rules in a table so i am
going to select my employee id name and
age and then count
all the
employee ids the names and each and
compare them with whether they are
greater than one or not so if they are
greater than one
then
i'll say that particular record is
duplicated or is present more than one
time in the table
let's
do this
implementation on our
workbench
okay
so i'll come down
and let me give my comment as
duplicate records
okay
so
let me first
show you the records that are present in
my table so i'll right select
star from
dup underscore
employees
run it
okay you can see here i have my table
that we saw in the slides
so
employee id 101 with name sam and age
40 is duplicated
so we want to find this duplicate record
the way to do is
i'll write
select
e underscore id which is employee id
comma name comma age
comma i'm going to count all of them
so i'll write count star
as
duplicate
count this is my alias name
from
my table that is dup underscore
employees
i'll say
group by
employee id
name
and age
and then i'm going to use my having
clause saying having
count of
employee id
is greater than 1
and
count of
name
should also be greater than 1
and
my count of age
should also be
greater than 1
let's run it and see the results
okay there is some error here
the name of the table should be
employees
okay
let's run again
we have
our correct result
that is employ id101 with name sam
and each 40 is duplicated so the value
is 2.
great
now
moving ahead
now the 14th question is a bit tricky
wherein we want to display the employees
with exactly two
a's in their name
so you see here i have my
employee names and
there are certain employees who have
just
two e's in their names so i want to find
those employees
only
now the way to do is
it is a bit tricky to understand i am
going to break it down and make you
understand
on my mysql workbench
so here you can just have a glance i
write select star from employees where
i am finding the length of my employee
name and then subtracting
my length
wherein i have
replaced my employee name
that has a with a
blank
and if this subtraction is equal to 2
then
that particular employee has two e's in
their names
so let me show this first
let me
first give my comment as
employees with
two
e's okay
so
first
i'm going to write a select statement
okay before that i'll show you
the records present in my table
okay
if you see here
shane is one of the employees that has
just one e
in its name then we have mary 1 a
duin has one a but if you see sarah
sarah has 2a
in the name so we want to extract sarah
then
jack has one a again if you see angela
angela has 2a it doesn't matter if it is
uppercase a or lowercase a we just need
to find
if the employees have two e's in their
name
and similarly if i scroll down let me
check if we have
any other employee with two a's in the
name marcus has one david has one sophia
has one
we also have amelia that has two a's
in its name or in her name
and we also have maya
okay
now
let me go ahead and write a sql query
and then i'll explain you what i'm
trying to do
i'll write select
i'm using the length function
and
in the length function
i'm going to replace
then i'll use another function called
upper
on top of employee name
i'll write
a and then replace it with a blank so
i'm using quotations to represent blank
from
employees
okay
let's run this and see the results
you see here
it has given us
the length
of the employee strings after
replacing all the e's with a blank
so here
i'm essentially
converting my employee names to upper
case
and i'm changing wherever there is an a
i'm replacing
that a with a blank
and then i'm finding the length
so this trick i'm going to use
in my
final query so i'll write select star
from
employees
where
what i'm going to do is
i'll bring this to the next line i'll
write
length of
employee name
minus then i'm going to use my above
condition
i'll
copy this
i'll paste it here
and this value should be
2.
so what i am doing is i am first
finding out the length of my employee
name
from that
i am subtracting
the length after replacing
the e is present in the employee name
with a blank and this value should be
equal to 2. the reason being we are only
trying to find the employees who have
two a's in their name
let's run and see the results
okay if you see here we have sarah
angela
emilia and maya who have
two a's in their name so we have
sara
that has 2a angela has 2a amelia has two
a's
and then maya also has 2a
okay
now moving ahead
now the 15th question is given a string
how will you extract four characters
starting from the
second position
so i have my string here
which says michael ballack now michael
ballack you must be aware he's a popular
footballer he's from germany and also
was the captain of germany
so from the string michael ballack i am
going to extract four characters
starting from the second position
you can use two inbuilt mysql functions
to
do this the first is called
sub str wherein we pass in the string
then we
give the position from where we want to
extract the characters so here i am
going to extract from the second
position so hence 2
and then the number of characters that
you want to extract which is 4.
the other way is to use the substring
function
which is again similar to the sub str
in the substring function also i am
first passing in my input string and
then giving my starting position which
is 2 and then i want to extract 4
characters from it
let's do it
i'll give a comment
extract
strings
so here i am going to write select
first i am going to use sub str
which is my inbuilt function
i am going to pass in my input string
which says
michael ballack
and then
i'll give my starting position which is
2 and then the number of characters that
is 4.
let's run it and see the results
you can see here it has given us
i cha
so if you see m is at the first position
from the second position onwards i
needed four characters so m c h and e
these are the four characters starting
from the second position
similarly let me just copy this
and instead of
sub str i'm going to use the sub string
function i'll write just
ing that becomes substring
let's
select and run it and this also returns
the same result suppose you wanted to
extract
from the fourth position
you wanted to extract let's say three
characters
let's see the results
it gives us h a and e if you see here
m is the first physician i is at the
second position c is at the third
position h starts from the fourth
position
so h a and e are the next three
characters starting from the fourth
position
so hence this is the result
all right now moving ahead
now my sixteenth question is on
how does self join
work
so self join joins a table to itself
so the table must contain a column x
that acts as the primary key
and a different column let's say y that
stores values that can be matched up
with the values in column x now
this might
not be really easy to understand you'll
get to know once we do this demo so i
have a table
which is called employee manager so this
is my table
now let me tell you how to interpret
this table we have five different
employees starting from employee id one
to employee id5
gary gibbs smith latham and
jimmy are the different employees we
have we have their salaries and now you
have
the employees reporting to which
manager
now if you see here
gary's manager
id is three
so if you see a table at 3 we have smith
so gary is reporting to 3
or in other words
smith has a employee under him who is
gary similarly
gibbs is reporting to manager id 1 or
employee id 1 which is gary so
gibbs manager is gary similarly if you
see for smith smith is reporting to the
person with manager id 4 or employee id4
we have latham so litham has one
employee under him who is smith
now litham in our table has no managers
then we have jimmy who's reporting to
the employee id3 who is smith
okay
now i want to
use this table and return the name of
the manager for each employee
to do that i am going to use my self
join so here i am using
a self join to join both the tables
here both the tables mean i'm using
the same table twice so i have written
select e dot employee id e dot employee
name then we have e dot manager id
then i'm using another alias for
managers so m dot employee name as
manager underscore name from
employee underscore manager as e
this join means self join employee
underscore manager sm on
e dot manager id equal to e dot employee
id so this is my common column that is
employee id and manager id let's do it
all right
i'll give a comment here
saying self join
and i'll start with myself join i'll
write
select
let me first display my table i'll write
select star from
and my table name is
emp underscore manager
i'll run it
you can see the table here this is the
same table that we saw
in the slides
now i'll write my
join query i'll write select e dot
employee id
comma
e
dot
employee
name comma
e dot
manager id
comma
then i am using another
as m
for
finding the
manager name so m dot employee name as
manager name
there shouldn't be any space in the
alias name
then i'll write from
emp underscore
manager as e
join
emp underscore
manager as
m
on e dot
manager
underscore
id equal to
m dot
emp underscore id
let me run this and we'll see the
results
there you go
so gary
reports to
the manager id three so from the table
three
is for smith so gary's manager is smith
gibbs manager is gary
smith's manager is lithum and jimmy's
manager is smith
okay so this is how you can use self
join
now moving ahead with our
next question
so the 17th question
is on which of the following is called a
virtual table in sql so again we have a
multiple choice question
so the answer
is view you can see here
so view is a virtual table that has rows
and columns as they are in a real table
in the database now we can create a view
by selecting fields from one or more
tables present in the
database next moving to the 18th
question
so here we want to write an sql query to
fetch the list of employees with the
same salary
again i am going to
use a self join here wherein i'll join
the same employees table
and this is how my
query would look like so i'm
selecting distinct employee id so e dot
employee id e dot employee name e dot
salary from employees
then i'm joining
employees as e on employees e1 where e
dot salary equal to e1 dot salary
because i want to fetch
the list of employees with the same
salary and i'm ensuring that
the employee ids from both the tables
are different
let's do it
i'll give a
comment here and write
employees
with
same salary
and i'll start with my
query i'll write
select
extinct
e dot
employee id
comma
i'll write e dot
employee name
comma dot salary
from
employees
as e
then
employs as e 1
where
e dot salary equal to
e 1 dot
salary
and
e dot
id is not equal to
e1 dot
employee id
i'll give a semicolon and let's print
the results
you see here we have
emilia
bayla sheen and sarah
who have the
same salary so amelia and sheen have the
same salary of fifty five thousand
dollars bill and sarah have the same
salary of seven to two thousand dollars
okay
now moving to the nineteenth question
so the question is to write an sql query
to print one row twice
in results from a table
so i have a table here called employees
and i want to print
one row twice in the results
so to solve such kind of problems
you need to use the union all operator
in sql
so union all combines the result sets of
two or more select statements
it does not remove duplicate rows
between the various select statements
all the rows are returned
so let's say i want to print the
employee name and department for those
employees who are from the hr department
now to do this we can use the union all
operator you can see it here so i am
selecting my employee name the
department from my table employs se
then i am giving my where clause where e
dot department equal to hr
and then i am using the union all
operator
then i am again selecting my employee
name department from employees with
another alias as e1 where e1.department
equal to
hr so let's do this
okay
so i'll give my comment as
print
row
twice
okay
now
i'll start with my query i'll write
select
my employee name
comma the department
from
my table that is employs as e
then i'll use where
e dot department equal to
hr
then i am going to use the union all
operator
so the union all will combine the result
set of two or more select statements
then i am going to write select
emp underscore name
comma
my department
from
employees
as
e1
where
e one dot department
equal to
hr
i'll give a semicolon now let's run it
there you go you can see here
marcus and sophia are from the hr
department and we have printed them
twice in our results
coming to the next question
the question is
using the num table
write a query to add 10 when number is 0
20 the number is 1
else
print the number itself
so you can see here i have my table
called num and it has just one column
which is
num id or number id
we have some
numbers here
and
from these numbers i want to add 10 if
the number is 0 20 if the number is 1
else i would print the number itself
so
to answer this question we'll use the
case statement in sql
so the case statement is sql's way of
handling if then logic
the case statement is followed by at
least one pair of when and then
statements
so here you can see i have my case
statement i'm writing one case
my column name and underscore id equal
to 0 then add
plus 10
if it is 1 then add plus 20
else
we'll just return the number id
now let's do this
okay i'll give a
comment saying using
case statements
okay first of all
let me
display the values present
in my
num table you can see here this is my
table and there are total
12 rows
of numbers
now let's start with our
i'll write
select
n underscore id
comma
then i'm going to write my case
statement so i'll use the keyword as
case when
n underscore id equal to 0
i'll use then
n underscore id
plus 10
i'll write when
n underscore id equal to 1
then
n underscore id
plus 20
else
i'll just print an id
now i'll end my case statement i'll
write end as
an alias name let's say num underscore
add
from my table that is
num
let's run and see the results
okay you can see here
my first
number was 0 so since it was 0 we have
added
num id or n id plus 10 so the result is
now
wherever
the num id is 1 for example here we have
added 20 so the
result or the output becomes 21.
similarly here the value was 0. so we
have added 10 the output is 10
and you see here again here we had
another one so we added 1 to 20 so the
result becomes 21
and for the rest of the numbers for
example 3
we had 2
the values are the same
okay
now moving ahead
so we have
a table called num1
and using this table we want to write a
query to find the sum of all positive
values and the negative values
so let's see the table first so this is
my table which is num1 you can see here
we have a list of integers
and
there are positive as well as negative
integers
so for positive values
and the negative values we want to find
the sum separately
so again for this we are using
the case statement you can see here i
have used
two key statements
i'm writing select
and then i'm using the case to find if
the number is greater than 0 which means
it's a positive number so i'm
finding out the sum and then i am
checking
case when
the integer is less than 0 so it's a
negative number and i'm finding the sum
for the negative numbers as well
let's do this
okay
so
i'll give my comment
as
add
positive and
negative numbers
okay so let's start with our select
query
i'll write select
i'll use the sum function and inside the
sum function
i'll use my case statement so i'll write
case when
num
underscore
integer
okay before that let me just print the
values present in my
table so i'll write select star from
my table name that is num1
okay
so you can see here these are the values
or the list of integers that we have
there are some positive as well as
negative integers
okay let's continue with our query
so here i am going to write case when
num underscore
integer or int which is my column name
if it is greater than 0
then
i'll return num underscore
int
else i'll say 0
and end my key statement
i'll give an alias as sum of let's say
positive numbers
give a comma
then i'll use another sum function
and inside the sum function we'll use
the case statement to find
the sum of
negative numbers or integers
so i'll write num underscoring if it is
less than zero
then
num underscore end
else
zero
and i'll end
okay
and i'll give another alias name as
let's say sum underscore any g which
stands for negative
pos is for positive integers
and then i'll write from my table that
is num1
let's
run it
okay there you go we have our results so
we have two columns
sum of positive integers and sum of
negative integers you can see the
results 19 and minus 14 respectively
okay now moving ahead
now in question number 22 we want to
list the difference between
primary key and foreign key
so as you can see here
primary key is something that can
uniquely identify a record in a table
so if you consider a school database a
primary key would ideally be
the
role number or the registration number
of the student
because that is unique to all the
students in a school
now
foreign key is the field in the table
that is
primary key to another table
so suppose you have another table called
courses to which the
students of enroll 2
now
if you have a roll number or a
registration number column in the
course table that becomes the
foreign key
now the other difference is primary key
don't accept or cannot accept null
values
while foreign key can accept null values
you can have only one primary key in a
table but you can have more than one
foreign key in a table
now coming to the 23rd question what is
the difference between primary key and
union
so you can have only one primary key in
a table as we discussed in the previous
question
but you can have more than one unique
key in a table a primary key column
cannot have null values but
union can accept null values
now
if you assign a column as a primary key
you create a clustered index
and similarly if you assign a column
with union
you create non-cluster index
okay
now coming to the 24th question
what is a check constant in sql
so check constraints are used while
creating tables
check constraint
helps to limit or restrict the values
that can be inserted into a column
for example
we have a
table here let's say dummy1
and
you want to ensure
that every time you insert the
age of
people or persons in the table you want
to make sure that age should be always
greater than zero reason being a person
cannot have or an animal cannot have or
a tree cannot have a negative each
similarly you can set a constant for the
salary column in a table to ensure that
it is always greater than 0 because you
cannot earn a negative salary or it
cannot be less than zero
now we are going to create a dummy table
on my mysql workbench and see how
check constraints can be applied
okay
so let's give our comment as
check constraints
all right
so i'm going to create
a table
called
dummy
let's say underscore
sql
now this table will have
a few columns first we have let's see
eid which stands for employee id
the data type is integer and
i'm going to assign employee id as my
primary key so i'll write
primary key here
okay i'll give a comma
next we'll have a
city column
city column is of type var care or
varying character
i'll give the size as 30
and here
i am going to apply my check constraint
to this
city column
i am going to check
the city
should
take only
values as mumbai
let's see
i'll have my final column that is each
ages of type integer
and here i'm going to check my age
should always be
greater than zero so i'll write check
age
greater than zero
okay
so our dummy sql table has
one primary key constraint and we have
applied two check constraints
on city and h column
let's run this
okay so we have created our table
successfully you can see it here
now
let's insert a few records and we can
see the difference
i'll write insert into
dummy
underscore sql
i'll write
values
i'll have my employee ids 101
i am giving my
city as mumbai
which is what you want
and let's see
i'll give my age as
10.
now this should perfectly bore because
my city is mumbai and my age
is greater than zero
so
i should be able to insert this record
successfully you can see here
i have inserted
this record to the table i'll write
select star from dummy sql so that you
can check
let's run it
oh there is some mistake i should write
from
okay
let's run it
you can see it here we have one record
or one row returned
now let's see we'll insert another
record
and this time i'm going to give my
employee ideas 102 because it has to be
unique
and this time instead of mumbai i am
going to give my city as let's say delhi
so i am not following my check constant
where i am
supposed to give only mumbai i am
purposely giving
delhi here to see the difference if i
run this
let's see will have
ages 40 which is greater than
let's run it
you see here we get an error saying
check constraint dummy underscore sql
underscore
check
is violated
similarly
let's see i'll change this to mumbai
again
and instead of 40 let's say i'll give us
minus 30
so your each can never be in negative
numbers
if i run this i get the same error my
check constraint has been violated
because each
should be greater than
zero
okay so this is how you can use check
constraints in sql
now coming to the 25th question
so given two tables a and b
you want to write a query to fetch
values in table b
that are not present in table a
now to answer this question
you can use the left join
so what left join does is
it returns all the rows from the left
table and only matching rows from the
right table
and i've used my
condition as a dot id which is in the
right table should be
null
let's write this query on the
workbench
okay
so i'll give my comment
using
left join
first of all let me display my
tables i'll write select star from
e
where on this i have the
ids there are total five ids in table a
similarly
i'll copy this and
we'll see the values that are present in
table b
again i have five values there are a few
non-matching values as well so i want to
return those non-matching values that
are not present in table a
so for that
i'll write select
id
from
table b
i'll use left join
a
using my id column
this is another way to give the
condition
or you can use the on operator
then i'll give
where
a dot id
is
null
let's run and see the results
there you go so 150 275
are not present in table a but are
present in table b
okay
now moving ahead
so now we look at the last set of five
questions
so these questions are based on the
popular northwind sample database
provided by microsoft now there are
several tables in this database so we
have an order table customers employee
products region table and others
will use our microsoft sql server to
solve the five questions
so my next question which is based on
microsoft sql server
the question is using the
north wind
database find the customers who don't
have any orders
okay so i am on my microsoft sql server
management studio so this is how the
interface looks like
and here you can see i have a list of
databases now to solve the last five
questions i'm going to use the northwind
database if i expand this
i'll click on the plus sign you can see
there are a lot of tables that are
already present in the
database you can see here we have
customers employees employee territories
order details orders products region
shippers suppliers territories and more
okay
let me just collapse this
all right
so
to write my queries i am going to create
a
new query file
and here you see
i am currently on my master database i
am going to change this to
northwind database so that we can
utilize all the tables that are present
so my 26th question was to find the
customers who don't have any orders
so for that
i'm going to use two tables
customers and orders
so
let me first give a comment
saying
customers
with
no orders
and now
let's go ahead and display the columns
that we have and see the
records present in the tables
customers and orders so first time
checking all the
columns and the rows present in the
customers table i'll
execute using this button or you can hit
f5 as well
okay you can see here there are total
91 customers these are all unique
customers you have total 91 unique
customer ids you see here the company
name of the customer
you have the contact name the contact
title address city to which the
customers belong to
then the region postal code country
phone fax number
okay
now let me just copy this query
and
now we'll check for the orders table
i'll write select star from
orders
and let's execute it or run it
okay so there are
total 830
rows of information so there were total
830 orders
or order ids we have the customer id now
this customer id is actually the
foreign key
for the orders table
but for the customers table customer id
is the primary key and in the orders
table order id is the primary key
we also have the employee id again this
employee id is the foreign key for this
orders table
we have the order date
we have the required date ship date
ship wire which means
by which medium the order was shipped we
have the freight charges ship name and
sip address as well
then you have the
city from which the item was shipped the
region postal code and the country
okay
now
let me use the distinct keyword i'll
write select
dextent
i want to find the distinct
customer ids
from
my customers table
let's run and see how many unique
customer ids we have so there are total
91 customer ids or customers
now let's check for the orders table
let's run it and see the difference now
if you see here there are total
customer ids in the orders table which
means
there are two customers missing from the
orders table
and that implies those two customers
don't have any orders
so to
get the result i will use two different
queries
to derive at the same
output
so i'm going to select
my customer id
from
my table that is
customers
i'm going to use
where
my customer id
and then i'm going to use the not in
operator
i'm going to use a sub query
select
customer id
from
my orders table
close the bracket and i'll give a
semicolon
now what this query essentially does is
it is first going to
find all the customer ids that are
present in my orders table
and
in the outer query we are only going to
return
the customers that are present in both
the tables and
we are going to
exclude those customers which are not
present in the
orders table
so let us run and see the results we
should get two customer ids there you go
so these are the two customer ids which
are
present in the
customers table and are not present in
the orders table meaning that they don't
have any
orders in their name
now there is another way to do it
that is to use the not exist operator
wherein you can write another
sub query to get this same result we
will leave that to you you can try this
out using the not exist operator as well
coming to the 27th question
using the orders table in the northwind
database we want to find all the
month and orders
so such problems you will face while
dealing with sales data so very often
sales executives would try hard to meet
their month end targets we want to
display all the orders made on the last
day of the month
so let's solve this question on our
microsoft sql server
okay so let me first give my comment for
the 27th question
so the question is to
find all the month end orders so i'll
just write month and orders
okay
now to get the month and orders we are
going to use a
built in
eo month function which stands for end
of month
so let's start with the query
i'll write select
we are going to select the
employee
id
comma
i also want the order id
and
we want the order date
from
my table that is
orders
i'll
then give my where clause i'll write
where
my
order date
equal to
and i'll use my
inbuilt function that is end of month
i
have hit tab to autocomplete
and inside this function i'll pass in my
order date column
then i'm going to
use the order by clause i'm going to
order it by
employee id and the order id
i'll just move down and hit tab
okay
let's
run the query there you go we have got
26 rows of information
you see on the left side we have the
employee ids the order ids and then we
have the order date column now if you
mark the values present in the order
date column these are all the
end of
month date values you see this is 28th
of feb
then we have
31st of
july we have 30th of june
so on and so forth
so these are the list of all the orders
that were placed
on the last day of the month
now coming to the 28th question
we want to find the top five countries
with the highest freight charges in the
year 1997.
so freight charge is the amount paid to
a carrier company for the transportation
of goods from origin to another location
the freight charge is calculated based
on the mode of transportation and the
distance between the pickup place or the
pickup location and the destination
so let's try this out on the
microsoft server management studio
okay so let me go ahead and
give my
comment
so since we want to find the top five
countries with the highest freight
charges
i'll just give my comment as
highest
freight charges
okay
now
to solve this question
i'll just change this to
ghd okay
we are going to use
our
orders table
so the way to do is i'll write select
i'm going to use the
top five so top is another
keyword or
an operator
so i'm going to find out the
ship country
and then
i'll calculate the average freight
prices so i'm going to use the average
inbuilt function
on top of my
column that is
freight
i'll give an alias as
let's say
average
fret
there should be no space i'll give a
underscore
i'll write from my table that is
orders
i'll use my where clause where
and then i am going to find the year
from my order
date column and this year should be
1997.
i'm going to
group it by
my ship country
and
i'll use order by
my alias name that was average freight
and in descending order i'm going to
sort it
let's see the top five
shipping countries who have the highest
freight charges
these are the results you have austria
switzerland sweden canada and ireland
and here you can see the average freight
prices
sorted in descending order
okay
now moving ahead to the
29th question
so here we want to display the total
number of products in each category so
we have two different tables products
and categories so both these tables we
are going to use
to find a solution to this problem that
is
to display the total number of products
in each category
so first let me give my comment to
display the total number of products in
each category i'll just write print
total
products
okay
so
to solve this problem we are going to
use our two tables
so let me first display the rows and
columns from both the tables the first
table is products
okay it is products
let's run this and see the columns that
we have in this table
okay so you have the product id which is
the primary key you have the product
name so there are total
77 different products okay
and then you have the supplier id you
have the category id so these two
columns are the foreign key columns you
have the quantity per unit unit price
units in stock
units and order
and if you want to
reorder
some product to fill in the stocks so
you have information for that as well
and if the product has been discontinued
or not
i'll copy this and let's see what
rows and columns we have
in my categories table
okay
let me execute this
so we have total eight categories of
products you can see beverages we have
dairy products
meat or poultry you have produce seafood
these are the description
okay
now to find the total number of products
in each category
i'll write my query as
select
i'll write
category
name
comma
count
star
i'll give this an alias name as total
products
give an underscore and write products
from
my first table that is
products
given alias as p
i am going to use an inner join
with
my categories table
and i'll give my alias as c
on my common key column that is p dot
category id
is equal to c dot
category
id then
i'm going to
group my results
based on the category names
so i'll write category
name
and we'll use the
order by clause i'll write order by
count star
as
descending
so let's see the total number of
products that we have in each category
so this shouldn't be as descending
should be just count star descending
okay
i'll select and run it
there you go
so here on the left hand side you have
the different category names and
on the right you have the
total number of
products that belong to
each of the categories
all
right
now moving on to the final question
so the last question is to use the
northwind database
and using this database we want to find
the list of late orders for all the
employees
so this is a real world problem that
often occurs
so the shipment of your orders might get
delayed due to logistic issues or if the
products are not available on time there
can be various other reasons as well so
here we want to find those orders for
the employees
or where the required date is less than
the shipment date
we are going to use two different tables
that is
orders and employees
okay now let me give my comment for the
final
query that we are going to write in this
interview questions tutorial
so using the orders table i want to find
the list of orders for all the employees
so i'll just give list
of
late orders
not just orders for employees i write
emp
s which stands for employees
so here i am going to use two tables
orders and employees
orders table we have already seen let's
see the rows and columns that are
present in the employees table
i'll write select star from employees
and let me run it
okay so there are total nine employees
we have
so we have the employee id this is the
primary key column which goes from one
to nine we have the last name of the
employee the first name of the employee
we have the title
then we have the
title of courtesy by the doctor
mr mrs
we have the birthday of the employee the
higher date or the date of join
you have the address city region postal
code and other information
all right
so let's
see how you can join the orders table
and the employees table to get the
list of late orders and we must remember
that late orders are those
where the required date is less than
equal to the shipped date
so i'll start with select
e
dot i'll write employee id
comma
i want the
first name
comma i'm going to count
star as
late orders
from
my table orders as o
then i'll use my inner join
i'll write
employees
as
e
it doesn't matter actually if you use
small e or capital e
then i'm going to use my on condition on
e dot
on
employee id
equal to
o dot employee id
so this is my common key column that is
present in both the tables
then i'll use my where clause where
you should be careful
and you should keep the right
clause
so my required date
should be less than or equal to my
shift date
so this is my condition
and then i am going to group by
e dot employee id
comma
e dot
first name
and then i'll use my order by clause
order by
my alias name that was late orders
and i'll arrange it in descending order
so let's run this and see our result
okay
so
you have the employee ids on the left
then you have the first name of the
employee ids and then you have the late
orders for each of these employees so if
you see here employee id 4 has the
highest number of late orders followed
by employee id
3 and 8
as well as 9 who have 5 late orders then
we have the employee id 2 which has
4 late orders even employee 7 has four
lead orders employee id 5 that is steven
has only one late orders
so we are done with our
demo section and we have covered all our
30 questions
out of which 25 questions were based and
used on mysql server
and to address the last five questions
we used our northwind database that had
a lot of tables you can see it here and
using those tables we solve some
interesting questions
in this video we'll understand what
exactly mongodb is and what are its key
features
now i'm sure you must have heard about
databases but mongodb is a popularly
used not only sql database
now without further delay let's begin
and understand what exactly mongodb is
so here's what's in store for you first
we'll understand what mongodb is
then we'll understand why exactly
mongodb is used
then we understand the characteristics
of mongodb
after that we'll understand the working
of mongodb and how it functions we'll
also look at some of the commonly used
applications of mongodb and finally we
look at the top companies that readily
deploy mongodb so what exactly is
mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents it offers
developers the flexibility to work with
evolving data models since it's document
based mongodb allows embedded documents
arrays and represents complex
hierarchical relationships using a
single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like sql why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility mongodb's notion
of documents that can contain
sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or
ranges next up is native aggregation
native aggregation allows its users to
extract and transform data from mongodb
and either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document-oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard balancer
[Music]
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is json now json is widely used
across the web for front-end and api
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs
now the data is stored in the bs1 format
at the back end mongodb converts json
data into a binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data
now all of these documents are stored in
a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco
barclays and google among others readily
deploy mongodb as their database
management system in this video i'm
gonna help you install and set up
mongodb on your windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and
you can see that the current version is
4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your and the mongodb applications
both are executable files now the mongod
file or the application is the daemon
process now this is the background
process that make sure you retrieve the
data from the database access the data
so it does all the background tasks so
after the installation now you need to
create a path to this file by doing this
you don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path
and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on ok
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the file
so
here you can just directly type
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero
so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning what mongodb is all
about and their advantages and some
practical demonstrations so let's get
started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is the mobodb so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay no sql means
it doesn't say like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
heretical relationship using the single
records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema-less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized environment
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql so it is completely into
the non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
you talk about
a typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns
a traditional idb base approach if you
see there they are using a complete
table structure like they talk about
columns they talk about rows and are all
about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents so the different type
of nosql databases are available like
you talk about called document based you
talk about key value base you talk about
white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for this
website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so it will get ready for if you are
from windows
i would say
in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip power portion because it won't
start any mobo db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so
inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay another file which is available
called mobo
mobo d is to basically start the mongod
server
and the mongodb is actually the client
which will connect with the mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment so once you are
inside this bin folder of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mogo so it
will get start as a client
okay since i'm using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start modi we have a
very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongodb
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing i forgot to mention
like mongodb would not start
automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
fold structure in place in your local
machine otherwise this is not going to
start
every time you start your mugi without
this location it automatically
terminates so to avoid those make sure
that you have this data db folder ready
with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db pass
slash data db i hit enter you can see
now my mobile db is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here
i open the another tab
and type
and the moment i type moment now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simplydb
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say you
simply db it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means you are in current
database name for simplydb
so if you are not sure which database
you are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and how to
identify whether my database is there or
not so if you remember previously we
have created our database using use
keyword so if i just see my databases
which we have created yes last time so
how we can check this out we can say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created our database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now
when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the mongodb rule unless we
have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually an idb
message is called here it is called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database
but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db
dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say
the table is created and now when i try
to see same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db dot create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
call
db
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl student dot insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert a
record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections when i say show
collections i can list down those number
of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language
which are there added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list down those
number of records which are added i say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my table also
called a collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db dot create collection many people
always think about what is the
significance of having this db.create
collection
look
db.createcollection is having its own
significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring
some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbi.org
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
i say
capped colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i am going
to pass that is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
and also we are saying 2 8 0 that is the
size of 5 mb and here we are giving call
max
colon
5.
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say db.create collection this option is
not possible when you're trying to use
this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside a
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document and second is called
embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
uh i would say the parent record as well
as the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we will talk about
caller name this name we can say
student1
followed by the next one i'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name
we are given the course name called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have a few more properties like in
course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here and from
address
and address we can say one more curly
braces
and inside this address we can say city
i'm giving the name called what
bangalore
the another one we are using that is
called state
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is called country
here is saying
i that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
find you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also you have option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can overwrite
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can overwrite from this value to
any value because if you do not pass any
value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can overwrite the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so the same record if i try to add
let's
go i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now records are added now
let me call find now you see this time
the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be
given to you so this is the first way of
how the insert document has been done
will be telling you the another ways
where the other documents are also added
okay so
in the previous examples we have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding
the first property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh
you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id1 and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
emp id uh just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one that is
called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing
and once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you an
inserted tree that is known called bulk
insert when you are inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay
now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what
your new erp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a bulk
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update on any of my
records how will i do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call our new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay
so
what i will do i will say db dot new emp
dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple uh
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just say four
i say five
nicest six
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
as an emp name
amp name
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set so that means you want to set the
new value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin call admin it
is not changed and that is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is
notice is like when you try to perform
update
so what mobile dv does it starts from
the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop
it doesn't carry forward its search
process for the next level of results
and that is something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a column name admin
second property we have called manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi colon true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple
changes well in our previous examples
you see like how we can perform the
update part but we have one more
beautiful feature available inside the
mongodb and that is called how exactly
we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi true we have
used
now here
this
multi true
is we're trying to update
but let's talk about something called
manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there is one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-troop
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
abstract rule
when i say absurd rule so what happened
now the same
and matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you'll be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager to
find it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we are saying emp equal to
new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upset at zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now that is very very
beneficial feature when you really want
to perform absurd so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so mongodb
also helps you to perform the delete
part and how you'll be trying to add it
now let's try to understand here in my
code if i want to perform any delete
part i have this statement name called
db
dot the option we are using it that is
called collection name emp
new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
p
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin
new okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
[Music]
available
okay now in a similar way if i try to
remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now when it comes to c in third part we
have seen update part we have seen
delete part we have seen now it's time
to basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that
let's see db
dot
uh
new emp
dot
find
clear now so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with a name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now you can see it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name called
limit
to to means only two records now you can
see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say emp name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
hit
now you can see it is showing a
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
what is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property we have on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order so
that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i'm talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say tb dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide
the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
city
so we say
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here hit enter and
you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than
or whatever values you would like to
make it
is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what two so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
gt
gc stand for what greater than colon
we're giving the value call what one
fine
close this
run you can see you have received three
records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide
the condition so-called limit as i can
say find emp id the way we provide it
so here i will not use
less than
okay instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here you're providing emp
id
and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details
i'm saying
inside so the properties three four six
we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as call working with
indexing see mongodb is one of the most
popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
uh
document which is huge document
in case if you would like to perform any
sort of indexing inside this how you
will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how will be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
[Music]
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot new emp
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me now
let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive so
to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me i'll be using this statement name
called db
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution stats will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon i'm giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was
hit enter and now you can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and return one that means one result is
returned
and the total number of documents
examines three in order to find this
record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i ever got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied on your underscore id
db dot
new emp
um
yeah db dot dmp dot
when i say
db.newemp.getindex is a predefined
function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes mongodb advantages it is
supporting multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is applied on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one
see now earlier the number of document
examined were three but since this index
is applied not just telling me the total
number of document examined is one so
performance is
certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i will be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties
now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here we are saying emp id and in this
emp id we will just offer it has to be
ascending or descending let me decide
descending order
so we are saying
-1
okay
now let's press enter and check the
status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out
db dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot
drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name
i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobile db you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen
how to utilize
indexing into our code
now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mongodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is see ideally
when you talk about call aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
mythical aggregation there so the unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from a collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available which we will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is a they belong
to the different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on a section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out with those students
who belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as the aggregate
functionality section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section a
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records
where the section is a
and we are using and operator
marks is greater than 80. there are so
many students over different marks like
70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say marks
colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than colon
okay
all are closed
so you see like here you ever got this
square bracket in noun brackets
so what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly crysis needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket
again round brackets
okay
let's see where it is gone wrong
so we are using this db dot student dot
aggregate we use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces
and we have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
this square bracket then curly braces
section a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon 80
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly braces square
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that
so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this
uh document i would like to selectively
take specific property
so
uh let's talk about how we can use this
so we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so i just use this statement name called
db
dot
student
okay dot
we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what we would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one comma i'm saying section
colon
one
okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is
zero that means the id will not be
visible here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my
implementation if you see the previous
one what we have used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we're picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those
so the requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from
student collection where the section is
a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can
implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avgn
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out a
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this
underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum okay colon on which we have i want
to use it mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you are basically taking this
marks in my application fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
we'll be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
conan
here we giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you're able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay
so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform an
average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of student in each
section and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks we
want to get it so how are we able to
take it now
it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also
into our code how we are taking call
group underscore id section talking
about section
total marks with the sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
called group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks
after that
we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and
after this we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay
colon
one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with
mobo db mobile db is properly known for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need
to install any software for this because
it is a building feature for the mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part okay so let's get started and talk
about how mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about replication you
are replicating your data to where the
multiple child so here in mobile db
we have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay and
slaves
okay
master is one and there will be multiple
slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored and this is a master
which will be responsible
to replicate the data to all its childs
when the request comes due to that
in case if one particular
node
fails so automatically the data will be
taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobodb atlas database as a
service see this is a free tool
it's a cloud environment where you
really don't need to install mobo db in
your local machine it is a cloud-based
mongodb support which is free to use
with a limited amount of space but yes
for the testing purpose it is the best
suitable
so i can start with the start free or
else i can say the login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
moba tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay
since i already have a cluster with me
so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free
tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and i've been closed on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and
8gb ram cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour
reason being because i already have a
cluster with me hence more than one
cluster is not allowed in a free tier
cluster so i have to cancel this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster it
will take a while minimum
two to three minutes depends on the
availability it creates a cluster for
you and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay
so here in this application
you have to go back and understand what
is there in a crystal when you click on
cluster zero
you can see now here we have a got
three nodes available one is called
primary node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary two will be
secondary
based on your package
whichever you have taken it you can
increase the number of nodes later on
but as a free i'm gonna get or i will be
receiving total number of three nodes
available here
so records whichever will be stored it
will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now first setting is you have
to put it remember the steps first step
will be your network access so in
network access you have to go
and you have to say add ip address
and in this ad ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be white
listed otherwise what you can do you can
see here in my options i have given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you will talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password
as per your own convenience so new user
i'm going to create it that is called
sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
admin
123 so sl user admin 123
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
and we went to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there a lot many databases
are there so you can go back and create
some new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee i can say create
now you can see slw create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and once it is there ready so remember
sldm
and employee i'll go back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third-party application of the mongodb
compass so
since i already have a mobile shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line
but i need to replace with this
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
i'll i'll selected this i open my
terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to connect to the
shell now
so
what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i say
i hit enter
it lasts me the password so i'll give
the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this
particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say
show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say db
dot
employee dot
insert
[Music]
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
[Music]
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
[Music]
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay
so that's where exactly it works fine
for all of you
so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
fine
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted in this
particular tutorial we will help you to
connect your mongodb
with the front end that is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you
this connectivity where you can have the
mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the mongodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud
and we can have this connectivity with
our python which is running local to my
system so i show you what few important
things
one by one
so
why python mongodb
we understand mongodb is one of the most
important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely called nosql database
okay and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how python and mongodb works
together
okay
so you can
use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of
applications which can suits to
different type of ideas now here we have
one of the very very popular tool
available name called pi
so pi is actually the python
library which is a kind of a driver
through which you will be able to
connect with your mongodb and perform
basic operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment with
cluster and one of the very very popular
tool that is known as called mongodb
atlas so we'll be opening our website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb
atlas
i search for mongodb atlas that is
basically the mongodb
where i called database as a service
i'll be selecting the first option
and go to the start free because it's
going to offer you by default some 500
db of free space
i say sign up with google
going ahead and selecting this
okay i say accept
and say
submit
okay so it's starting up now
it'll ask you about a few things i would
rather say to select escape
and continue
well it will ask you about which
environment you would like to take so
i like to take this shared cluster i say
create cluster
now here it will take a while to get
yourself ready for you can see it is
offering the sandbox of having five
kilometer free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default cluster
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but let it be y d
for cluster zero i'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so i tell you what this
cluster is gonna give you
by default two child and one parent so
called a one master and two
child nodes where your cluster will get
ready
so you really don't need to set up any
kind of cluster in your local
environment and that is the best
environment i would suggest for
most of your development where your time
reduced
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting ready so once the
cluster is ready you will be seeing some
options where
will help you to create the clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment so in this environment you
will see there are some options they
have given you one by one
build up your cluster create a first
database user
add an ip address multiple options are
telling you now so how to setup so the
first build of the cluster which we have
anyways done next is called create your
first database user so select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and uh
i'm going to create a first new database
user and new database user
given that it is a name for admin
let's keep very simple username and
password admin
one two three so admin admin one two
three
yeah same
and say add user
now you can see
the user is
created now let's go back to the next
option
it's telling me the network access now
go here
and say
sorry
now say add ip address
and
i'll say allow access from anywhere
so that i can take it from anywhere
i say confirm
now it is telling me about the progress
i select this
and tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so i select this
and inside this i'll be selecting this
called collections
okay
and
it's getting
ready
so it is giving me some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data i'll say
add my own data give the database name
sl demo
give the collection name emp or employ
remember
database name sl demo or i can better
give the name called sldb
sldb and employ i say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it
so i think
we are all set
with this environment
okay
well once it is ready your collection is
also ready i'll go back and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then i'll be
clicking on this option called
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect
so it will say correct with the
shell or it will say connect with your
application correct using compass
i'll select
the python
python version
3.11 or later so certainly i'll be using
those version only
okay and
in this i'm having this
so i will be using this to connect with
my back end
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster
everyone so we are all ready now with
our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later
so here if i just go back and check
i have a god three point eight point six
which is python three version which is
available
so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's say three
point one one or later we can say three
point
six or later so there'll be no much
difference if i just see
even if i just talk about 3.4 there's
some change but here 3.6 or later
it is same so i have a 3.8.5
okay
so i can use the same option
so here in my
vs core editor i am using for my
development so here's a simple demo dot
pi i have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
i'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so i just go back and say
demo
py or i can say uh
py
demo
dot py
okay
and here if i want to go back and start
working on the development remember one
thing we need
first dependency called pi
okay what i need pi
and for this we have already
installed this dependency here
sometime back this is how you installed
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay
so
that's what we have taken this is
installed by so if you just see
you can go back and start
developing this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this
step number one you need to always say
import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called pi
so
as you can just say p by mo ngo
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import pymongo
and we're also saying import
client
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay after that we would like to go back
and use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
client and here i'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line i just take it
go back
and here
i'm pasting it
now here
i have to basically replace this
password with admin one two three
okay and we are all set
okay
now
once it is ready
we can go ahead and define db
equal to
cluster
and provide
which database you're talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call
sltb so i can just use the same sltp
there
and accordingly i can use
which collection i'm connecting it to so
accordingly i can go back and insert a
record okay everybody so i can see i
have got this
file with me going forward i have to
tell so this is what exactly the
connection url you have received now you
could define which database you are
working on
let me say tp equal to
cluster and we have to provide in
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to
db and here we just give the name call
employee
that was our collection name
so once it is ready then i have to
basically perform some insert operation
so i just say post
okay it's just a name equal to
and here
we just provide the properties
like i would say name
so
you know to the json based database so i
can just use the name
i say
armor
and once again i can just say
email
and
say i'm anthony email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
i have now i want to insert so i can
certainly say
collection dot because i want to insert
only one record you can see i have open
functions coming up collections dot
insert one and pass
post
is in parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so i'll be running this with python
by mobile.py
hit enter
now it's done let's confirm
here into my code i will just go back
and check
here
inside my
applications i can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay so fantastic so first example is
working perfectly fine how we can have
the records coming from the python and
insert it there like that i can have as
my number of records i can
add it
so how we can basically add if i want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here and in case if i
want to add more than one records so i
can just use call post one
i copy this url
and paste it below
and i say pause tool
i say
i'm saying
email
i'm going to at the rightmail.com and
rather than saying insert one
i can use
insert many and inside this i'll be
using this
square brackets
and pass
post
post one corner
post two
that's it okay so let's change the
little name because it's already there
let's insert
yeah records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
well now we have a total number of three
records are available
yeah there we go so records are added
perfect so like this you can have
as my number of records you can
basically add it in a similar one the
way we have basically used this i can
also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what
i'll go here
the way we have added this so in this
i'll just
these records which are added inside my
application i would not execute this
rather
i would like to go back and say
they are basically commenting now
and uh
in fact i would like to use this also
okay i will go here
and
find results
results equal to
same collection
dot
find if i want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
[Music]
okay
so let me say print
and pass
results
okay let's run this
okay so it'll print what
the results for me
okay
so
it is just printing what the cursor
object for me saying hey this is what a
record is available to me we can also
change in case if we do not think the
correct result is coming up we can also
go back and
we can use some alternative option that
is called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
with this for i can say result
okay in
results
and
print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay so what you can do you can run this
code again
i forgot to put this
semicolon here
or
we need to check
well that was my
requirement was so i'm having this
let's try to run this
well i got my result and this is what
the detail which i have available to me
so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code in this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want id or else
if you want name
you can basically pick that up
okay so if i just want that
id
the only id is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this file
now in a similar line you can also have
the option available because see when we
used to talk about confine it gets me a
lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this loop
but in case if you want to fetch the
individual records
i'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use fine
you can just
use find one
so what you can do is rather than using
find
i can also use one more option called
one and for which
i can come back
just remove this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file i can use fine
underscore you can see this option
called file one here we talk about
which are the properties you want to
skip and which of the properties you
want
so i can just use this option called
underscore
idle
okay colon
zero okay i just remove this
unless id zero and here
just print what
results
that's it let's run
so that'll try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that id which you've overridden it
will certainly not found it depends on
what you would like to take
so if i just say
this is having some issues but no
problem but you know it very well how it
basically takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity
to talk about delete
so for which what i will do is this i
just want to uncomment it
okay and i would like to insert some
records here
so here i want to add the id by my own
with name
so we already have this name
email
i have it i would like to use underscore
id
okay
so
we have this property called underscore
id
colon
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
i'm using
name and everything
it'll be taken let me say
one
here we try to say
user
two
okay so collections dot many result file
one i'm just deleting it all
and uh let's try to
execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so i have some records with ide one
zero one and one zero two
now here
i just delete this
and perform some actions here
here we say
results
equal to
collection
dot
delete
see the options are available delete one
and delete money it totally depends on
what you really want
okay so if i just talk about call delete
one it will be only deleting one record
delete money means where the matching
records are available you delete it
fine so i'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
matched cause quite possible name
sometimes match or whatever it is
just did delete many so the option is up
to you now for you want so the selected
name you have to offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is
so that will be offering it but there's
also one option available where you
would like to delete everything
are we clear so if you're applying to
delete everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete
underscore menu
let's check
great all records are deleted so as i
told you earlier also so delete many
means what it will delete all the
records whichever are present in your
code now
clear in a similar one if i want to
perform insert so you remember about we
have an option called what
insert many
and here
we would like to pass
post one
host two let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay
and next time what i want to perform
after adding this record i would like to
perform
the update part
okay
so
what i really wanted my update let's
take a look update means certain
properties i'm looking forward to be get
updated
okay
so
in case if i want to check the record
has to be updated i would first go and
check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update bar
here
i just
save collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see
update one here very simple
functionality
here you will go
and tell which id you would like to
perform an update
so i say
underscore id
colon
which i do want to consider i'm saying
one zero one
okay
and what else
so i just use another curly braces and i
say
sorry
dollar
set
and after this
i use this colon
use the curly braces
name
okay and
use whatever you want to use it so
suppose there is a user one i'm saying
user
one two three
okay
let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 1v3 is updated
perfect
so
your code is absolutely working fine so
you talk about either insert you talk
about what
update
you talk about anything it works so
insert update one
delete one
insert one as the name suggests they'll
be taking care about inserting updating
and deleting one one records but the
moment you use many they'll be
performing multiple records so this is a
very simple way like how the python will
connect with your mongodb in this video
we're gonna learn about the differences
between mysql and mongodb
now i'm sure you must have heard about
these database management systems
but do you exactly know what set them
apart
don't worry i'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there is no set schema to define
how the data is being stored in the
database
this causes lesser data migrations
but what exactly is mysql then
now mysql is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented
mysql is a relational database system
now this uses something called as a
structured query language and this is
used to access data which is stored in
the form of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and sql is developed and maintained by
oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between mysql and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure now mysql
requires you to define your tables and
columns before you can store anything
and every row in a table must have the
same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data in the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier mysql requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database now this schema is crucial in
case of mysql
on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
mysql uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set etc in case of
mongodb it supports a json query
language to work with data next up is
foreign keys
now mysql supports the usage of foreign
keys now if you don't know what exactly
a foreign key is then sql uses foreign
keys to link one table to another now
these foreign keys make data retrieval
easy especially when there are multiple
tables interlinked with one another in
case of mongodb there's no support for
foreign keys
next up is replication
now mysql supports the master slave and
the master master replication in this
setup data set from one master database
server can be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a shard
key
don't worry if you're not able to
understand these concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
concepts in detail
next up is scalability
now sql database can be scaled
vertically while mongodb can be scaled
both vertically and horizontally now
horizontal scaling means scaling by
adding more machines to your pool of
resources
while vertical scaling refers to scaling
by adding more power like for example
cpu or ram
moving ahead let's look at performance
now mysql is optimized for high
performance joins across multiple tables
while mongodb is optimized for right
performance
talking about community support some of
the popular github repositories on mysql
currently are mysql js mysql and then
there's mysql server and at the time of
writing there were about 222 000
repositories on github with 7 million
comments for mysql in case of mongodb
few popular github repositories are
mongodb slash and doctrine slash
mongodb and at the time of writing there
were about 177 000 repositories with
about 923 000 comments according to
google trends mysql is largely used
compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well
if your application requires multi-row
transactions
like for example an accounting system
then a relational database would be more
ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for
real-time analytics content management
internet of things mobile applications
and so on also mysql is a great choice
if you have structured data and need a
traditional relational database
in case of mongodb it is an ideal choice
if you have an unstructured set of data
so you could pick your choice and if
you're partial towards one dbms let us
know in the comment section below as to
why you like that particular dbms and so
with that we come to the end of this
session thank you so much for watching
this full course we hope you enjoyed
watching it if you have any queries let
us know in the comment section below
thanks again stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you